did you know that Facebook removed 2.29
billion content pieces from their
website after a record number of
complaints regarding hacked accounts
even the mighty Facebook cannot secure
its systems 100% such is a situation
when it comes to cyber security based on
recent events and future predictions
cyber crimes will cost organizations
worldwide a whopping $10.5 trillion
coming from just $3.5 trillion in 2050
so you can understand why it should not
come as a surprise that professionals
trained in cyber security are in skyh
high demand and will be for the
foreseeable future so what's better than
staying ahead of the curve and getting
traded in cyber security subscribe it
simply learn of course since we upload
Tech related content every day hit the
Bell icon to get notified whenever we
drop a new video today's video will be a
full course on cyber security for 20123
starting from the basics to the advanced
topics we provide a small introduction
to cyber security followed by explainers
regarding the career scope in this
domain and the job roles offered after
covering a few cyber security skills we
will learn about ethical hacking and
network masking techniques like vpns and
proxies further we delve into various
attacks like d attacks SQL injection and
cross-site scripting with live
demonstrations that you can carry out on
your own system for practice after
learning a bit more about different
cyber attacks we will learn about
cryptography covering topics like
encryption famous algorithms like RSA
and AES and hashing algorithms like s256
algorithms next we look at the Linux
based operating systems that you can use
for ethical hacking like K Linux and Par
security we then further dive into some
of the tools that cyber security
analysts use to secure their systems
finally we cover the industry's most
well-known certifications followed by a
series of interview questions to prepare
you for your first job in cyber security
so let's get
started meet an she often shops from
www. shoppingcart
to enable a faster and hasslefree
shopping
experience the required information is
stored in a server one day an received
an email which stated her eligibility
for a special discount voucher from
shopping cart.com in order to receive
the coupon code she was asked to fill in
her shopping cart.com account
credentials this didn't seem fishy to
her at the time as she thought it was
just an account verification step little
did she realize the danger she would be
facing she was knocked off her feet when
a substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how do you think this
happened well yes the email she received
was fake an's shopping cart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a Cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker could
Ann have prevented this attack indeed
she could have with the help of cyber
security cyber security involves
techniques that help in securing various
digital components networks data and
computer systems from unauthorized
digital access there are multiple ways
to implement cyber security depending on
the kind of network you are connected to
and the type of cyber attacks you are
prone to so let's take a look at the
various cyber attacks that an could have
been exposed to one of the most common
types of cyber attacks is a malware
attack like Trojan adwar and spyware to
name a few had Anne downloaded any
suspicious attachments online her system
could have gotten corrupted by certain
malicious viruses embedded within the
attachments next is a fishing attack the
type of Cyber attack which an
experienced here the hacker usually
sends fraudulent emails which appear to
be coming from a legitimate Source this
is done to install malware or to steal
sensitive data like credit card
information and login credentials
another type type of attack is the man
in the- Middle attack here the hacker
gains access to the information path
between Ann's device and the website
server the Hacker's computer takes over
Ann's IP address by doing so the
communication line between an and the
website is secretly intercepted this
commonly happens with unsecured Wi-Fi
networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here Ann's
password could have been CED by using
either common passwords or trying all
possible alphabetical combinations to
prevent future cyber attacks and sought
to implement a few cyber security
practices first she installed a firewall
as the name suggests it is a virtual
wall between Ann's computer and the
internet firewalls filter the incoming
and outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware
reinforcements secondly and implemented
honeypots just like how flowers attract
bees dummy computer systems called
honeypots are used to attract attackers
these systems are made to look
vulnerable in order to deceive attackers
and this in turn defends the real system
in addition to these she also decided to
use unique alpha numeric passwords
antivirus software and started avoiding
males from unknown Cinders that was
Ann's story cyber attacks are not just
confined to individuals but also to
public and private organizations the
cyber attacks carried out in such places
are more deadly and they result in
colossal losses motives of such attacks
are many starting from tampering with
crucial data to monetary gains let's
have a look at a few of the cyber
attacks that companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat a in this form of
attack hackers gave gain access to
networks for a prolonged period in order
to continuously gain confidential
information companies also witnessed the
denial service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL ection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases amidst a plethora of cyber
attacks it is indeed a challenge for
organizations with several networks and
servers to ensure complete Security this
is not an easy task and to help with
this cyber Security Professionals are
hired to work on identifying cyber
threats and securing a company's Network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored such professionals try to exp
Network's vulnerabilities just like how
a hacker would do but only to identify
those vulnerabilities and resolve them
for protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more apt a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization now there are several
reasons as to why you should learn cyber
security here we have the top 10 reasons
for the same at number 10 the reason we
have is basic requirements there is a
wrong notion that building a career in
cyber security is daunting well it is
not a fancy college degree is not at all
that it takes to become a successful
cyber security professional you can
Venture into the domain of cyber
security with some basic knowledge of it
and with an authorized cyber security
certification the overall eligibility
Criterion for the cyber security domain
is relaxing across the world it
professionals with cyber security
certifications are known to receive
higher salary packages certifications
are always given extra vitage in the
infosec field and it opens doors to
bigger
opportunities these cyber security
certifications can be opted by anyone as
the eligibility for these are very basic
cyber security certifications train
professionals and thus helps in Bridging
the Gap between the supply and demand of
skilled cyber security
professionals so don't take a step back
from learning cyber security thinking it
is a tedious process if you are a
fresher or a professional you can go
ahead with just these basic
requirements before moving on to our
next reason here is a question for you
all how many of you like mathematics
please let us know in the comment
section below I'm sure not everyone
loves mathematics and that is completely
okay when it comes to learning cyber
security and our ninth reason is
mathematics is not a concern for
learning cyber
security many of us find mathematics
challenging some have the aptitude for
dealing with numbers and some don't and
for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has maths
involved however you can take your
decision without any worries when it
comes to cyber security as the domain of
cyber security does not involve
mathematics so if maths is not your
strong point then choosing to learn
cyber security is a great choice this
can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking network security control and
coding to build a career in cyber
security our eighth reason is that cyber
security is a profession that helps
achieve the greater good cyber security
consists of a set of measures and
approaches that help companies and
individuals data from being compromised
and
stolen cyber Security Professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability cyber crimes are currently
on the rise with different types of
cyber attacks the threat to
organizations and individuals alike is
only growing by the day government
agencies police forces and cyber crime
cells tackling this threat however there
is more requirement for skilled cyber
security professionals who can protect
data and work for the greater good
therefore if you want to bring about a
positive impact and a meaningful
difference to the society we live in
then learning cyber security is a great
choice our seventh reason is that you
get to travel the world who doesn't love
to travel the globe learning cyber
security is a great reason especially
for those of you who aspire to travel
the the world with the lack of cyber
Security Professionals in the world
there are plenty of opportunities for
skilled experts to travel overseas to
Showcase their cyber security skills
which are in high demand The increased
demand for cyber Security Professionals
is not just restricted to one area but
to the entire world there are several
employment opportunities for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
so learning cyber security can open new
doors for you overseas as well our sixth
reason is very interesting and that is
the fact that you get to work with
secret agencies and high-profile
ones like other
professionals cyber Security
Professionals also have the opportunity
to work with several prestigious
multinational companies and big giants
like Google Dell Accenture and others
however a cyber security professional's
career opportunities can go beyond mnc's
and they might get the opportunity to
work with top government secret agencies
like mosad NSA ni FBI and so on so what
are you waiting for become a cyber
security expert and showcase your skills
to grab the chance to work with these
top agencies our fifth reason is it is
never too late to begin with there are
very few professions that give you the
Liberty to begin late and one such
profession is cyber security it is never
too late to realize that you want to
become a cyber security expert many
people work as cyber security
professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about
it you could also join cyber security
courses that train you irrespective of
your
age as long as you have good cyber
security skills there is no need to
worry about job security however late it
is our fourth reason is cyber security
is an evergreen
industry cyber security has gradually
become an evergreen industry in the
current times with the onset of the co
pandemic business businesses are moving
online and shifting to cloud storage the
demand for cyber security is at its
peak there is a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can Safeguard
Digital Data hence we can be rest
assured that cyber security is here to
stay and this domain is only going to
grow in the coming
years according to cyber security
Ventures the number of Internet users
will hit a whooping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this reveals the growing demand for
cyber Security Professionals across the
globe digitalization is taking place
across several
Industries a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front so now is the right time
if you are looking to learn and start a
career in cyber security before moving
to our top three reasons to learn cyber
security here's some crucial information
for you
all as you know with relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career and here we are to help
you with that you can check out Simply
learns cyber security expert Masters
program to equip you with the necessary
skills to become an expert in this
rapidly growing
domain training for highly short after
certifications like compa Security Plus
CH cism and cissp is at the Forefront of
this course preparing you for the
industries best jobs so what are you
waiting for get certified with simply
loarn and grow your career in cyber
security
today so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers according to the
US Bureau of Labor Statistics the
employment of information security
analysts is projected to grow 33% from
2020 to 2030 much faster than the
average for all
occupations with the world turning
digital there is a dire need for
companies to hire cyber Security Experts
who can protect and Safeguard sensitive
data as firms work to improve their
cyber security structure they are also
hiring several cyber Security Experts to
design Implement and maintain the Cyber
Security
Solutions cyber security jobs are not
limited to the it domain many security
positions are found at companies outside
of it including Industries like media
sports or Finance to name a few this
emphasizes on the fact that a cyber
security export is exposed to several
job opportunities from different types
of companies across the
globe our second reason for you to learn
cyber security is the good salary
package it
offers salaries play a crucial part in
any job that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat pain
paychecks cyber Security Experts are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world organizations
are willing to pay Skyhigh salaries for
these cyber security exports there is a
lack of skilled cyber Security
Professionals and this is another reason
cyber Security Experts are paid
well the salaries of cyber Security
Professionals are still expected to grow
in the coming times owing to the high
demand salaries and cyber security
have a high growth potential and if you
are a skilled cyber security
professional you can always negotiate
your
salary finally a top reason to learn
cyber security is that you will have a
job that never gets boring and a domain
that offers unlimited potential for
personal
growth several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenges due to their mundane
work and also due to stagnation at work
these reasons play a major role when it
comes to a professional quitting their
job however a job rule in cyber security
tackles these reasons to an extent and
that is why we have this reason at
number one cyber security is a domain
that is constantly evolving and so are
the nature of cyber attacks hackers are
always trying to develop new methods to
get to your data they develop new
exploits regularly and hence as a cyber
security professional you will face
interesting challeng Alles to find
Optimal Solutions for new exploits you
will have new puzzles to solve a cyber
security career is not going to be
stale along with failures you will also
be exposed to new and interesting
discoveries to keep yourself updated in
this field and to tackle cyber attacks
you should be in a position to outsmart
the hackers being in the field of cyber
security allows you to constantly
upskill and enhance your knowledge and
experience it also ensures that your
Learning Journey will never stop with
the world turning virtual cyber attacks
are constantly flooding new headlines Co
19 accelerated the current digital
transformation and the year 2020
witnessed several data breaches since
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives it is no surprise
that the need for skilled cyber Security
Professionals is increasing on that note
hey everyone welcome yet to another
exciting video by simply learn which
will take you through the top cyber
security career your options available
today but before we begin if you're new
here and haven't subscribed already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and
that Bell icon for interesting Tech
videos every day there is a significant
lack of skilled cyber security
professionals who can tackle the cyber
security challenges face daily hence a
career in cyber security is demanding
and equally rewarding finding the right
career path in the cyber security
industry isn't always easy here we are
here to help you with that there are a
few prerequisites for a career in cyber
security the basic one being a
bachelor's degree in a subject relating
to cyber security however if you don't
have a relevant degree you can always
take up relevant cyber security
certifications and Kickstart your cyber
security Journey a few other skills like
networking knowledge of operating
systems and Cloud security are required
to start and grow your cyber security
career you can check out our video on
the top five cyber security skills to
know more cyber security jobs vary from
entry level to Executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security Pats available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience here let us have a look at
the top five cyber security job roles
today the first job role is that of a
network engineer Network Engineers
construct and administer a company's
computer networks they are responsible
for installing ing configuring and
supporting Network equipment they also
configure and maintain firewalls
switches and routers this entry level
cyber security job can help you start
your journey to become an ethical hacker
the annual average salary of a network
engineer in the US is
$85,900 and in India it is around
510,000
rupees second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary Duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
Implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the Cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the US an
information security analyst earns $
89,1 140 annually and in India they earn
64275 rupees third on our list is
ethical hacker they're also known as
penetration testers they are Network
Security Consultants to identify and
exploit system vulnerabilities just like
how a hacker would do they probe and
test the network using various
penetration tools and software they also
design new penetration tools and
document the test results in the US a
certified ethical hacker earns around
$93,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job roll that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the US make a handsome sum
of
$124,000 a year on an average and in
India they make nearly 21 lakh 80,000
rupees and finally fifth on our list is
Chief Information Security Officer ciso
they are senior level officers in an
organization they ensure the safety of
the information they develop Implement
and maintain information security and
risk management programs they also
interact with stakeholders and regularly
brief them with information security
concerns the average annual salary of a
chief information security officer in
the states is a whopping
$165,000 annually and in India it is 22
lak
22845 rupees several companies are
looking for skilled cyber Security
Professionals Phillips seamons Google
Microsoft and GE to name a few with
passion the right amount of experience
and relevant certifications you can grow
your cyber security career you can check
out Simply learn cyber security expert
master's program to equip you with the
necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more according to cyber crime magazine
by cyber security Ventures globally
there would be nearly 3.5 million
unfilled cyber security jobs by 2021 and
the number of Internet users will hit a
popping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this shows the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber Security Professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill
set many of you out there might be
waiting to become a cyber security
professional but are unsure of how to go
about it and what skills you would need
to get a cyber security job
not to worry we are here to help you
with that after extensive research we
have come up with the top five skills
that will help you get into the field of
cyber security let's have a look at
these skills
individually first we have networking
and system administration the number one
skill you need to have to enter the
field of cyber security is computer
networking networking is the backbone of
the internet it is imperative that you
have an in-depth understanding of
networking to start a career in cyber
security a network is a group of
interconnected devices and networking is
the art of understanding how data is
sent transmitted and received amongst
these
devices you need to know various routing
protocols the tcpip and OSI models
govern networking The OSI model is
comparatively newer basically in these
models all the protocols are grouped
into layers and work together to help
you receive data on your device sent
from a server learning networking will
help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data you can take
up networking certifications like
Security Plus and Cisco CCNA to gain a
strong networking
Foundation another skill that be
beneficial for you is to Master System
Administration if you think about it all
of us are CIS admins at some
level system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit carry out a trial
and error method and give yourself small
tasks like recovering deleted files or
monitoring old viruses on a VM explore
new techniques put them into use and
expand your
knowledge let us now move on to our
second skill knowledge of operating
systems and virtual
machines to become a cyber security
professional you need to have a strong
knowledge of operating environments such
as Windows Linux and Mac OS
cyber Security Professionals largely use
Linux and it comes with several tools to
learn operating systems go ahead and set
up and use Virtual machines that is VMS
and play around with them this will help
you gain hands-on experience as a cyber
security expert you should be
comfortable working on any OS WMS allow
you to train and research in an isolated
environment and help you maximize your
skills the next point to remember is to
know Ki Linux it is the most widely
known Linux distribution for ethical
hacking and penetration
testing it comes with several hundred
tools related to penetration testing
malware analysis security research
computer forensics and so on Kali
contains several projects and you can
learn a lot another good thing about
Kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away remember that Linux is the
backbone of cyber security and a
commonly asked topic for cyber security
interviews especially for pentesting
roles moving on to our third skill our
third skill is network security control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network it is
simple you can only Safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a fire W is a hardware or software that
blocks incoming or outgoing traffic from
the internet to your
computer firewalls are required to
secure a network as a cyber security
expert you must be able to leverage a
firewall to filter and prevent
unauthorized traffic onto the network in
addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intrusion prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote
access an intrusion detection system IDs
is is designed to detect unauthorized
access to a system it is used together
with a firewall and a router you should
be able to operate the IDS and recognize
any security policy violations and
malicious traffic on the
network as many of you may have used a
VPN is a connection between a VPN server
and a VPN client it is a secure tunnel
across the
internet moving on next up we have an
interesting skill any idea what that is
if yes boss and leave a comment as to
what you think the next skill will be if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more and before we jump into this skill
if you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up fourth skill
on our list is
coding so you might be wondering if
coding is really required to become a
cyber security professional well it is
true that not all cyber Security
Professionals have or need coding
skills however having zero coding
knowledge May limit your opportunities
in the future knowing a couple of
programming languages will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking
techniques so as seen on your screens
these are the best programming languages
to learn to make your cyber security
career
worthwhile we have C and C++ the C
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems C and C++ are
low-level programming languages that you
need to know as a cyber security
professional on the other hand python is
a highlevel programming language that is
becoming popular among cyber Security
Experts today knowing python will give
you an upper hand in your career it will
help you identify and fix
vulnerabilities JavaScript is another
highlevel programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages a good
advantage of knowing JavaScript is that
you can prevent cross-site scripting
attacks from occurring as in these
attacks the attacker implants malicious
code in a web application speaking of
PHP because most of the websites are
created using PHP learning it will help
you defend against
Intruders similarly HTML is another
language cyber Security Professionals
should understand as most websites use
it and it is one of the easiest
languages to learn another programming
language that you can use is goang it is
great for cryptography you can solve
various cyber security problems with it
then we have SQL that is structured
query language attackers use this
language to damage the stored data one
such example is the SQL injection attack
hence having a good understanding of SQL
will be highly beneficial another Point
we'd like to highlight is to have
knowledge of Assembly Language this will
help you become a cyber security
engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it it in
the cyber security domain you can't just
lock into a single language and hence it
is advised that you're acquainted with a
couple of them you can also do a crash
course for these languages and learn
them hence determine the best
programming language for your cyber
security role and get familiar with the
basics moving on our fifth skill on the
list is cloud security there is a
growing demand for cyber Security
Professionals with Cloud security skills
in the coming
years companies are on the look of for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
and Azure more organizations look to
Cloud infrastructure to store data and
run
applications this includes the
implementation of policies and
technologies that protect cloud-based
systems and
devices just like application
development security Cloud security also
involves building secure systems from
the start companies want professionals
who can manage the cloud security tools
to ident identify and prevent any Cloud
breaches people with experience and
knowledge in managing big platforms such
as Microsoft Azure AWS and the gcp are
in high demand now that we have seen the
top five cyber security skills let us go
through a set of additional skills that
can help you get into the cyber security
field remember that to become a
successful cyber security expert you
must possess a rich and diverse skill
set so in a list of additional skills
first we have risk
analysis identify ing risks even before
their arrival is a great skill cyber
Security Professionals are required to
identify manage and mitigate risks risk
management and mitigation is a skill set
that is going to be highly in demand in
the coming
years next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes here in demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data
recovery next on a list list is security
incident handling and
response as a cyber security expert you
must be prepared to handle any
forthcoming threat or violating an
organization security policy by
following an updated incident response
plan your team can proactively protect
your data and minimize the
damages in security Incident Management
you are required to identify manage
record and analyze security threats in
real time a security incident can be an
active threat or a successful compromise
of dat or an attempted intrusion it can
also be incidents like DS attacks
fishing APS ransomware and many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management S tools
and
services moving on we have security
audit security auditing is an internal
check that is carried out to find flaws
in the organization's information system
you must be able to conduct a review of
the organization's adherence to
regulatory guidelines security audit and
compliance knowledge are very crucial as
any M of Regulatory Compliance could
lead to Hefty penalties soon
organizations will need people who are
more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the
regulations finally we have loss and
regulations and often overlooked cyber
security aspect there are several cyber
security laws and regulations and if you
break these laws intentionally or not it
doesn't matter as you will still be
charged these laws Define how you can
use the internet and it also defines how
people can be protected from becoming
the victims of cyber crimes knowing
these laws and regulations and following
the best practice will make you ethical
at your job and this will in turn be
good for your organization so those were
our list of additional skills apart from
these make sure you stay updated with
new hacks and learn new tools as cyber
security is ever
evolving another important skill apart
from these technical skills is your soft
skills having a set of good soft skills
will help you bag your dream job we have
a video on the top five soft skills that
will help you grow in your career do
watch that and incorporate those skills
as well we humans are highly techsavvy
in today's times with the extensive use
of the internet and modern Technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our Digital Data such as
net banking information account
credentials and medical reports to name
a few have you heard about the deadly
one to cry ransomware attack the attack
happened in May 2017 in Asia and then it
spread across the world within a day
more than 230,000 computers were
infected across 150 countries the one
cry crypto worm encrypted the data and
locked the users out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of $300 to $600
in Bitcoin the users who used the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a toll on every sector top
tier organizations like Itachi Nissan
and FedEx had to put their businesses on
hold as their systems were affected too
now now this is what you call a Cyber
attack to prevent such attacks cyber
security is implemented we can Define
cyber security as the practice of
protecting networks programs computer
systems and their components from
unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking hacking refers to exploiting
weaknesses in a computer network to
obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems this
is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives let's have a look
at three different types of hackers
black hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for a
monetary gain on the contrary we have wh
hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the gry Hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black these hackers
discover vulnerabilities in a system and
report it to the system's owner which is
a good act but they do this without
seeking the owner's approval sometimes
gry hat hackers also ask for money in
return for the spotted
vulnerabilities now that you have seen
the different types of hackers let's
understand more about the hacking that
is legal and valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story Dan runs a
Trading Company he does online training
with the money his customers invest
everything was going well and Dan's
business was booming until a hacker
decided to hack the company servers the
hacker stole the credentials of various
trading accounts he asked for a lump
some Ransom in exchange for the stolen
credentials Dan took the Hacker's words
lightly and didn't pay the hacker as a
result the hacker withdrew money from
various customers accounts and Dan was
liable to pay back the customers Dan
lost a lot of money and also the trust
of his customers after this incident Dan
gave a lot of thought as to what could
have gone wrong with the security
infrastructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable his systems were before the
hacker penetrated into the network this
was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
and identifies the vulnerabilities in
his Network before an outsider does to
do this job he hired an ethical hacker
John John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad John in this scenario exposed the
vulnerabilities in the existing Network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases let us look at
these phases step by step with respect
to how Jon our ethical hacker will act
before launching an attack the first
step Jon takes is to gather all the
necessary information about the
organization's system that he intends to
attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like inmap
and hping for this purpose John then
tries to spot the vulnerabilities if any
in the Target system using tools like
inmap and nexos this is the scanning
phase now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after JN makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
but by installing back doors in the
Target system the Metasploit tool helps
him with this this phase is called
maintaining access Jon is a brilliant
hacker hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase John documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack looking into
the report Dan is now able to take a
call and see how to protect his
organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think Jon is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like John then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh you must have reasonably
good knowledge of programming languages
such as HTML PHP python SQL and
JavaScript networking is the base of
ethical hacking hence you should be good
at it ethical hackers should be well
aware of security laws so that they
don't misuse their skills finally you
must have a global certification on
ethical hacking to successfully bag a
position of an ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certific ification C CompTIA
pentest plus and licensed penetration
tester certification to name a few
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert Masters program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security
expert when it comes to web app hacking
It generally refers to the exploitation
of applications by HTTP which can be
done by manipulating the applications
via its graphical user interface this is
done by tampering with the uniform
resource identifier also known as a URI
or tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators post these online vain
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversations or produse the back
end of your personal website usually
disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive person personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertex transfer protocol or
HTTP so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like GS
attacks SN flooding ping flood port scan
and social engineering attacks in the
area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
network packets without having to be in
the same building where the network is
located as wireless networks communicate
through radio waves a hacker can easily
sniff the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer
systems coming to our main focus for
today let us have a look at the top five
most essential ethical hacking tools to
be used in
2021 at the top of the chain lies
nmap nmap which stands for network
mapper is a free and open-source utility
for network discovery and security
auditing many systems and network
administrators also find it useful for
tasks such as Network inventory managing
service upgrade schedules and monitoring
host or service uptime it is most
beneficial in the early stages of
ethical hacking where a hacker must
figure the possible entry point to a
system before running rning the
necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage any insecure
openings and thus breach the
device nmap users raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in Ed and
dozens other characteristics it was
designed to rapidly scan large networks
but works F against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked
device next on our list we have
Metasploit the Metasploit framework is a
very powerful tool that can be used by
cyber criminals as well as ethical
hackers to probe systematic
vulnerabilities on both networks and
servers because it's an open- Source
framework it can be easily customized
and used with most operating
systems with Metasploit the ethical
hacking team can use readymade or custom
code and introduce it into a network to
probe for weak spots as another flavor
of threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions once a particular
vulnerability is identified and the
necessary exploit is fed into the system
there are a host of options for the
hacker depending on the vulnerability
hackers can even run root commands from
the terminal allowing complete control
over the activities of the compromise
system as well as all the personal data
stored on the
device a big advantage of Metasploit is
the ability to run full-fledged scans on
the target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
softwares having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the
list moving on we have the acuns
framework AC unetic is an endtoend web
security scanner which offers a 360°
view of an organization security it is
an application security testing tool
that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web
assets the need to be able to test
application in depth and further than
traditional vulnerability management
tools has created a market with several
players in the application security
space actic can detect over 7,000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross- site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other outof band
vulnerabilities it can scan all pages
web apps and complex web applications
running HTML 5 and JavaScript as as well
it also lets you scan complex
multi-level forms and even password
protected areas of the
site actic is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as sast scanners sast tools
only work during development and only
for specific languages and have a
history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas Dynamic testing tools
also known as D have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal
issues next on our list we have air
gedon this is a multi-use bash script
used for Linux systems to hack and audit
wireless networks like our everyday
Wi-Fi router and its counterparts along
with being able to launch denial of
service attacks on compromis networks
this multi-purpose wi-fi hacking tool
has very rich features which support
multiple methods for wi-fi hacking
including WPS hacking modes WP attacks
handshake captures evil twin and so much
more it usually needs an external
network adapter that supports monitor
mode which is necessary to be able to
capture Wireless traffic that Traverse
the air
channels thanks to its open source
nature air Garden can be used with
multiple Community plugins and add-ons
thereby increasing its Effectiveness
against a wide variety of routers both
in the 2.4 GHz and the 5 GHz band
finally at number five we have John the
Ripper John the Ripper is an open-source
password security auditing and the
password recovery tool which is
available for many operating
systems John the Ripper jumbo supports
hundred of hash and Cipher types
including for user passwords of
operating systems web apps database
servers encrypted keys and document
files some of the key features of the
tool include offering multiple modes to
speed up the password password cracking
automatically deselecting the hashing
algorithm used by the passwords and the
ease of running and configurating the
tool to make it password cracking
easier it can use dictionary attacks
along with regular brute forcing to
speed up the process of cracking the
correct password without wasting
additional resources the word list being
used in these dictionary attacks can be
used by the users and allowing for a
completely customizable
process we also have a few honor
mentions in our list that just missed
the cut netsparker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported
vulnerabilities the bup suit
professional is one of the most popular
penetration testing and vulnerability
finder tools and it's used for checking
web application security the term burp
as it is commonly known is a proxy based
tool which is used to evaluate the
security of web- based application and
to do Hands-On testing moving away from
websites and applications yasak is a
free and op Source packet analyzer which
was launched in 2006 it is used for
Network troubleshooting analysis
software and Communications protocol
development and education it captures
Network traffic on the local network and
stores data for offline analysis ysha
captures Network traffic from ethernet
Bluetooth wireless networks and frame
relay
connections now that we learn about the
different types of tools that can be
used when conducting an ethical hacking
audit let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits being able to identify defects
from an attacker's perspective is gain
gamechanging since it displays all the
potential Avenues of a possible hack one
can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors another advantage of hiring
ethical hackers is the ability to
preemptively fix possible weak points in
a company comp's Network infrastructure
as seen on many occasions a real breach
will cause loss of data and irreparable
damage to the foundation of an
organization being able to gauge such
shortcomings before they become public
and can be used exploited is a benefit
most organizations make use
of this is not to imply that such
security audits are only beneficial to
the organization paying for it when
coming across companies that provide
certain Services a reliable third party
security audit goes a long way in
instilling trust and confidence over
their craft if the ethical hackers
cannot find any major vulnerabilities
that can be leveraged by hackers it just
accentuates the technical billin of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount Jude is waiting at
the airport to hop on her flight back
home when she realizes that she missed
making an important Bank payment she
connects her laptop to the public Wi-Fi
at the airport and goes ahead to carry
out the bank transaction everything goes
well and Jude completes her
transaction after a couple of days she
was wiped off her feet when she learned
that her bank account was subjected to a
Cyber attack and a hefty amount was
wiped from her account after getting in
touch with the bank Authority she
learned that her account was hacked at
the airport she then realized that the
public Wi-Fi she used might have caused
her this trouble Jude wishes that had
her bank transfer escaped the Hacker's
eyes she would not have been a victim of
a Cyber attack back Bank officials
advise her to use a VPN for future
transactions especially when connecting
to an open or public network like most
of us Jude had come across the term VPN
several times but didn't know much about
it and little did she think that the
repercussions of not using a VPN would
be this bad let's understand how the
hacker would have exploited Jude's
transaction in the absence of a VPN in
this process judee's computer first
connects to the internet service
provider ISP which provides access to
the internet she sends her details to
the bank server using her IP address
Internet Protocol address or IP address
is a unique address that recognizes a
particular device be it a laptop or
smartphone on the internet when these
details pass through the public network
the hacker who passively watches the
network traffic intercepts it this is a
passive Cyber attack where the hacker
collects Jude's Bank details without
being detected
more often or not in such an attack
payment information is likely to be
stolen the targeted data here are the
victim's username passwords and other
personal information such an unsecured
connection exposed Jude's IP address and
Bank details to the hacker when it
passed through the public network so
would Jude have been able to secure her
transaction with the help of a VPN well
yes picture Jude's Bank transaction to
be happening in a tunnel that is
invisible to the hacker in such a case
the hacker will not be able to spot a
transaction and that is precisely what a
VPN does a virtual private Network more
often known as bpn creates a secure
tunnel between your device and the
internet for using a VPN Jude's First
Step would be to install software-based
technology known as the VPN client on
her laptop or smartphone that would let
her establish a secure connection the
VPN client connects to the Wi-Fi and
then to the ISP
here the VPN client encrypts Jude's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure next
the VPN client establishes a VPN tunnel
within the public network that connects
to the VPN server the VPN tunnel
protects judee's information from being
intercepted by the hacker Jude's IP
address and actual location are changed
at the VPN server to enable a private
and secure connection finally the VPN
server connects to judee's bank server
in the last step where the encrypted
message is decrypted this way judee's
original IP address is hidden by the VPN
and the VPN tunnel protects her data
from being hacked this explains how VPN
makes your data anonimous and secure
when it passes through the public
network and the difference between a
normal connection and a VPN connection
after learning about this Jude was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the the future this is also
applicable to each one of us even if you
work remotely or connect to public Wi-Fi
using a VPN is the safest option in
addition to providing a secure encrypted
data transfer vpns are also used to
disguise your whereabouts and give you
access to Regional web content VPN
servers act as proxies on the internet
this way your actual location cannot be
established VPN enables you to spoof
your location and switch to a server to
another country and thereby change your
location for example by doing so you can
watch any content on Netflix that might
be unavailable for your region meet
Jonathan he is an investigative
journalist who occasionally researches
and publishes news articles contrary to
the government's
ideologies on one such occasion he could
not access a Global News website dealing
with uncensored information it seemed
his IP was blocked from visiting the
news website with his IP blocked
Jonathan turned to a popular proxy
service that was able to unblock the
news website thereby allowing an open
internet to all users just like how your
friend gives a proxy attendance for you
a proxy server serves as a standin user
to keep the real client private but what
is a proxy let's understand it's working
by taking a look at how Jonathan was
able to access geolock content without
much hassle a proxy server acts as a
Gateway or intermediary server between a
user and its destination website when
Jonathan wasn't able to access the news
website he connected his system to a
global proxy server once connected the
proxy server assigns a new IP address to
Jonathan system an IP address of a
different country where the website is
not censored following this process
whenever Jonathan visits that website
the website administrators see the new
IP address assigned via proxy server and
sees no reason to deny access to their
account once the proxy server is able to
access the website it's passed on to
Jonathan's system via the same channel
regarding accessibility to proxy servers
you must first set it up on your
computer device or network next check
the steps required for your computer or
network as each operating system has its
setup procedures in most cases however
setup intels using an automated
configuration script there are plenty of
free proxy services available on the
internet however the safety of such
proxies is rarely verified most free
proxies will provide an IP address and a
relevant port for connection purposes
reputed proxy providers like smart proxy
and WR data that run on subscription
models will most likely provide
credentials to log into when
establishing the connection this extra
step access authentication that verifies
an existing subscription on the proxy
provider server unlike free providers
that are open to all when it comes to
hiding IP addresses many people consider
a VPN to be the primary solution while
that's true up to some extent there are
a few things proxies do differently in
the case of vpns extra encryption is
also carried out to create a secure
tunnel between the user's device and a
VPN server a VPN is usually much faster
more secure thanks to multiple layers of
encryption and has little to no downtime
proxies tend to be comparatively unsafe
with the service owners having the exact
IP address of the end user and having no
guarantees regarding downtimes and
reliability if you want to know more
about how vpns work do watch how Jude
could have protected her banking
credentials using vpns in our detailed
video linked above now let's take a
small quiz to check how much we have
learned what can a VPN connection
provide that a proxy service cannot a
new IP address address B multiple layers
of encryption C access to geoblock
content D authentication credentials
think about it and leave your answers
Below in the comment section and three
lucky winners will receive Amazon gift
vouchers what about the benefits of a
proxy service though besides allowing
access to blocked content proxies can
serve as an efficient firewall system
they can also filter content from
thirdparty websites allowing control
over internet usage
in many cases browsing speeds are
stabilized compared to vanilla Internet
thanks to proper optimization of the Bas
proxy server the element of privacy
proxies provides is highly lucrative to
people looking to hide their actual IP
address from as many crying eyes as
possible one can easily argue the
benefits of using vpns over proxies for
added security measures however a few
basic tasks don't warrant maximum
privacy for the user's side as in other
cases for example many consumers
worldwide find proxy Services more
convenient since all major operating
systems starting from Windows to Android
allow proxy configuration without the
hassle of installing new applications as
is in the case of a VPN in addition
there are services online that function
as web proxies allowing users to access
block content without any setup from
their end they can enter the target URL
and the web proxy will route data from
its physical server
this level of freedom is hard to come by
in the case of vpns making proxies an
ideal solution for casual browsing with
the next generation of Internet
exchanges focused on maximum privacy and
security a variety of ways have been
enforced to maintain them as such
censorship has been shifted from the
streets to the digital domain it forces
the standard citizen to derive
alternative ways to maintain anonymity
major weapon in this battle for privacy
and security is the T browser an
independent browser meant to browse the
internet while relaying information
through the Tor Network it serves as a
meaningful alternative to the standard
internet browsing habits to better
understand the purpose of this browser
and suchar you must learn about the work
of the T Network featuring its own
routing protocol the top browser is an
easy way to maintain anonymity while
browsing without emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the T Network and its
significance in the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
T directories in order to circumvent
government
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the to browser and the
distinct advantages the tour Network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a t to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the Tor Browser
anonymization features in action
let's move on to learning about the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open-source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the Tor was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid Rising development and
innovation of digital products has given
way to frequent data breaches and cyber
thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber security T
is one such underground Network that was
implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the to
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the to network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user request Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the T Network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different to relays
within the network the T Network uses an
onion routing technique for transmitting
data hence the original name of onion
router to operate within the tornet
Network a user has to install the to
browser any address or information
requested using the browser is
transmitted through the T Network it has
its own feature set which we will be
covering over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the to network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the the sender has data package to
transmit which is done directly over a
line of communication with either a
receiving party or a server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable moreover it becomes very easy
to trace the origin of such requests on
many occasions websites with
questionable and controversial content
are blocked from the ISP this is
possible since the ISP is able to detect
and spy on user information pass ing
through the network apart from isps
there is a steady chance of your private
information being intercepted by hackers
unfortunately easy detection of the
source and contents of a web request
make entire network extremely vulnerable
for people who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the to browser
installed on the client system the
network sends the information to node
one's IP address which encrypts the
information and pass passes it on to
node 2's address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node 3
address this is the last address which
is also known as the exit node this last
node decrypts the encrypted data and
finally relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user the to network
of confiscates user IP addresses from
unwanted surveillance by keeping the
users's request untraceable with
multiple servers touching the data it
makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
to works let us learn more about the T
browser the T browser was developed by a
nonprofit organization as a part of the
T project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced the to browser is
a a browser Fork from the popular
Firefox that anonymizes your web traffic
using the to network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right
solution before the top browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers in tour and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the T
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the to network
is the availability of onion links on
only a small portion of the worldwide
web is available to the general public
we have the Deep Web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the to network onion is a special
used top level domain which designates
an anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activities and sales onion
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over tour
is slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users to browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regime teams that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced t as a Cornerstone
of democracy and researchers are hard at
work at improving TOS anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser
over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network outing the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the T browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference to is completely free and
open source all of the code for the
browser and the network can be audited
and has been cleared for security
concerns when it comes to VPN there are
many different brands which have open
source clients but the same cannot be
said for their counterparts some have
partly open source while some have
completely locked up their code so that
they cannot be stolen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the cender it goes through all of
those relay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one: one
between the client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multier encryption
of T is consistent if you use T browser
every single request passes through the
same layer of encryption and follows the
same routing protocol in the case of a
VPN different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multihop
some prefer a single onetoone connection
and these kind of differences make the
choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the T Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward for inance in
the case of vpns many such VPN are
hosted by adware companies or are being
monitored by Central governments to note
the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of the T browser and its
routing let us take a look at how the T
browser can anonymize and protect our
internet
usage on opening up the tour browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the to
network before we start our
browsing so let's press connect
and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome currently is showing as Navi
Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the tour browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the T browser will be little delayed and
the speed will be hampered because of
the multiple layers of encryption like
we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the outof the Box settings that come
inbuilt with the tour browser similarly
we have an option of cleaning up the
data let's say if you want to refresh
your location and you want to use a
different ID for the next browsing
session if you just restart it once
and we can have to check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this
time as you can see we have Netherlands
right now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that
you cannot be tracked when in browsing
the internet like we discussed we have
some onion links that can only be used
on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the T
browser as you can see we have opened
the hidden wiki which is available only
on the tour Network this is kind of an
alternative Wikipedia website where we
can find articles to read and more
information to learn similarly we have
another onion link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is
specifically for dark web
members this operates over the T Network
and this is used by mostly journalists
and people who want to anonymize is
their internet transactions when it
comes to dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall this would make
our properly easy accessible to
trespassers and robbers and place our
homes at at Great risk right hence
fencing our property helps safeguarded
and keeps trespassers at Bay similarly
imagine our computers and networks
without protection this would increase
the probability of hackers infiltrating
our networks to overcome this challenge
just like how boundary walls protect our
houses a virtual wall helps Safeguard
and secure our devices from Intruders
and such a wall is known as a firewall
firewalls are security devices that
filter the incoming and outgoing traffic
within a private Network for example if
you were to visit your friend who lives
in negated Community you would First
Take permission from the security guard
the security guard would check with your
friend if you should be allowed to entry
or not if all is well your access is
granted on the other hand the security
guard would not Grant permission to a
trespasser looking to enter the same
premises here the entry access depends
solely on your friend the resident's
discretion
the role of the security guard in this
case is similar to that of a firewall
the firewall works like a gatekeeper at
your computer's entry point which only
welcomes incoming traffic that it has
been configured to accept firewalls
filter the network traffic within your
network and analyzes which traffic
should be allowed or restricted based on
a set of rules in order to spot and
prevent cyber attacks your computer
communicates with the internet in the
form of network packets that hold
details like the source address
destination address address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports a firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network this
is when a firewall comes to your Rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet the firewall
rejects the malicious data pack and thus
protects your network from hackers on
the other hand traffic from trusted
websites is allowed access to your
network this way the firewall carries
out quick assessments to detect malware
and other suspicious activities thereby
protecting your network from being
susceptible to a Cyber attack firewalls
can either be Hardware or software
software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called host firewall meanwhile Hardware
firewalls are equipments that are
established between the Gateway and your
network linky routers are a good example
of a hardware firewall besides this
there are other types of firewalls
designed based on their traffic
filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a the packet
filtering firewall if the incoming
Network traffic is not for the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the stateful inspection
firewall these types of firewalls not
only examine each Network packet but
also checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection such firewalls are also
referred to as Dynamic packet filtering
firewalls our next type of firewall is
called a proxy firewall this drw close
comparison to how you give proxy
attendance for a friend like how you
take the authority to represent your
friend the proxy firewall pretends to be
you and interacts with the internet they
come between you and the internet and
thereby prevents direct connections this
protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they're
also known as application Level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content it's the year
2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer after a
long gaming session Richard tries to
shut it down but find some random text
file on the desktop that says Ransom
note the text file mentioned how a
hacking group had encrypted Richard's
game files in private documents and he
had to pay a ransom of $500 worth of
bitcoin in a specified Bitcoin address
Richard quickly checked his files only
to see them being encrypted and
unreadable this is the story of how the
Tesla Crypt ransomware spread in 2015
which affected thousands of Gamers
before releasing the master key used for
encrypting the files so so what is
ransomware for Richard to be targeted by
such an attack he must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link both of them
can function as gateways for a
ransomware breach ransomware is a type
of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
the password a text files available to
the victim explaining how to make the
ransom payment and unlock the files for
it just like Richard found the ransom
note text file on his desktop even after
the money has been paid there's no
guarantee that the hackers will send the
decryption key or unlock the files but
in certain sensitive situations victims
make the payment hoping for the best
having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
Richard an opportunity to learn more
more about this and he began his
research on the topic the spread of
ransomware mostly starts with fishing
attacks to know more about fishing
attacks click the link in the button
above users tend to click on unknown
links received via emails and chat
applications promising rewards of some
nature once clicked the ransomware files
installed on the system that encrypts
all the files or blocks access to
computer functions they can also be
spread via malware transmitted via
untrusted application install ation or
even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access a
computer can be accessed remotely using
this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is a type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a log
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers once the files are
encrypted finding the decryption key is
impossible unless the ransomware variant
is old and the keys are already
available on the Internet scareware is
fake software that claims to have
detected a virus or other issue on your
computer and directs you to pay to
resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with pop-up
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security one must always have backups of
their data cloud storage for backup is
easy but a physical backup in a hard
drive is always recommended keeping the
system updated with the latest security
patches is always a good idea
apart from system updates one must
always have reputed antivirus software
installed many antivirus software like
kasperski and Bit Defender have
anti-ransomware features that
periodically check for encryption of
private documents when browsing the
internet a user must always check for
the lock symbol on the address bar which
signifies the presence of https protocol
for additional security if a system is
infected with ransomware already there's
a website no more r .org it has a
collection of decryption tools for most
well-known ransomware packages it can
also help decrypt specific encrypted
files if the list of anti-ransomware
tools didn't help the
victim malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and
Trojan firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan Horse Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create back doors into a
system to allow the cyper criminal to
steal our information
let's take a look how they function
after getting installed into our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan
functioning for Trojan hes entryway into
our system is through emails that may
look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the tro
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
andion are let's understand different
types of virus
andrs let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as the boot sector virus this type of
virus damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the masterb record
which is also known as MBR this damages
the boot sector section by targeting the
hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
macro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the the reason it is known
as a non-resident virus let's take a
look at different types of
prions the first type of troan is the
back door troan they are designed to
create a back door in the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of a system to the
hacker this way the Cyber criminal can
steal our system data and may use it for
illegal activities next we have criost
strogen they enter the system by
clicking the random popups which we come
across on the internet they attempt the
user to give their personal details for
different transactions or
schemes which may provide remote access
of a system to the
cybercriminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system functioning the
Cyber criminal Demands a ransom from the
targeted user for the removal of the
Trojan program from the device now that
we understand some details regarding
viruses and prion let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in
his
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind this system's
problem option a macro virus option b
rans some rosion option C back door
rosion give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and troan
in our
system to detect virus or troan activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system for Trojan we have
frequent system crashes and system also
faces slow reaction time then we have
there are more random popups from the
system which may indicate troan activity
and lastly we have modification in the
system application and change of the
desktop appearance can be also due to
the infection of a Trojan
program next let's take a look at a
famous Cyber attack for virus and a
Trojan
hor for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails
which was to gain back door access into
our
systems next for the troan horse we have
the emot troan program which is a
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses can this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
much better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troen activity in our system
and also avoid clicking random popups
that we often see on the internet and
lastly using antivirus and firewalls for
protection against troan horses is a
good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and
information effect of viruses is more
drastic in comparison to the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote programs whereas troen
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
Trojan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with a database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it
to prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when they send a
query to the application will form a
malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database uh basically gets cracked or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick Mo so what we have done here
is I have this virtual machine called
oasp broken web applications virtual
machine version 1.2 I'm going to power
this
on till this powers on I'm going to show
you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just look for
OAS broken web application project
download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net click on the link
you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for-profit
organization and uh periodically uh
releases the most top 10 risks that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so till to
upgrade your skills to skill yourself
please download this machine hosted in a
VM workstation or Oracle virtual box and
you can uh then try your skills on it
right so uh just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 7113 to
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 192
132 and you see the oasp broken web
application project and there are lot of
training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications inbuilt over here that you
can try your skills upon you are going
to try to use the OAS mutil day over
here uh this gives you the uh OAS top 10
risks for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest
one so far uh but the difference between
between 2013 and 2017 is that some of
these have changed but not all of them
uh the order has changed a little bit
but you can see that SQL injection is on
the top A1 amongst the injection attacks
right and you can see there are multiple
types that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh attacks blind
SQL injection and then there is a tool
called SQL map which is available freely
on your Linux machines Ki Linux or parot
Linux whichever you want to use uh for
your practice targets and so on so forth
so if I just take you here for bypass
authentication and this is a regular
login page that an application may have
right you look at a username you look at
a password you type that in and you log
in so let's say I don't know a password
here I'm just going to type in the
username test password is pssw Rd I try
to log in and it shows shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work I did
try type in a username and password it
wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote r 1 equals 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it give me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and uh we're going to look at
the basics of SQL injection so looking
at that small demo looking now let's
look at what types of SQL injections are
available so the first is inband SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within inband error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a Time based attack and the
third one is outof bound SQL injection
attack now what is inband SQL injection
attack inband is where we either
attempting the error based or the union
based what is error based uh we send a
query to the database we craft a query
to the database and uh it generates an
error M message and it dumps the error
message right in front of us on the
screen that uh makes us realize that
there is a flaw and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to CR
our further queries as we go ahead
whereas Union base is the it is where we
combine multiple statements at the same
time so if you look at the URL earlier
in the URL you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would a error based uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember the username we gave it a
single quote r 1 equals 1 space hyphen
hyphen space we gave it the condition
right so basically what it did was a
single code is an operator that goes to
the database selects the default uh
table uh in the user tables in this
database column and then Compares it to
the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was 1 equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default uh user table
that was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the account doesn't exist comes
back again because the condition was
false and instead of comparing the user
account to the password it basically uh
compared the user account to the
condition so if I give it a single quote
or 1 equal 1 hyphen space uh and log in
you can see that this is a correct
condition and thus we are able to log in
now before we even go uh to that extent
if I just forget the condition over here
and I just give it a single code the
operator and I send this operator to the
database and I click on login you will
see that it generates an error which is
right on top and it tells us the line
the uh file where the error happened and
you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler. PHP file right and then it give
us the message you have an error in your
SQL syntax check the manual that
corresponds to your my SQL Server
version for the right syntax to use now
why would a hacker want to do this in
the first place because there are
different types of databases so there is
a MySQL Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL Oracle
SQL IBM db2 all of these are variations
of the SQL database uh they use the SQL
language however every database has its
own Command right they they have their
own syntax they have their own uh
specific commands that are utilized for
the database so in this scenario the
hacker wants to identify what database
is being currently utilized so they can
craft those particular queries so now
with this injection with just me sending
the quote and the error getting
generated rated I now come to know that
we are using a MySQL server and the
version of that server is
5173 and uh the rest of the information
about uh where the handlers are located
and so on so forth right this gives the
information to the hacker of how they
want to proceed next what kind of
queries they want to create what kind of
syntax they want to utilize so error
based attack is where you generate these
kind of Errors uh and you get this
information the Union Bas is where you
craft your queries within the URL or you
can try to combine multiple statements
within the input fields and try to
generate a response from that then we
come to Boolean based SQL injection uh
sends a SQL query to the database which
forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a false
result so basically if the input is
false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input B the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attack will come to know
which input is true with this he can
then access the database of the website
so you're trying to figure out by
sending out multiple inputs uh and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
uh which command exactly worked what was
the resultant output of that command
thus from this kind of an information
the hacker can infer their next step
forward then you have time based SQL
injections uh now there are times when a
database administrator an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and does have disabled
verbos error messages now what is a
verbos error message the error message
that we saw right here is a verbos error
message that means that the message
gives out details the message gives out
details about what the data is the
version and whatnot so if they have
sanitized these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply
learn
and
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbos error that we saw here
so this gives us a detail error of what
went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this side where
there's some there's a lot of security
that goes in here so you can see that it
doesn't generate a error it just get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what does a hacker do so the hacker
then injects a Time based uh query in
the URL which allows us to verify
whether the command is being executed or
not so uh we put in a time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weight
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitize them
so you have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed at a user
level with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing the these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there's an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how a website works right uh how
cql works on a website now the website
is constructed of HTML hypertext markup
language uh which would include
javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheets for the mapping of
the website right and then react JS and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like Oracle my SQL Ms SQL and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've used it on quite a bit uh
here we have a example for gmail.com so
let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quote single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single quote right there so uh that's
where we use that operator and that's
where the exception error occurred so
these are the kind of queries that are
structured by the application and then
taken on to the database for execution
when we type in uh it is a HTTP get
request with the username and password
within that query uh that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a SQL query sends it to the
database and the database responds with
the appropriate response so how do we
prevent SQL injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterized
queries uh these statements make sure
that the parameters pass into SQL
statements are treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
code was an operator this shouldn't be
allowed to be utilize in the first place
right so here what we are doing here is
a secure way of running a SQL qu quy in
the jdbc using a parameterized statement
Define which user we want to find so
there's a string the email comes in
connection to the database we are going
to figure out how the connection is
going to be passed how it is going to be
created construct the SQL statement we
want to run specifying the parameter
right so we Define how is it going to be
uh created what is going to be created
what can be passed to the database and
what should not be passed to the
database so that is one way of utilizing
prepared state statements and
parameterized queries then we have
object relational mapping most
development uh teams prefer to use
objection object relational mapping
Frameworks to make the translation of
SQL results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping uh where we map
certain objects and allow that to be
executed and then escaping inputs it a
simple way to protect against most SQL
injection attacks many languages have
stand standard functions to achieve this
right so you need to be very careful
while using Escape characters in your
code base when a SQL statement is
constructed not all injection attacks
rely on abuse of quote characters so you
need to know what characters are being
utilized uh in the configuration that
you have created in the structure that
you have created in the code that you
have created uh which characters are
being recognized as operators you need
to sanitize those operators and you need
to uh basically Ensure that these
operators cannot be accepted as user
input if they are they feed out by the
application and they never reach the
database other methods of uh preventing
SQL injection are uh password hashing so
that passwords cannot be bypassed the
passwords cannot be recovered passwords
cannot be cracked uh third party
authentication you use o or uh some
other service for a single sign on
mechanism does uh you rely on a third
party
to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
onto Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the AU
authentication mechanisms to third party
such as Facebook or Google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is as safe as can be Facebook
and Google are wealthy organizations uh
hire a lot of Security Experts and the
development for their authentication
mechanisms is topnotch small
organization cannot spend that kind of
money on security itself right so you
use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the shhot method of uh mitigating
or minimizing the uh threat in the first
place so at this point in time you have
realize that the application has some
vulnerabilities for SQL injection and
instead of recoding or restructuring the
application uh you want to take the
easier way out or the cheaper way out so
what you do is you uh you install a web
application firewall and you configure
the web application firewall to identify
malicious queries and stop them uh at
the firewall level itself so they never
reach the application and thus the
vulnerabilities on the application don't
get
executed buy better software and keep on
updating the software so it's not
necessary that once you have a software
you install it it's going to be safe for
Life new vulnerabilities are discovered
every day every hour and it may so
happen what is secured today
may be completely insecure tomorrow or
the day after right so you need to keep
on upgrading the software if there are
no upgrades available and the varability
still exist you might want to migrate to
a better software and does uh ensure
that you don't get hacked right always
update and use patches organizations
keep on sending out updates and patches
as and when they are released you need
to install them to uh enhance your
security postures and then continuously
monitor SQL statements and databases use
protocol monitors uh use different
softwares use the firewalls to keep on
monitoring what kind of queries you're
uh getting and based on those queries
you want to ensure the inputs and the
queries that are creating uh are not
detrimental to the health of the
software that you have Jane is relaxing
at home when she receives an email from
a bank that asks her to update her
credit card pin in the next 24 hours as
a security measure judging the severity
of the message Jane follows the link
provided in the email on delivering her
current credit card pin and the
supposedly updated one the website
became unresponsive which prompted her
to try sometime later however after a
couple of hours she noticed a
significant purchase from a random
website on that same credit card which
she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
entailed credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish in the the fishing emails the
bait if Jane never opened the malicious
link or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively
ineffective but how does the hacker gain
access to these credentials a fishing
attack starts with a fraudulent message
which can be transmitted via email or
chat applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns where an identical
fishing mail is sent to thousands of
users the rate of success is relatively
low but never zero between 2013 and 2015
corporate giants like Facebook and
Google were tricked off of $100 million
due to an extensive fishing campaign
where a known common associate was
impersonated by the hackers apart from
credit access some of these campaigns
Target the victim device and install
malware when on the malicious links
which can later function as a botn net
or a target for ransomware attacks there
is no single formula for there are
multiple categories of fishing attacks
the issue with Jane or the hacker stoer
Bank credentials falls under the
umbrella of deceptive fishing a general
email is sent out to thousands of users
in this category hoping some of them
fall prey to this scam spear fishing on
the other hand is a bit customized
version the targets are researched
before being sent in email for example
if you never had a Netflix subscription
sending you an email that seems like the
Netflix Team sends it becomes pointless
this is a potential drawback of
deceptive fishing techniques on the
other hand a simple screenshot of a
Spotify playlist being shared on social
media indicates a probable point of
entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information since the hacker
already knows the target uses Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10-fold which can be
called a case of wailing the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their fishing attack often to
steal industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price apart from just emails farming
focuses on fake websites that resemble
their original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit web page which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cache poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource constraints now that we
know how fish attacks work let's look at
ways to prevent ourselves from becoming
victims while the implications of a
fishing attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that it redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or or
pop-up Windows irrespective of how
legitimate they seem it is also
recommended to use secure anti- fishing
browser extensions like cloudfish to
sniff out malicious emails from
legitimate ones the best way to prevent
fishing is browsing the internet with
care and being on alert for malicious
attempts at all times start by learning
about cross-site scripting from a
Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xss is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
Attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious code infected web page or
online application the web page or
application serves as a vehicle for the
malicious script to be sent to the
user's browser forums message boards and
online pages that enable comments are
vulnerable vehicles that are frequently
utilized for cross script rting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then par this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript o to the fact that JavaScript
is most important to most browser
experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as
well cross crosss side scripting is
often compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client side code add
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike serers side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
Navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window while
JavaScript is client site and does not
run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing ing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously the manner of attack can
range in a variety of ways it can be a
single link which the user must click on
to initiate a JavaScript piece of code
it can be used to show any piece of
images that can be later used as a front
end for malicious code being installed
as malware but the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and sends it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting let us learn
more about how how this kind of attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website ask the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately reses the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending an
injecting malicious code or script this
attack can be performed in different
ways depending on the type of attack the
malicious script may be reflected on the
victim's browser but stored in the
database and executed every time when
the user calls the appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output a malicious user can enter a
script which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not therefore this
malicious script is being executed on
the victim's browser or any faked form
if that is being displayed for the users
there are many ways to trigger an xss
attack for example the execution could
be triggered automatically when the page
loads or when a user hovers over
specific elements of the page like
hyperlinks potential consequences of
cross-site scripting attacks include
capturing keystrokes of a user
redirecting a user to malicious websites
running web browser based exploits
obtaining cookie information of a user
who is logged into a website and many
more in some cases cross-side scripting
attack leads to complete compromise of
the victim's account attackers can trick
users into entering credentials on a
fake form which can then provide all
information to the attacker with the
basic basic working of a cross-side
scripting attack out of the way let us
go over the different ways hackers can
leverage vulnerable web applications to
gather information and eventually breach
those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
xss attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display fake
Pages or forms for the victim however
this can be performed in several ways
we have a reflected attack this attack
occurs when a malicious script is not
being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected xss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying fak
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflect Ed cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser this
script is not stored in the web
application and malicious code is shown
only to one user the user that opens the
link executes the script and the tack is
not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when a malicious script is being saved
on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate functionality
this way stored xss attack can affect
many users also as the script is being
stored on the web server it will affect
the website for a longer time in order
to perform stored xss attack the
malicious scripts should be sent through
the vulnerable input form for example
can be a comment field or a review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function calling in a stored
xss example the script might have been
submitted via an input field to the web
server which did not perform a
sufficient validation and stores the
script permanently in the database the
consequence of this might be that the
script is now being delivered to all
users visiting the web application and
for example able to gain access to the
user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently St in the web app the users
visiting the app after the information
retrieve the script the malicious code
then exploits the flaws in the web
application and the script and the
attack is visible on the server side or
to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how EX Dom
attack is being performed Let Us analyze
the following example if there is a
website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform accss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based accss attack may
be successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the the web
page it can be based on an input field
or the get parameter without validating
the input this allows the malicious code
to be
executed the malicious code the exploits
flaws in the browser on the user side
and the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-site
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of is one can
Safeguard against such attacks let's go
through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier exus
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent accesss attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
security suit or a kinetic security
suit still manual testing is highly
timec consuming and cost costly and
therefore not possible to be done for
every iteration of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected exsus
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server side as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accss vulnerabilities
typically requires properly escaping
user provided data that is placed on the
page rather than trying to determine if
the data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and Escape data whether it is user
provided or not unfortunately because
there are many different rules for
escaping you still must choose the
proper type of escaping before settling
on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encoded
content security policy or CSP is a
computer security standard introduced to
prevent cross-side scripting
clickjacking and other code injection
attacks resulting from the execution of
malicious content in The Trusted web
page context it is a candidate
recommendations of the w3c working group
on web application security it's widely
supported by modern web browsers and
provides a standard method for website
owners to declare approved Origins of
content that browser should be allowed
to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports the flag
as a result even if a cross-side
scripting flaw exists and a user
accidentally accesses a link that
exploits this flaw the browser will not
reveal the cookie to a third
party if a browser does not support HTTP
only and a website attempts to set an
HTTP only cookie the HTTP only flag will
be ignored brows the browser thus
creating a traditional script accessible
cookie as a result the cookie becomes
vulnerable to theft of modification by
any malicious script next on our docket
is a live demonstration where we solve a
set of cross-site scripting problems
starting from the basic level to the
topmost level six we're going to start
at level
one in this web application it
demonstrates the common cause of
crosslite scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if you interact with a
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge let's see why the most
primitive injections work here right
away let's do a simple query and inspect
the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quote as a special
character
we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the pad
should be included in the URL to perform
successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily just going to write the script
over
here
and we're going to press
search as you can see we have
successfully launched our first
cross-side scripting attack we can see
an alert box popup with the necessary
message and a similar process can be
used to steal browser cookies and
passwords all be it with different
commands now we have the option to move
to level two
in this web application it shows that
how easily xss bugs can be introduced in
complex chat
applications chat app conversations are
stored in a database and retrieved when
a user wants to see the conversation
therefore if a malicious user injects
some JavaScript code all visitors will
be infected this kind of cross-site
scripting attack is more powerful and it
is more riskier than reflected cross-
scripting attacks and that's why is
known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single code and this is what I
get whatever I typed in simply appeared
on the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand
why we're going to toggle the code of
here and check the index.html
file important
part is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parer will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
JavaScript
we're going to use an image over
here and when we press on share
status in the above injection we loading
an image that doesn't exist which causes
to trigger an on error event in on error
event the it will execute our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see clicking on any
tab called cuses the tab number to be
displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chw tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use the existing IMG tag and change
the source to something that doesn't
exist hence forcing it to fall in to
execute an on error even which I will
pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
Java popup has opened up here with the
same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of
attack in this we application there is a
timer on the page that means whatever
numbers we put in the Box a countdown
starts and then when it finishes the
application alerts that the countdown is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload
however the timer parameter is being
directly passed to the start timer
method we need to perform a popup Alert
in the web application which escapes the
content of the function start timer
without baking the JavaScript code the
parameter value is directly added to the
start timer method without any filtering
what we can try to do here is to inject
an alert function to be executed inside
the on loone event along with the start
timer
method we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here now I me press on create
timer and we have a popup with xss level
complete we can now move on to level
five in this web application this
application xss is different cuz this
challenge description says cross-side
scripting isn't just about correctly
escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cu the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected the href attribute value of
next link is confirm which is exactly
the value of the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
can be used to inject a JavaScript code
to the href attribute of the next link
the following is the best way to do it
as soon as the user clicks on the link
the script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level
six
in this sub application it shows some of
the external Javascript is
rried if you analyze the URL you can see
that the script is loaded already the
vulnerability lies within how the code
handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and then in line 48
the value is directly passed on to the
include Gadget method and the include
Gadget method that we can see over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own JavaScript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
application URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using https but
anything like that to bypass the regular
expression for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting at taxs and
use different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a Dos
attack these dos attacks are getting
more extreme with hackers getting easy
access to bot net farms and compromised
devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botet allow further penetration into the
consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DS attack
in 2018 widely suspected to be conducted
by Chinese authorities this attack went
on for about 20 minutes after which the
systems were brought into a stable
condition it was the strongest DS attack
to date at the time and made a lot of
companies reconsider the security
practices to combat such attacks even
after years of experimentation Ros
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space hey everyone this is BB
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on what is a Dos attack let's
learn more about what is a DS
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a DS attack comes from
multiple systems generally these attacks
work by Drowning a system with requests
for data this could be sending a web
server so many requests to server page
that it crashes under the demand or it
could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control
center the bots in the network attack a
particular Target
thereby hiding the original perpetrator
of the DS campaign but how do these
devices come under a botnet and what are
the request being made to the web
servers let's learn more about these and
how dos attack
work a DS attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
anytime to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the botn net the
devices in these networks are called
Bots or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests the
target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like SN
flooding and UDP flooding the aim is to
overwhelm them with more traffic than
the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to render the
website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DS
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
re resource it can be a website or a
server they include icmp udap and
spoofed packet flood attacks the size of
volume based attack is measured in bits
per second these attacks focus in
clogging all the available bandwidth for
the server thereby cutting the supply
short several requests are sent to the
server all of which warrant a reply
thereby not allowing the target to cater
to the general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balancers and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the dors attacks these
protocol attacks include SN floods and
Smurf DDOS among others and the size is
measured in packets per second for
example in an SSL handshake server
replies to the Hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the IP is poofed and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application L attacks are
conducted by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests the size of
application layer attacks is measured in
request per second these are relatively
sophisticated attacks that Target the
application and operating system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network banded up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking a
single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about about the
reasons for such an attack there are
multiple lines of thought as to why a
hacker decides to launch a Dos attack on
unsuspecting targets let's take a look
at a few of them the first option is to
gain a competitive Advantage many ds
attacks are conducted by hacking
communities against rival groups some
organizations hire such communities to
stagger their Rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field since being a victim
of a DS attack IND Ates a lack of
security the reputation of such a
company takes a significant hit allowing
the rivals to cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launch
these DS attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a
while DS attacks have also found use in
the political segment certain activists
tend to use DS attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
Forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dilemas or even protest against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against Ros
attacks the company can employ load
balancers and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load
balancers reroute the traffic from one
server to another in a DS attack this
reduces the single point of failure and
adds resiliency to the server data a
firewall blocks unwanted traffic into a
system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a Dos attack in
action early detection of a DS attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that that
only legitimate traffic reaches the
server by intelligent routing you can
break the remaining traffic into
manageable chunks that can be handled by
your cluster resources the most
important stage in DOS mitigation is
where you will look for patterns of Dos
attacks and use those to analyze and
strengthen your mitigation techniques
for example blocking an IP that's
repeatedly found to be offending is a
first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who are
offer high levels of cyber security
including firewalls and threat
monitoring software can help protect
your assets and network from dos
criminals the cloud also has greater
bandwidth than most private networks so
it is likely to fail if under the
pressure of increased DS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since DS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of Dos attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a Dos
attack of sorts once a botet is ready
multiple devices can do the same and
eventually emulate a DS attack to do so
we will use the virtualization software
called VMware with an instance of parro
security operating system running for a
Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use wire shark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly this is Linux light which is
a target machine and this is parot
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the terminal
we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parro security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
192.168 72129 which which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi when
launching attacks with public servers or
public addresses it will have a public
IP address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hping
3 hping 3 is an open open source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
wire shark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light drro is
being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to once we have the
Dos attack launched you you can see the
results coming over here from The Source
IP which will be par security Now to
launch the hping 3 command we need to
give pseudo access to the console which
is the root
access now we have the root access for
the console the hping 3 command will
have a few arguments to go with it which
are as you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is21 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies syn packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the par
security OS is the client and Linux
slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shark it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which is2 168 72.1
128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the requests keep on coming and we
can see the
HTTP flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a back
end now remember Linux light is a drro
and such Linux dros are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system has
become completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from parot
security you can see whatever I pressed
nothing is responded even the wire shark
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux drro is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system againsts its
strength it is relatively easy to gauge
right now the effect of a Dos attack now
remember this Linux light is just a VM
instance actual website servers and web
databases they have much more bandwidth
and are very secure and it is tough to
break into that is why we cannot use a
single machine to break into them that
is where a DS attack comes into play
what we did right now is a Dos attack as
in a single system is is being used to
penetrate a Target server using a single
request now when a Dos attack multiple
systems such as multiple pirate security
instances or multiple zombies or bots in
a botnet network can attack a Target
server to completely shut down the
machine and drop any legitimate request
thereby rendering the service and the
target completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for education
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any per domains only test
this on servers and networks that you
have permission to test on cyber
security has become one of the most
rigid Industries in the last decade
while simultaneously being the most
challenged with every aspect of
corporate culture going online and
embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more comp
complex attacks and one of these attacks
is a Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one Brute Force
attacks are simple and reliable there is
no prior knowledge needed about the
victim to start an attack most of the
systems fallowing prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until the find the one that works due to
this repeated trial and error format the
strength of password matters a great
dral although with enough time and
resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be timec
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data aisc are used and
at times downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take with hardly
any effort dictionary attacks are an
alternative to Brute Force attacks where
the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analyst like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8-digit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to get the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combination with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken we can try and
break into a specific encrypted document
a social media account or even devices
at home that connect to the internet
let's say there is a Wi-Fi router the
generated passwords are then fed into
the connection one after the other it is
a long and arduous process but the work
is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the
router sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad password
habits is very appealing and the general
public tends to stick with simple and
easy to use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
Brute Force Works let's see if you can
answer this question we learned about
how complex passwords are tougher to
crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to Brute Force attacks
a hack laptop or mobile can have social
media accounts logged in giving the
hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification
among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the Hacked machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of withstanding buil
Force attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or a password
is comp compromised due to a breach or a
hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the
incident two Factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific tofa
applications like Ai and agis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for TW course
are much more reliable and
secure captas are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with 5i taking the re in every
household it's natural that the security
will always be up for debate to further
test the security index and understand
Brute Force attacks you will attempt to
break into the password of a Wi-Fi
router for that to happen we first need
to capture a handshake file which is a
connection file from the Wi-Fi router to
a connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called air gedon which is
made to hack into Wireless Network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the WLX X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see above
it's written it is in managed mode right
now so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and its name is now W l0o
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for
example the station that you can see 56
26 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BSS ID is supposed to
be which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C it will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA 2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA hand handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a do cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the path
and the hand shap file is generated we
can already see a Target over here same
go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with air crack plus
crunch which is a Brute Force attack
against a handshake file we can go with
option
two it can all already detect the
capture file that we have generated so
we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than 8 digits and
Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
we go with only uppercase characters and
numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting so how aircrack is working
right here you can see this pass phrase
over here the first five or six digits
are a it starts working its way from the
end from the last character it keeps
trying every single combination you can
see the last the fourth character from
the right side the D it'll eventually
turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world cyber
attacks are frequently making headlines
in today's digital environment at any
time everyone who uses a computer could
become a victim of a Cyber attack there
are various sorts of cyber attacks
ranging from fishing to password attacks
in this video we'll look into one such
attack that is known as botnet but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon never to miss an
update to begin with let's take a look
at some of the famous botet attacks the
first one is miray botet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots that on
command perform basic and medium level
denial of service attacks then we have
the zoo bot is specifically designed for
attacking the system for Bank related
information and data now let's see what
exactly a bot net is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and a hijack criminal
known as bot holder remotely controls
them the Bots are used to automate large
scale attacks including Data Theft
server failure malware
propagation and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly
bot net is let's dive deeper into
learning how bot net works during the
preparation of a botet network the first
step involves preparing the bot net Army
after that the connection between the
bot net Army and the control server
established and the end the launching of
the attack is done by the bot Herer
let's understand through a
illustration firstly we have a bot Herer
that initiates the attack according to
the control server commands the devices
that are infected with the malware
programs and begins to attack the
infected system let's see some details
regarding the preparation of the bot net
Army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a B net is to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that there are enough Bots to
carry out the attack this way it creates
Bots either by exploiting the security
gaps in the software or websites or
using fishing attacks they are often
deployed through troan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with a specific malware that
connects the device back to the control
Boton server a bot Herer uses command
programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to admin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the
important
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the bot Herer issues a command
to the server it is then related to the
clients to perform malicious
actions then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the BS are topological interconnected
and acts as both C and C servers that is
the server and the client today hackers
adopt this approach to avoid detection
and single point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some counter measure against
bot net
attacks the first step is to have
updated drivers and system updates after
that we should avoid clicking random
popups or links that we often see on the
internet and lastly having certified
anti virus anti spyware softwares and
firewall installed into a system will
protect against malware attack the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web hi everyone
and welcome to the simply La Channel
today we will discuss a topic that
secretly records our input data that is
known as key loggers but before we begin
if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data
regularly this is Jacob from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet
activity as Jacob heard about the the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key loging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
into the system to begin with we learn
what exactly the key logging program
is as a name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these lock files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging programers let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key logging program into
a
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard Lacks behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arouse is API based the most
common key logging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests they are based key
loggers that store the form data that is
if we often use web forms or different
kinds of forms to enter different data
they can be recorded into the system by
the program and send it to its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are are
installed deeply into the operating
system where they can hide from
different antivirus if not checked
properly and they record the data that
we type on the keyboard and send it to
its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how hack
is different initiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hikers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the company
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kindes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system now to prevent our system from
getting infected by the key locking
program let's take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import the key keyboard module which
will help us to record the data that we
type on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of of code that will allow us to
save the data that is recorded by the
program into a text file that will be
named as key _ log text file along with
the date and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as
the format would be the message and the
time stamp which would be given
as along with the time
stamp
given as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed
is
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line and
logging the Press
key
info a string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release the that will come into play
when the Escape key has been pressed
that is the program will terminate
itself and the program will stop from
running and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to Loop these functions that is
while press and while release to
continue it
cycle that will be going for while
press
and
on release will contain while
release
function
as listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the log file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not
let's take a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the
bottom over here we see the key log text
that is the text file that we created
let's open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is a Hello World part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learn what exactly key logos are then we
understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key loging problem then we learn how
to detect the problem into our system
then we learn what different types of
key loggers are present on the net we
also understood how hackers use the
recorded data from the program and we
also learned whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system before we learn about
the Pegasus platform let us understand
what spyware is and it's working spyware
is a category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information with some spyware
systems even clicking on the link isn't
necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such spyware system that
is making the rounds in the tech
industry today is Pegasus the Pegasus is
a spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform since Pegasus has
existed since as early as 2016 a highly
intricate spy program that can track
user location read text messages scan
through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillance for
any client that wishes to buy its
services initially the NSO group had
designed the software to be used against
terrorist factions of the world with
more and more encrypted communication
channels coming to the Forefront Pegasus
was designed to maintain control over
the data transmission that can be a
threat to National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on if eventually the
primary clients became Sovereign Nations
spying on Public Information that is
supposed to stay private became really
easy with the service multiple devices
can be affect With the same spy system
to create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus pyware targets such
occurrences by passing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this is isn't unique to the email
ecosystem since it's equally likely to
be targeted by SMS text WhatsApp
Instagram or even the most secure
messaging apps like signal and threa
once the malicious links are clicked a
spy package is downloaded and installed
on the device after the spyer is
successfully installed the perpetrator
who sent the payload to the victim can
monitor everything the user does Pegasus
can collect private emails passwords
images videos and every other piece of
information that passes to the device
Network all this data is transmitted
back to the central server where the
primary spying organization can monitor
the activities at a granular level this
is not even surface level since complex
PIV software like Pegasus can access the
root files on our mobiles these root
files hold information that is crucial
to the working of the Android and iOS
operating systems leaking such private
information is a massive blow to the
security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where a hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike crypto Miners and
Trojans spying Services usually do not
demand many system resources which makes
them tough to detect after they have
been activated since many devices slow
down after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often attributed to poor software
longetivity by the users they do not
check meticulously for any other causes
that is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if we are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall free to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comments section below
and we will R the correct answer next
week but what about the unaffected
devices the vulnerable ones while we
cannot be certain of our security there
are a few things we can do to boost our
device be it against Pegasus or the next
big SP on the market let's say we are
safe now and we have the time to take
the necessary steps to prevent a spyware
attack what are the things we can go for
our primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits Target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen prey
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spyware platform alog
together another big factor is the
spread of malware is the trend of
sideloading Android applications using
APK files downloading such apps from a
thirdparty website have no security
checks involved and are mostly
responsible for adware and spyware
invasions on user devices avoiding the
side loading of apps would be a major
step in protecting yourself we often
receive spam emails or texts from people
we may not know on social medias they
are accompanied with links that allow
malware to creep into our device we
should try to follow the trusted
websites and not click on any links that
redirect us to unknown domains spy is a
controversial segment in governance
while the ramifications are pretty
extreme in theory it severely impacts
user privacy against authoritarian
regimes sufficient resources and a
contingent plan can alter the false ve
of democracy altogether even if our
daily life is rather simplistic we must
understand that privacy is not about
what we have to hide instead it portrays
the things we have to protect it stands
for everything we have to share with the
outside world both theorically and
literally hey everyone today we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar winds attack the
global statistics indicate that upward
of 18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn the date is December 8th 2020 fire
a global leader in company specializing
in cyber security released a blog post
that caught the attention of the entire
it Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solar wind
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access trojen or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the reveal sent the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for their platform in order
to to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this breach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion cering to
corporations and governments worldwide
Oran was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
brought the platform solar winds claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferably services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was softer
updates the update server for solarin
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled the software
updates was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers pack
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believed the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix this vulner
abilities introduced by the software
while the actual perpetrators have never
been found it is believed that this was
an act of crossborder corporate
Espionage conducted by state sponsored
hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar wind hack was it one a virus a
remote access Trojan a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two authentication
applications is also encouraged since it
acts as a safety net if hackers directly
get a hold of our credentials clicking
on unknown links transmitted via emails
is also a strict no as is installing
applications from unverified sources the
solar wind hack is estimated to cost the
parent company nearly $18 million as
reparations making it one if not the
biggest hacks in cyberspace history as
recently as of July 2021 the hackers
accessed some us attorneys Microsoft 365
email accounts as part of the attack
criminal organizations like the FBI and
CIA are determined to figure out the
culprits responsible for this debacle
however the intricacy and the full
extent of the breach makes it a way more
complicated job than it looks on paper
the day is 26th February
2022 the world is hit with breaking news
that Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a activist
collective in movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade
this was in response to the Russian
aggression on Ukrainian territory in the
hopes of annexation Anonymous hacked the
Russian State TV networks to combat
propaganda in Russia and highlight the
damage to life Meed out by the Kremlin
in Ukraine they also hacked 120,000
Russian troops personal information and
the Russian Central Bank stealing 35,000
files this served as a clear indicator
of how cyber War can change the momentum
in battle something which people had
never seen so closely so what is cyber
War a digital assault or series of
strikes or hacks against a country is
sometimes referred to as a cyber War it
has the ability to cause havoc on
government and civilian infrastructure
as well as disrupt essential systems
causing State harm and even death in
this day and age the internet plays a
bigger role than just watching videos
and learning content it's where you have
your personal data and carry Financial
transactions so rather than resorting to
physical violence cyber War has become
the new means to cause Havoc considering
the vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves a
nation state attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
Verizon to secure remote access to their
networks stuck net was a computer worm
designed to attack Iran's nuclear fa
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague applying rules and sanctions
based on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out a
major category of Cyber attack is
espionage Espionage entails monitoring
other countries to steal critical
Secrets this might include compromising
vulnerable computer systems with botn
Nets or spear fishing attempts before
extracting sensitive data in cyber
warfare the next weapon in cyber war is
sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with ties
to the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorists to steal
or destroy information
by overwhelming a website with bogus
requests and forcing it to handle them
denial of service attacks prohibit real
users from accessing it attacking
parties may use this form of assault to
disrupt key operations and systems and
prevent citizens military and security
officials and research organizations
from accessing sensitive websites but
what benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability conduct attacks from anywhere
globally without having to travel
thousands of miles as long as the
attacker and Target are connected to the
internet organizing and launching Cyber
Wars is relatively less tedious Than
Physical Warfare people living in or
battling for a country are subjected to
propaganda attacks in an attempt to
manipulate their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world starting from
communication channels to Secure Storage
servers crippling a country's footprint
and control on the Internet is very
damaging but what are some of the ways
we as Citizens protect ourselves in the
case of a cyber war in the unfortunate
event that your country is involved in
Warfare be sure to fact check every
piece of information and follow only
trusted sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of War
drastically it is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being attacked having
devices segregated in a network goes a
long way in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses in this video we
bring you the top 10 computer hacks of
all time but before we begin if you're
new here and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the Subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting Tech
videos every day let's see what we have
at number 10 from April 27 2007 Estonia
the European country faced a series of
cyber attacks that lasted for weeks
this happened when the Estonian
government desired to move the bronze
soldier from Talent Center to a less
prominent military cemetery located on
the city's
outskirts unprecedented levels of
internet traffic took down Estonian
Banks online services media Outlets
broadcasters and government bodies
botnet sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated Online
requests according to researchers the
public faed dos attacks there were
conflicts to edit the English language
version version of The Bronze soldiers
Wikipedia page as well although there is
no confirmation Russia is believed to be
behind these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the Estonian Society let's now
move on to the next attack on December
23rd 2015 several parts of Ukraine
witnessed a par outage and this was not
a typical blackout it was indeed the
result of a Cyber attack Information
Systems of three energy distribution
companies in Ukraine were compromised it
is the first known Victorious Cyber
attack on a grid it is said that here
hackers sent out fishing emails to the
par companies 30 substations were
Switched Off and about 230,000 people
were left in the dark for about 1 to 6
hours us investigators believed that
Russia based hackers were responsible
for this experts have warned that other
countries could also be vulnerable to
such attacks let's see what we have at
number eight in the year 1999 a Cyber
attack caused a 21-day shutdown of NASA
computers unbelievable isn't it the
hacker was none other than the then
15-year-old Jonathan James he first
penetrated US Department of Defense
division's computers and installed a
back door on its servers this allowed
him to intercept more than a thousand
government emails including the ones
containing usernames and passwords this
helped James steal a piece of NASA
software and crack the NASA computers
that support the International Space
Station which cost a space exploration
agency's
$41,000 as systems were shut down for 3
weeks he was the first person to carry
out a computer hack against the American
space agency let's now move on to the
next attack in late November 2014 there
was a leak of confidential data from the
film studio of Sony Pictures information
about Sony Pictures employees their
emails copies of the then unreleased
Sony films future propositions and other
crucial data were leaked this Cyber
attack was carried out by a hacker group
named guardians of peace so what did the
hackers want well they demanded that
Sony withdraw its then upcoming movie
the interview this movie was a comedy
story line to assassinate the North
Korean leader Kim jnun Sony then decided
to cancel the film's theatrical release
due to the threats at Cinema screening
the movie it is indeed hard to trace the
roots of a Cyber attack in this case
after evaluation the US intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of North Korea however North
Korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six in December
2006 TJX the US retailer company
identified that 45.6 million debit and
credit card details were
stolen this happened from one of its
systems over 18 months by an unknown
number of intruders it was one of the
first largest ever cyber attacks
involving the loss of personal data as a
result banks in the affected regions had
to reissue and block thousands of
payment cards a group of hackers did
this Albert Gonzalez being The
Mastermind the group was from Miami the
place where the TJX Heist was believed
to have originated reports said that the
TJX data breach occurred because of weak
web encryption at two of its Marshall
stores in Miami next moving on to our
top five let us see what we have at
number five the year 2010 witnessed the
discovery of the deadly computer worm
stuck net this Mal's motive was unlike
any other usual cyber attacks it aimed
at destructing the equipment the
computers controlled stuck net came with
the deadly purpose of damaging Iran's
nuclear
infrastructure it infected more than
200,000 computers including 14
Industrial sites and a uranium
enrichment plant in Iran stuck net
initially spread via Microsoft Windows
and targeted seens industrial Control
Systems although it was discovered only
in 2010 It is believed to have been
silently sabotaging Iran's nuclear
facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuges of the Iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the US and the Israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same moving on to number four in
the year 2014 Home Depot was the victim
of one of the deadliest cyber attacks 56
million payment cards were compromised
along with 53 million customer email
addresses stolen this security breach
happened from April to September 2014
criminals were believed to have used a
thirdparty vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of Home
Depot's Network the attackers were then
able to deploy custom built malware on
its self checkout systems in the US and
Canada moving on to our top three as you
might be aware the PlayStation gaming
system is one of Sony's most popular
products unfortunately in April 2011
Sony Executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the PlayStation Network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million PlayStation
users accounts and prevented users of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation Portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced Sony to turn off the
PlayStation Network on April 20th on May
4th Sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
post the outage lasted for 23 days Sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
Sony is believed to have invested
approximately $170 million to improve
the network security to investigate the
attack and to cover the expenses of
caring for the consumers that had been
affected let's now move on to the next
attack at number two in May 2017 one of
the most dangerous cyber attacks took
place it was known as the Warner cry
Ransom attack caused by the Warner cry
crypto worm the victims were the users
that used the unsupported version of
Microsoft Windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update this
did not take place through fishing like
other attacks but through an exposed
vulnerable SMB boort the attack
originated in Asia and then eventually
spread across the globe in a day more
than 200,000 computers were infected
across 150
countries the W cry crypto worm locked
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of $300 to $600 which
had to be paid via Bitcoin in exchange
for their data this attack took a toll
on both private and government
organizations it resulted in Damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars in a matter of few days the
emergency patches released by Microsoft
halted the attack also the discovery of
a kill switch prevented the infected
computers from spreading the Cryptor
worm Security Experts and a few
countries believed that North Korea was
behind this attack and finally let's see
what we have at number one more than two
decades ago in March 1999 the Melissa
virus a mass mailing macro virus was
released it targeted Microsoft Word and
Outlook based systems and created
considerable Network traffic Melissa
virus infected computers via emails the
email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake if the
recipient opens the attachments in the
mail and downloads the document and then
opens it with Microsoft Word a virus was
released on their
computers this would then massmail
itself to the first 50 people in the
victim's contact list and then disable
multiple safe card features on Microsoft
Word and Microsoft Outlook this began
spreading like a wildfire across the
internet David L Smith released the
virus the virus caused nearly 80 million
worth of Damages it did not steal data
or money however it cost a Havoc almost
1 million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations was
slowed down security was traditionally
considered an afterthought in software
development it is becoming an
increasingly important concern for all
aspects of app development from design
to deployment and Beyond the number of
programs produced distributed deployed
and patched across Network continuous
increases as a result application
security features must deal with a wide
range of risks let's take an example a
malicious script may be mirrored on the
victim's web browser or kept in a
database and run whenever the user
contacts the proper function depending
on the kind of attack in question here
this allows malicious code to be entered
in the case of an output the major cause
of this attack is faulty user input
validation which allows malicious input
to enter the final output an evil user
can enter a script that will be injected
into the website's scode the browser
will then be unable to determine whether
the process boot is harmful as a result
a malicious script is performed on the
victim's browser or a bogus form is
shown to the users are you aware of
which attack this is if not do stay till
the end to find the correct answer are
you aware of which attack this is if not
please stay till the end of the video to
know the correct answer hey everyone
welcome to today's video video on
application security before we move
forward subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from us let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today we start by learning
about application security and its
different types we learn about the most
common vulnerabilities in absc followed
by the importance of application
Security in today's cyber security
space next we cover some attacks against
application layer security and end the
video with some protection techniques to
enforce application security parameters
so let's start by learning about
application security from a Grassroots
perspective application security which
is often known as appsc protects
application software from external
security threats by utilizing security
software Hardware methodologies best
practices and different processes
organizations require application
security technologies that Safeguard all
of their programs from internal to
popular external apps on consumer mobile
phones these Solutions must address the
whole development cycle and provide
testing after an application has been
deployed to detect possible issues
application security mechanisms must be
capable of testing web pages for
possible and exploitable vulnerabilities
analyzing code and assisting the
administration of development and Safety
Management processes the testing
Solutions must also be simple and easy
to install for system administrators
worldwide consumers utilize hundreds of
applications daily to access theoretic
important and favored services such as
e-commerce banking music Etc to be
productive these professionals use a
variety of software Solutions as well
ranging from online word Checkers to
tablet based creative tools among other
things backend software of course exists
to automate essential operations and
processes and decreases human labor but
to make matters worse the quantity and
complexity of these apps and their
backend code is increasing the software
security problem 10 years ago was about
securing desktop apps and static web
pages that were natively harmless and
easy to scale through and
defense because of Outsource development
the number of Legacy programs and
in-house development that uses
third-party open source and
commercialized of the Shelf software
modules the software supply chain has
become considerably more
convoluted now that we understand
application Security on a general level
let us go through some of the different
categories or the types of application
security the three major types to be
covered in this section web application
security API security and Cloud native
application
security a web application is a program
available through the internet and it
operates on a web server the client is
accessed using a web browser the
applications by definition must allow
connections from clients across
unsecured Network this exposes them to a
variety of risks many online apps are
mission CRI IC and include sensitive
customer data making them an attractive
Target for attackers and a top concern
for any cyber security program or
framework the Advent of https which
offers an encrypted channel of
communication guards versus man in the
middle attacks or mitm attacks has
addressed several online application
weaknesses many weaknesses though still
persist many security providers have
created Solutions specifically geared to
safeguard online applications in
response to the rising challenge a web
application security a web application
firewall is an example of a security
technology meant to identify and prevent
application layer sols in the case of
web
applications when it comes to apis apis
that have security flaws are the root of
many major data breaches they have the
potential to reveal sensitive data and
disrupt vital corporate processes API
security flaws include insufficient
authentication unintended data
disclosure and a failure to apply rate
restriction which allows API abuse the
requirement for API security like the
necessity for web application security
is led to the creation of sophisticated
equipment that can discover API
vulnerabilities and protect apis in
production
level the third type is cloud native
application security infrastructure and
environments are often built up
automatically in Cloud native apps
depending on declarative configuration
which is known as infrastructure as code
or
IAC developers are tasked with
developing declarative settings and
application code both of which should be
secure because practically everything is
Define during the development stage
shifting left is even more crucial in
Cloud native setups traditional testing
techniques can help Cloud native apps
but they are insufficient dedicated
Cloud native Security Solutions are
mandatory at this point of time which
are capable of instrumenting vessels
container clusters and serverless
operations reporting on security
concerns and providing developers with a
quick feedback loop now that you have
covered the different types of
application security let us go through
some of the most common vulnerabilities
that these Frameworks face on a daily
basis first is cryptographic failure
when data is not adequately safeguarded
in transit and at rest cryptographic
failures which are forly known as
sensitive data exposures occur it has
the potential to reveal credentials
health information credit card details
and personal information as well
depending on the type of data being
protected in that particular case
injection attacks C actors can use
injection vulnerabilities to convey
malicious information to a web
application interpreter it has the
potential to assemble and execute this
data on the server esql injection is a
popular type of injection which I've
already covered in an introduction for
this
video another major vulnerability are
outdated components vulnerable and out
ofate components Encompass any
vulnerability caused by obsolete or
unmaintained software it can happen if
you construct or even use an application
without first learning about its scoree
components and
versions authentication failures
identification and authentication
failure which are previously known as
broken authentication enpass any
security issue involving user identities
identity attacks and exploitation may be
avoided by implementing secure session
Administration authentication and
validation for all identi entities in
the
organization in the next section let us
cover some of the protection mechanisms
employed by cyber security firms and
third party automated software to
prevent the application layer from being
bombarded with SQL injections and other
attacks the first is a web application
firewall or
WF a web application firewall monitors
and filters HTTP traffic between a web
application and the worldwide web web
application firewall architecture does
not add address all risks but it may be
used in conjunction with other defense
mechanisms it can used to the portfolio
of Security Solutions to provide a
comprehensive defense against diverse
attack roades it is a protocol layer 7
protection in the open systems
interconnection or the OSI model
Paradigm that helps defend online
application against attacks such as
cross-side scripting cross-side fraud
Escape injection and file
infusion unlike a proxy server which
conceals the ident of client computers
by an intermediary a functions as a
reverse proxy shielding the server from
exposure it acts as a barrier in front
of a web application protecting it from
the internet the clients must pass
through the web application firewall
before they can access the
application the second is threat
assessment a list of sensitive assets to
safeguard will assist you in
understanding the threat to your firm
and how to minimize them considering how
a hacker can infiltrate an application
if a existing security protections are
in place and whether additional tools or
defense capabilities are required it's
also crucial to keep your security
expectations in check nothing is
impenetrable even with the most
stringent security measures it would be
best if you were realistic about what
you believe your team can handle in the
long run when pushed to aggressively
safety regulations and procedures might
be disregarded remember that safety is a
lengthy and time-taking project that
requires the collaboration of other
employees and some sometimes even your
customers the next topic is privilege
management limiting privileges is vital
especially for Mission critical and
sensitive systems the least privileged
principle states that access to programs
and data should be limited to those who
require them when they require them for
two reasons the least privilege
principle is absolutely
critical the first is that hackers May
compromise less privileged accounts and
ensuring they do not acquire access to
highly sensitive systems is critical the
second is that internal dangers are
equally harmful as external adversaries
if insiders go bad it's critical to
ensure they never have more power than
they need minimizing the harm that they
may be able to cause to the
organization network security is a set
of technologies that protects the
usability and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself itself and
the applications that run over it
effective network security strategies
employ multiple lines of defense that
are scalable and automated each
defensive layer here enforces a set of
security policies which are determined
by the administrator beforehand this
aims at securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network the every company or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses so recently network
security has become the central topic of
cyber security with many organizations
involving applications from people with
skills in this area it is crucial for
both personal and professional networks
most houses with highspeed internet have
one or more wireless routers which can
be vulnerable to attacks if they're not
adequately
secured data loss theft and sabotage
risk may be decreased with the usage of
a strong network security system your
workstations are protected from
hazardous F thanks to network security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network by dividing information into
various sections encrypting these
portions and transferring them over
separate Pathways network security
infrastructure offers multiple levels of
protection to th man in the middle
attacks preventing situations like
eavesdropping among other harmful
attacks it is becoming increasingly
difficult in in today's hyperconnected
environment as more corporate
applications migrate to both public and
private clocks additionally modern
applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team Network traffic
and infrastructure must be protected in
these cases since assaults on businesses
are increasing every single day we now
understood the basics of network
security but we need to understand how
network security works in the next
section in slightly more detail network
security revolves around two processes
authentication and
authorization the first process which is
authentication is similar to access
cards which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building in other
words authentication checks and verifies
that it is indeed the user belonging to
the network is trying to access or enter
it thereby preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example Network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network based on the network users role
the process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network
architecture is complex and faces a
threat environment that is always
changing and attackers that are always
trying to find and exploit vulnerability
these vulnerabilities can exist in many
areas including devices data
applications users and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
downtime can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and its working
let's cover the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenet of
network security is the layering of
protection for massive networks and
store data that ensure the acceptance of
rules and regulations as a whole there
are three types the first of which is
physical security the next being
Technical and the third being
administrative let's look into physical
security first this is the most basic
level that includes protecting data and
Network netw to unauthorized Personnel
from acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network this
include external peripherals and routers
that might be used for cable connections
the same can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems physical
security is critical especially for
small businesses that do not have many
resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engage in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized users the other is a
defense against malevolent
actions the last category is
Administrative this level of network
security protects user Behavior like how
the permission has been granted and how
the authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks this
level also suggest necess necessary
amendments that have to be done to the
infrastructure I think that's all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security in which a next topic we're
going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties through the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employs lighter symmetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app player security can
lead to Performance and stability issues
in data theft and in some cases the
network being taken down examples of
application layer attacks include
distributed denal of service attacks or
DDOS attacks HTTP floods hql injections
cross-site scripting Etc most
organizations have an arsenal of
application layer security protections
to combat these and more such as web
application firewalls secure web Gateway
Services Etc now that we have the theory
behind network security has been covered
in detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security
policies the first tool to be covered in
the section is a firewall a firewall is
a type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow or deny in accordance
to a set of security rules for more than
25 years firewalls have served as
Network Security's first line of defense
they provide a barrier between
trustworthy inter internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some
point the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for short it's an
encrypted connection between a device
and a network via the Internet the ened
connection AIDS the secure transmission
of sensitive data it makes it impossible
for unauthorized parties to e stop on
the traffic and enables remote work for
the user the usage of VN techn
technology is common in both corporate
and personal networks next we cover the
importance of intrusion prision systems
in network security or IPS
framework an intrusion prevention system
is a network security tool that
continually scans the network for
harmful activity and response to it when
it does occur by reporting blocking or
discarding it it can be either Hardware
or softare it's more sophisticated than
an inion detection system or an IDs
framework which can just War an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an IPS it actually takes against that
activity the next tool in this section
and the final one are going to be
behavioral analytics behavioral
analytics focus more on the statistics
that are being carried over and stored
through months and years of usage on
some kind of similar pattern is noted
whe the it administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further
enhanced now that you have covered all
the we need to know about network
security the necessary tools it's
different types Etc let's go through the
benefits of network security as a
whole the first which is protection
against external threats the objective
for cyber assaults can be as varied as
the offenders themselves although
they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert the attacks are
getting
a strong cyber security posture that
considers routine software updates May
assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry
points the next benefit is protection
against internal threats the human
aspect continues to be the cyber
security systems weakest link Insider
risk can originate from current or
former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive
disasters the third benefit is increased
productivity it nearly impossible for
employees to function when Network and
personal devices are slow to a crawl by
viruses and other cyber attacks during
the operation of website and for the
company to run you may significantly
minimize violations and the amount of
downtime required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit f is brand
trust and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development customers today place a
premium on maintaining brand loyalty
through a strong cyber security stance
since this is the fastest way to get
other businesses back get referrals and
sell more tickets overall additionally
it helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities for potential future
Endeavors and development with the rise
in censorship and general fear over
privacy loss consumer security is at an
all-time high risk technology has made
our life so much easier while putting up
a decent Target on our personal
information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet an Anne wanted to look
for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50% discount on
the first purchase once Anne submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after devastated and
quickly realized she had failed to
notice that the website was a HTTP web
page instead of an https one the payment
information submitted was not encrypted
and it was visible to anyone keeping an
eye including the website owner and
hackers had she used a reputed website
which has encrypted transactions and
employees cryptography a rphone
Enthusiast could have avoided this
particular incident this is why it's
never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today we take a
look into what cryptography is and how
it works we learn where cryptography is
being used in our daily lives and how we
are benefiting from it then we will
understand the different types of
cryptography and their respective uses
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action let's Now
understand what cryptography
is cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties encryption is a primary route
for employing cryptography by adding
certain algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography for example when simply
learn is jumbled up or changed in any
format not many people can guess the
original word by looking at the
encrypted text the only ones who can are
the people who know how to decrypt the
coded word thereby reversing the process
of
encryption any data pre- encryption is
called plain text or clear text to
encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers they
are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plane text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
cipher text and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption
on receiving the message unless any
third party manages to find out both the
algorithm and the secret key that is
being used they cannot decrypt the
messages since both of them are
necessary to unlock the hidden content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for
cryptography any website where you have
an account can read your passwords
important emails can be intercepted and
their contents can be read without
encryption during the transit more than
65 billion messages are sent on WhatsApp
every day all of which are secured
thanks to endtoend
encryption there is a huge Market
opening up for cryptocurrency which is
possible due to blockchain technology
that uses encryption algorithms and
hashing functions to ensure that the
data is secure if this is of particular
interest to you you can watch our video
on blockchain the link of which will be
in the description of course there is no
single solution to a problem as diverse
as explained there are three variants of
how cryptography works and is in
practice they are symmetric encryption
asymmetric
encryption and hashing let's find out
how much we have understood until now do
you remember the difference between a
cipher and Cipher text leave your
answers in the comments and before we
proceed if you find this video
interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs up before moving ahead let's look
at symmetric encryption
first symmetric encryption uses a single
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data it is comparatively
less secure than asymmetric encryption
but much faster it is a compromise that
has to be embraced in order to deliver
data as fast as possible without living
information completely vulnerable this
type of encryption is used when data
rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times Caesar Cipher Enigma
machine are both symmetric encryption
examples that we will look into further
for example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message symmetric
encryption uses one of the two types of
ciphers stream ciphers and block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into Cipher text stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
Cipher text one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks in today's world the most
widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is AES 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard with has a
key size of 256bit with 128bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available other
primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the dees the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it
unreadable asymmetric encryption on the
other hand has a double whammy at its
disposal there are two different keys at
play here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiv
receiving the message Bob uses his own
private key to decrypt the data this way
nobody can inter accept the message in
between transmissions and there is no
need for any secure key exchange for
this to work since the encryption is
done with the public key and the
decryption is done with a private key
that no one except Bob has access to
both the keys are necessary to read the
full
message there is also a reverse scenario
where we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public the key can decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information RSA encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its Founders
reest Shamir and Adelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albate relatively slower
than a it is widely used in web browsing
secure identification vpns emails and
chat
applications with so much hanging on the
key secrecy there must be a way to
transmit the keys without others reading
our private data many systems use a
combination of symmetric encryption and
asymmetric encryption to bolster
security and match speed at the same
time since asymmetric encryption takes
longer to decrypt large amounts of data
the full information is is encrypted
using a single key that is symmetric
encryption that single key is then
transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the Diffy helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into the third
variant of cryptography is termed as
hashing hashing is a process of
scrambling a piece of data beyond
recognition it gives an output of fix
fixed size which is known as the hash
value of the original data or just hash
in general the calculations that do the
job of messing up the data collection
form the hash function they are
generally not reversible without
resilient Brute Force mechanisms and are
very helpful when storing data on
website servers that need not be stored
in plain text for example many websites
store your account pass words in a
hashed format so that not even the
administrator can read your credentials
when a user to login they can compare
the entered password's hash value with
the hash value that is already stored on
the servers for authentication since the
function will always return the same
value for the same
input cryptography has been in practice
for centuries Julius Caesar used a
substitution shift to move alphabets a
certain number of spaces beyond their
place in the alphabet table a spy can't
decipher the original message at first
glance for example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use a substitution shift
of plus two a becomes c b becomes D and
so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus
three becomes dww dfn this Cipher has
been appropriately named the Caesar
Cipher which is one of the most widely
used
algorithms the Enigma is probably the
most famous cryptographic Cipher device
used in ancient history it was used by
the Nazi German armies in the world wars
they were used to protect confidential
political military and administrative
information and it consisted of three or
more rotors that scrambled the original
message depending on the machine State
at that time the decryption is similar
but it needs both machines to stay in
the same state before passing the cipher
text so that we received the same plane
text message let's take a look at how
our data is protected while while we
browse the internet thanks to
cryptography here we have a web based
tool that will help us understand the
process of RSA encryption we see the
entire workflow from selecting the key
size to be used until the decryption of
the cipher text in order to get the
plain text back as we already know RSA
encryption algorithm falls under the
umbrella of asymmetry key
cryptography that basically implies that
we have two keys at play here a public
key and a private
key typically the the public key is used
by the sender to encrypt the message and
the private key is used by the receiver
to decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well in RSA we have the choice of key
size we can select any key from a
512-bit to 1024-bit all the way up to a
496 bit key the longer the key length
the more complex the encryption process
becomes and thereby strengthening the
cipher text although with added security
more complex functions take longer to
perform the same operations on similar
size of data we have to keep a balance
between both speed and strength because
the strongest encryption algorithms are
of no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here now
we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on past freezes the tool we are
using right now generates the sudo
random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other they cannot be substituted with
any other key and in order to encrypt
the original message or decrypt the
cipher text this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself in this
scenario let's try and encrypt a word
simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over
here the cipher we are using right now
is plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well once we click on
encrypt we can see the cipher text being
generated over
here the suder random generating
functions are created in such a way that
a single character change in the plain
text will trigger a completely different
Cipher text this is a security feature
to strengthen the process from Brute
Force methods now that we are done with
the encryption process let's take a look
at the decryption
part
the receiver gets this Cipher text from
the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always be the same used
during the encryption
process once we click decrypt you can
see the original plane text we had
decided to encrypt this sums of the ENT
entire process of RSA encryption and
decryption now some people use it the
other way around we also have the option
of using the private key to encrypt
information and the public key to
decrypt it this is done mostly to
validate the origin of the message since
the keys only work in pairs if a
different private key is used to encrypt
the message the public key cannot
decrypt it conversely if the public key
is able to decrypt the message it must
have been encrypted with the right
private key and hence the rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key and use that to encrypt the plain
text and select the same in this
checkbox as well you can see we have
generated a completely new Cipher text
this Cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for
decryption let's select the correct
checkbox and decrypt and we still get
the same
output now let's take a look at
practical example of encryption in the
real
world we all use the internet on a daily
basis and many are aware of the
implications of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at Wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
H stands for secured let's take a look
at how it secures the
data wi shck is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level
and we are going to use this software to
see the traffic that is leaving a
machine and to understand how vulnerable
it
is since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to
[Music]
Wikipedia let's search for something
that we can navigate the website
with okay once we get into it a little
you can see some of the requests being
populated over
here let's take a look at the specific
request these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice
versa as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way to put this in
perspective let's take a look at another
website which is a HTTP web
page this has no encryption enabled from
the server end which makes it vulnerable
to attacks there is a login form here
which needs legitimate user credentials
in order to Grant access let's enter a
random pair of
credentials these obviously won't work
but we can see the manner of data
transfer unsurprisingly we weren't able
to get into the platform instead we can
see the data
packets let's apply a similar filter
that will help us understand
what request this website is
sending these are the requests being
sent by the HTTP login form to the
internet if we check here see whatever
username and password that we are
entering we can easily see it with the
wire shockk now we used a dummy pair of
credentials if we select the right data
packet we can find our correct
credentials if any website had asked for
a payment information or a legitimate
credentials it would have been really
easy to get a hold of these to reiterate
what we have already learned we must
always avoid HTTP websites and just
unknown or not trustworthy websites in
general because the problem we saw here
is just the tip of the iceberg even
though cryptography has managed to
lessen the risk of cyber attacks it is
still prevalent and we should always be
alert to keep us s safe online there are
two types of encryption in
cryptography symmetric key
cryptography and asymmetric key
cryptography both of these categories
have their pros and cons and differ only
by the implementation today we are going
to focus exclusively on symmetry key
cryptography let us have a look at its
applications in order to understand its
importance
better this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving onto
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial symmetric cryptography
helps in detecting bank fraud and boost
the security index of these payment
gateways in
general they are also helpful in
protecting data that is not in transit
and rests on servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no
delay while browsing the internet we
need symmetric encryption to browse
secure https websites so that we get an
allaround protection it plays a
significant rol in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security this helps us in
preventing the rather insecure http
website
format so let us understand how
symmetric key cryptography works first
before moving on to the specific
algorithms symmetric key cryptography
relies on a single key for the
encryption and decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into Cipher text and vice
versa as you can see in the image the
key used for encryption is the same key
needed for decrypting the message at the
other end the secret key shouldn't be
sent along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the defy Helman
key exchange protocol for
example for example if Paul wants to
send a simple message to Jane they need
to have a single encryption key that
both of them must keep secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious
actors it can be generated by either one
of them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into Cipher text using a
specific substitution Cipher by Paul in
that case Jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decrypt the cipher
text once it reaches her irrespective of
the scenario where someone manages to
grab the cipher text mid transit to try
and read the message not having the
secret key renders everyone helpless
looking to snow in the symmetric key
algorithms like the data encryption
standard have been in use since the
1970s while the popular ones like the
EES have become the industry standard
today with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
whes of Paramount importance to keep it
secret on All
Occasions the side effect of having a
single key for the encryption and
decryption is it becomes a single point
of failure anyone who gets their hand on
it can read all the encrypted messages
and do so mainly without the knowledge
of the sender and the receiver so it is
the priority to keep the encryption and
decryption keep private at all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin if the sender somehow
transmits the secret key along with the
cipher text anyone can intercept the
package and access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's Integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public provided we manage to keep the
key secret we still have to choose what
kind of ciphers we want to use to
encrypt this information in symmetric
key phography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a
look stream ciphers are the algorithms
that encre basic information one bit at
a time it can change depending on the
algorithm being used but usually it's
relies on a single bit or bite to do the
encryption this is the relatively
quicker alternative considering the
algorithm doesn't have to deal with
blocks of data at a single time every
piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to to be
converted into binary format in stream
ciphers each binary digit is encrypted
one after the other the most popular
ones are the rc4 salsa and Panama the
binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bitstream upon passing it
through we receive the cipher text that
can be transferred to the receiver
without fear of man in the middle
attacks the binary data can be passed
through an algorithmic function it can
have either X or operations as it is
most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or heximal format to give our final
Cipher
text on the other hand block ciphers
dissect their raw information into
chunks of data of fixed size the size of
these blocks depend on the exact Cipher
being being used a 128bit block Cipher
will break the plain text into blocks of
128bit each and encrypt those blocks
instead of a single digit once these
blocks are encrypted individually they
are chained together to form a final
Cipher
text block ciphers are much slower but
they are more tamper proof and are used
in some of the most widely used
algorithms employed
today just like stream ciphers the
original Cipher text is converted into
binary format before beginning the
process
once the conversion is complete the
blocks are passed through the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us with the encrypted
blocks of binary
data once these blocks are combined we
get a final binary
string this string is then converted
into hexadecimal format to get a cyer
text today the most popular symmetric
key algorithms like AES Dees and 3
are all block Cipher methodology
subsets with so many factors coming into
play there are quite a few things
symmetrically cryptography excels at
while falling short in some
other symmetrically cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography there is
only one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption similarly the performance of
symmetric encryption is much more
efficient under similar computational
limitations fewer calculations help in
better memory management for the host
system bulk amounts of data that need to
be encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetry key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication Channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret Keys is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday Communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can encpt
vast amounts of data with very less
overhead Dees algorithm stands for data
encryption standard
it is a symmetric key Cipher that is
used to encrypt and recpt information in
a block byblock manner each block is
encrypted individually and they're later
chained together to form our final
Cipher text which is then sent to a
receiver DS takes the original unaltered
piece of data called the plain text in a
64-bit block and it is converted into an
encrypted text that is called the cipher
text it uses 48 bit Keys during the
encryption process and follows a
specific structure called the the fistal
Cipher structure during the entire
process it is a symmetric key algorithm
which means DS can reuse the keys used
in the encrytion format to decrypt the
cipher text back to the original plain
text once the 64-bit blocks are
encrypted they can be combined together
before being
transmitted let's take a look at the
origin and the reason thees was
founded DS is based on a fistal block
Cipher called Lucifer developed in 1971
by IBM cryptography researcher host
fistal Dees uses 16 rounds of this
fistal structure using a different key
for each round it also utilizes a random
function with two inputs and provides a
single output
variable DS becames the organization's
approved encryption standard in November
1976 and was later reaffirmed as a
standard in 1983 1988 and finally in
1999 but eventually DS was cracked and
it was no longer considered a secure
solution for all official routs of
communication consequently triple Ds was
developed triple Ds is a symmetric key
block Cipher that uses a double Ds
Cipher encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple Ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using DS for encrypting messages in
order to search for a better alternative
a public wide competition was organized
and helped cryptographers develop their
own algorithm as a proposal for the next
global standard this is where the rile
algorithm came into play and was later
credited to be the next Advanced
encryption standard for a long time DS
was the standard for data encryption for
data security its rule ended in 2002
when finally the advanced encryption
standard replace Dees as an acceptable
standard following a public competition
for a
place to understand the structure of a
fistal Cipher we can use the following
image as a reference the block being
encrypted is divided into two parts one
of which is being passed onto the
function while the other part is exord
with the function's output the function
also uses the encryption key that
differs for each individual round this
keeps going on until the last step until
where the right hand side and the left
hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final Cipher text for the
decryption process the entire procedure
is reversed starting from the order of
the keys to the block sorting if the
entire process is repeated in a reverse
order we will eventually get back our
plane text and this Simplicity helps the
speed overall This was later detrimental
to the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was
compromised a fistal block BL Cipher is
a structure used to derive many symmetri
block ciphers such as Dees which as we
have discussed in our previous
comment pistal Cipher proposed a
structure that implements substitution
and permutation alternately so that we
can obtain Cipher text from the plain
text and vice versa this helps in
reducing the redundancy of the program
and increases the complexity to combat
Brute Force
attacks the fistal Cipher is actually
based on the Shannon structure that was
proposed in 1945 the fistel Cipher is
the structure suggested by horse feistel
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers the Shannon structure highlights
the implementation of alternate
confusion and diffusion and like we
already discussed the fistal Cipher
structure can be completely reversed
depending on the data however we must
consider the fact that to decrypt the
information by reversing the fal
structure we will need the exact
polinomial functions and the key
orders to understand how the blocks are
being calculated we take a plane test
which is of 64bit and that is later
divided into two equal halves of 32 bit
each in this the right half is
immediately transferred to the next
round to become the new Left half of the
second round the right hand is again
passed off to a function which uses an
encryption key that is unique to each
round in the fistal Cipher whatever the
function gives off as an output it is
passed on has an exor input with the
left half of the initial plane text the
next output will become the right half
of the second round for the plane text
this entire process constitutes of a
single round in the fistal
Cipher taking into account what happens
in the polinomial
function we take one half of the block
and pass it through an expansion box the
work of the expansion box is to increase
the size of the half from 32bit to 48
bit text
this is done to make the text compatible
to a 48 bit Keys we have generated
beforehand once we pass it through the
XO function we get a 48-bit text as an
output now remember a half should be of
32-bit so this 48-bit output is then
later passed on to a substitution box
this substitution box reduces its size
from 48 bit to 32bit Output which is
then later exort with the first half of
the plain
text
a block Cipher is considered the safest
if the size of the block is large but
large block sizes can also slow on
encryption speed and the decryption
speed generally the size is
64bit sometimes modern block ciphers
like AES have a 128bit block size as
well the security of the block CER
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process earlier 64-bit
keys were considered sufficient modern
ciphers need to use 128bit Keys due to
the increasing complexity of today's
computational
standards the increasing number of
rounds also increase the security of the
block Cipher similarly they're inversely
proportional to the speed of
encryption a highly complex round
function enhances the security of the
block Cipher albeit we must maintain a
balance between the speed and
security the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed there is
no use of an algorithm it it cannot be
implemented in a real life framework
that can help organizations to encrypt
or decrypt the data in a timely manner
now that we understand the basics of FAL
ciphers we can take a look at how Dees
manages to run through 16 rounds of the
structure and provide the cipher text at
the end now that we understand the
basics of FAL cyers we can take a look
at how d DS manages to run through 16
rounds of this structure and provide a
cipher text in simple terms DS takes the
64bit plain text and converts it into a
64-bit Cipher text and since we are
talking about asymmetric algorithms the
same key is being used when it is
decrypting the data as
well we first take a 64bit plane text
and we pass it to an initial permutation
function the initial permutation
function has the job of dividing the
block into two different parts so that
we can perform fistal Cypher structures
on
it there are multiple rounds being
procured in the DS algorithm namely 16
rounds of FAL Cipher structure each of
these rounds will need keys initially we
take a 56 bit Cipher key but it is a
single key we pass it onto a round key
generators which generates 16 different
keys for each single round that the
fistal Cipher is being run these keys
are passed on to the rounds as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bits ke is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation Bongs in the polinomial
functions of the faal
ciphers when passing through all these
rounds we reach round 16 where the final
key is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the RS are
swapped and we get a final Cipher text
this is the entire process of Dees with
16 rounds of FAL ciphers encompassed in
it to decrypt a cipher text pack to the
plain text we just have to reverse the
process we did in the DS algorithm and
reverse the key order along with the
functions this kind of Simplicity is
what gave Dees the bonus when it comes
to speed but eventually it was
detrimental to the overall efficiency of
the program when it comes to security
factors DS have five different modes of
operation to choose from this one of
those is electronic code book each
64-bit block is encrypted and decrypted
independently in the electronic code
book format we also have Cipher block
chaining or the CBC method here each
64-bit block depends on the previous one
and all of them use an initialization
Vector we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding Cipher
text becomes the input for the
encryption algorithm it produces a sued
a random output which in turn is exor
with the plain
text there is an output feedback method
as well which is the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding
DS counter method has a different way of
approach where each PL text block is
exor with an encrypted counter the
counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by cryptographers
worldwide let's take a look at the
future of
Dees the dominance of Dees ended in 2002
when the advanced encryption standard
replaced the DS encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done
following a public competition to find a
replacement nist officially withdrew the
global acceptance standard in May 2005
although triple Ds is approved for some
sensitive government information through
20130 an isg also had to change the DS
algorithm because its key length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the key
and DS found itself a victim of ongoing
technological advances in Computing we
have received a point where 56-bit was
no longer a challenge to the computers
of cracking note that because DS is no
longer the nist federal standard it does
not mean that it is no longer in use
triple Ds is still used today and is
still considered a legacy encryption
algorithm to get a better understanding
of how these keys and cyer text look
like we can use an online tool for our
benefit as we already know to encrypt
any kind of data a key is mandatory this
key can be generated using mathematical
functions or computerized key generation
program such as this website offers it
can be based on any piece of text let's
say the word is simply
[Music]
learn in our
example once the key is settled we
provide the plain text or the clear text
that needs to be encrypted using the a
mention key suppose a sentence for this
example is this is my first
message we have satisfied two
prerequisites the message and the key
another variable that goes into play is
the mode of
operation we have already learned about
five different modes of operation while
we can see some other options here as
well let us go with the CBC variant
which basically means the cipher block
chaining method one of of cbc's key
characteristics is that it uses a
chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of Cipher text to
depend all on the preceding Cipher text
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjustment blocks as well a
single bit error in a cipher text block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks rearrangement of the
order of these for example can cause the
decryption process to get corrupted
regarding the man of displaying binary
information we have two options here we
can either go with base 64 or the
heximal format let's go with the base 64
right
now as you can see the cipher text is
readily available b64 is a little more
efficient than a hex so we will be
getting a smaller Cipher text when it
comes to B
64 albe the size of both the formats
will be the same the hex has a longer
Cipher text since basic 64 takes four
characters for every three bytes while
hex will take two characters for each B
hence B 64 turns out to be more
efficient now to decut the cipher text
we go by the same format we choose Bas
64 we copy the cipher text onto a
decryption tool and we have to make sure
that the key we are using is exactly the
same we choose similar mode of
operation and we choose the correct
encoding format as well which is base 64
in this
case as you can see the decryption is
complete and we get a plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt
anything unfortunately DS has become
rather easy to crack even without the
help of a key the advanced encryption
standard is still on top when it comes
to symmetric encryption security and
will likely stay there for a while
eventually with so much computing power
growth the need for a stronger algorithm
was necessary to safeguard a personal
data as solid as de was the computers of
today could easily break the encryption
with repeated attempts thereby rendering
the data security helpless to counter
this dilemma a new standard was
introduced which was termed as the
advanced encryption standard or the AES
algorithm let's learn what is Advanced
encryption
standard
the AES algorithm also known as the
reile algorithm is a symmetric block
Cipher with a block size of 128 bits it
is converted into Cipher text using keys
of 128 192 or 256 bits it is implemented
in software and Hardware throughout the
world to encrypt sensitive data the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as n started
development on AES in 1997 when it was
announced announced the need for an
alternative to the data encryption
standard the new internet needed a
replacement for Dees because of its
small key size with increasing computing
power it was considered unsafe against
entire key search attacks the triple Ds
was designed to overcome this problem
however it was deemed to be too slow to
be deployed in machines
worldwide strong cases were present by
the Mars rc6 Serpent and the twofish
algorithms but it was the rindal
encryption algorithm also known as AES
which was eventually chosen as the
standard symmetric key encryption
algorithm to be used its section was
formalized with the release of federal
information processing standards
publication 197 in the November of 2001
it was approved by the US Secretary of
Commerce now that we understand the
origin of AES let us have a look at the
features that make AES encryption
algorithm
unique the AES algorithm uses a
substitution permutation or SP Network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a cipher text it has a series of
linked operations including replacing
inputs with specific outputs that is
substitutions and others that involve
bit shuffling which is
permutations at the beginning of the
encryption process we only start out
with a single key which can be either a
128bit key a 192bit key or a 256bit key
eventually this one key is expanded to
be used in multiple rounds throughout
the encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on bite data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the dees
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16 bytes the
number of rounds during the encryption
process depends on the key size that is
being used the 128bit key size fixes 10
Rounds the 192bit key size fixes 12
rounds and the 256bit key holds 14
rounds a round key is required for each
of these rounds but since only one key
is input into the algorithm the single
key needs to be expanded to get the key
for each round including the round
zero with so many mathematical
calculations going on in the background
there are bound to be a lot of steps
throughout the procedure let's have a
look at the steps followed in
AES before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES
encryption everything in the process is
stored in a 4 into 4 Matrix
format this Matrix is also known as a
state array and we'll be using these
State arrays to transmit data from one
step to another and from one round to
the next
round each round takes straight array as
input and gives a straight array as
output to be transferred into the next
round it is a 16 by matrix with each
cell representing one bite with each
four bytes representing a word so every
state array will have a total of four
words representing
it as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expanded to the number of
rounds that we need the key to be used
in let's say the number of rounds are n
then the key has to be expanded to be
used with n+1 rounds because the first
round is the key zero round
let's say n is the number of rounds the
key is expanded to n + 1 rounds it is
also a state array having four words in
its vicinity every key is used for a
single round and the first key is used
as a round key before any round
begins in the very beginning the plane
text is captured and passed through an
exor function with the round key as a
supplement this key can be considered
the first key from the n+1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a bite
substitution
process beyond that there is a provision
to shift rows in the state arrays later
on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mixed column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round the last four steps mentioned are
part of every sing single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input in the
last round however we skip the mix
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining
unchanged but what are these bite
substitution and row shifting processes
let's find out regarding each step in
more
detail in the first step the plane text
is stored in a state array and is exor
with the k0 which is the first first key
in the expanded key set this step is
performed only once on a block while
being repeated at the end of each round
as per iteration
demands the state array is exor with the
key to get a new state array which is
then passed office input to the sub byes
process in the second stage we have bite
substitution we leverage an Xbox called
as a substitution box to randomly switch
data among each element every single
bite is converted into hexadecimal value
having two parts the first part denotes
the row value and the second part
denotes the column value the entire
State array is passed through the sbox
to create a brand new state array which
is then passed off as an input to the
row shifting process the 16 input bytes
are replaced by looking at a fixed table
given in the design we finally get a
matrix with four rows and four
columns when it comes to row shifting
each bit in the four rows of the Matrix
is shifted to the left an entry that is
a fall off is reinserted to the right of
the line the change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left the third line is
shifted two positions to the left and
the fourth line is shifted three
positions to the left the result is a
new Matrix that contains the same 16
bytes but has been moved in relation to
each other to boost the complexity of
the
program in mixed columns each column of
four bytes is now replaced using a
special mathematical function the
function takes four bytes of a column as
input and outputs for completely new
bytes we will get a new Matrix with the
same size of 16 bytes and it should be
noted that this phase has not been done
in the last round of the
iteration when it comes to adding a
round key the the 16 bytes of the Matrix
are treated as 128 bits and the 128 bits
of the round key are exort if it is the
last round the output is the cipher text
if you still have a few rounds remaining
the resulting 128 bits are interpreted
as 16 bytes and we start another similar
round let's take an example to
understand how all these processes work
if our plane text is the string
2192 we first convert it into to a
heximal format as follows we use an
encryption key which is that's my K Fu
and it is converted into a hexad desmal
format as
well as per the guidelines we use a
single key which is then later expanded
into n + 1 number of keys in which case
it's supposed to be 11 keys for 10
different
rounds in round zero we add the round
key the plane test is exort with the k0
and we get a state array that is passed
off as an input to the substitution byes
process when it comes to the
substitution bytes process we leverage
an sbox to substitute the elements of
each bite with a completely new bite
this way the state array that we receive
is passed off as an input to the row
shifting process on the next
step when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three the state array that we received
from the row shifting is passed off as
an input to mix columns in mix columns
we multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which I receive a
new state array to be passed on onto the
next
step we add the new state array as an
exor with the round key of the
particular iteration whatever state
array we receive here it becomes an
output for this particular
round now since this is the first round
of the entire encryption process the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the new
Round We repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text once the final State array can be
denoted as in the hexadecimal format
this becomes our final Cipher text that
we can use for transferring information
from the sender and
receiver let's take a look at the
applications of AES in this
world AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients highly secure
mechanisms like WPA and WPA2 psk are
extensively used in securing Wi-Fi
endpoints with the help of RI
algorithm it also helps in SSL TLS
encryption that is instrumental in
encrypting our internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for
communication AES is also prevalent in
general file encryption of various
formats ring from critical documents to
the media files having a large key
allows people to encrypt media and
decrypt data with maximum security
possible AES is also used for processor
Security in Hardware Appliances to
prevent machine hijacking among other
things as a direct successor to the dees
algorithm there are some aspects that
eses provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a
look
when it comes to key length the biggest
flaw in DS algorithm was that small
length was easily vulnerable by today's
standards eses has managed to NAB up 128
192 and 256bit key lens to bolster the
security further the block size is also
larger in AES owing to more complexity
of the algorithm the number of rounds in
Dees is fixed irrespective of the plane
text being used in AES the number of
round depends on the key length that is
being used for the particular iteration
thereby providing more Randomness and
complexity in the
algorithm the dees algorithm is
considered to be simpler than AES even
though AES beats Dees when it comes to
relative speed of encryption and
decryption this makes Advanced
encryption standard much more
streamlined to be deployed in Frameworks
and systems worldwide when it compares
to the data encryption standard hello in
a last video on crypto cryptography we
took a look at symmetric key
cryptography we used a single private
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data and it works very
well in theory let's take a look at a
more realistic scenario now let's meet
Joe Joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with Ryan via long-distance
messaging due to the critical nature of
the information people are waiting for
any message to leave Joe's house so that
they can intercept it now Joe can easily
use symmetric cryptography to send the
encrypted data so that even if someone
intercepts the message they cannot
understand what it says but here's the
tricky part how will Joe send the
required decryption key to Ryan the
sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily key share sharing is
a risk that will always exist when
symmetric key cryptography is being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this
problem this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on asymmetry key
cryptography let's take a look at what
we are going to learn today We Begin by
explaining what asymmetry key
cryptography is and how it works we take
a look at its application and uses we
understand why it's called publicly
cryptography and then learn a little bit
about RS encryption
and then we learn about the advantages
of asymmetric key cryptography over
symmetric key
cryptography let's understand what
asymmetry key cryptography
is asymmetry encryption uses a double
layer of protection there are two
different keys at play here a private
key and a public key a public key is
used to encrypt the information pre-
Transit and a private key is used to
decrypt the data post Transit these pair
of keys must be belong to the receiver
of the message the public keys can be
shared via messaging blog posts or key
servers and there are no restrictions as
you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
cipher text the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt it and get the
plain text back there has been no
requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key
cryptography the public key known to
everyone cannot be used to decrypt the
message and the private key which can
decp the message need not be shared with
anyone the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys as often as
possible to understand this better take
the analogy of your
mailbox anyone who wants to send you a
letter has access to the box and can
easily set in information with you in a
way you can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it this
is how the private key comes to play no
one can intercept the message and read
its contents since it's encrypted once
the receiver gets its contents he can
use his private key to decrypt the
information both the public key and the
private key are generated so they are
interl and you cannot substitute other
private keys to the data in another
example if Alice wants to send a message
to Bob let's say tre's call me today she
must use Bob's public key while
encrypting the message upon receiving
the cipher message Bob can proceed to
use his private key in order to decrypt
the message and hence complete Security
is attained during transmission without
any need for sharing the
key since this type of encryption is
highly secure it has many users in areas
that require High
confidentiality it is used to manage
digital signatures so there is valid
proof of a document's authenticity with
so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography senders can now sign
documents with their private Keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sender's
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with with duplicate Keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
similar
approach in blockchain architecture
asymmetric key cryptography is used to
authorize transactions and maintain the
system thanks to its two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain's peer-to-peer Network only
if it is approved from both ends along
with asymmetry key KP rography stamp
appro architecture its non- repudiation
characteristic also helps in keeping the
network
stable we can also use asymmetric key
cryptography combined with symmetric key
cryptography to monitor SSL or TLS
encryptor browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal up personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general it
plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption Keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure HTTP website
format security parameters differ on a
session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to Modern data
security another great use of the
asymmetric key cryptography structure is
transmitting keys for symmetric key
cryptography with the most significant
difficulty in symmetric encryption being
key exchange asymmetric keys can help
clear the shortcoming the original mage
message is first encrypted using a
symmetry key the key used for encrypting
the data is then converted into the
cipher text using the receiver's public
key now we have two Cipher text to
transmit to the receiver on receiving
both of them the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt the Symmetry key
he can then use it to decrypt the
original information on getting the key
used to encrypt the data while this may
seem more complicated than just
asymmetric key cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions encrypting the key
using asymmetric algorithms will
definitely be more memory efficient and
secure you might remember us discussing
why symmetric encryption was called
private key cryptography let us
understand why asymmetric falls under
the public key
cryptography we have two keys at our
disposal the encryption key is available
to everyone the decryption key is
supposed to be
private unlike symmetric key
cryptography there is no need to share
anything privately to have an encrypted
messaging system to put that into
perspective we share our email address
with anyone looking to communicate with
us it is supposed to be public by Design
so that our email login credentials are
private and they help in preventing any
data mishandling since there is nothing
hidden from the world if they want to
send us any encrypted information this
category is called the public key
cryptography there are quite a few
algorithms being used today that follow
the architecture of asymmetric
cryptography none more famous than the
RS
encryption RS encryption is the most
widely used encryption or public
encryption standard using asymmetry key
approach named after its Founders reest
Shamir and Adelman it uses block ciphers
to obscure the information if you are
unfamiliar with how block ciphers work
they are encryption algorithms that
divide the original data into blocks of
equal size the the block size depends on
the exact Cipher being used once they
are broken down these blocks are
encrypted individually and later chained
together to form the final Cipher
text widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption albate
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat
applications with so many variables in
play there must be some advantages that
get asymmetric key cryptography and Edge
over the traditional symmetric
encryption methodologies let's go
through some of
them there is no need for any reliable
key sharing channel in asymmetric
encryption it was an added risk in
private key cryptography that has been
completely eliminated in public key
architecture the key which is made
public cannot recpt any confidential
information and the only key that can
decrypt doesn't need to be shared
publicly under any
circumstance we have have much more
extensive key lens in RSA encryption and
other asymmetric algorithms like 248 bit
key and 496 bit Keys larger keys are
much harder to break into via brute
force and are much more
secure asymmetry key cryptography can
use as a proof of authenticity since
only the rightful owner of the keys can
generate the messages to be decrypted by
the private key the situation can also
be reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the
owner it also has a tamper protection
feature where the message cannot be
intercepted and changed without
invalidating the private key used to
encrypt the data consequently the public
key cannot equip the message and it is
easy to realize the information is not
100% legitimate when and where the case
requires now that we have a proper
revision let's understand what digital
sign signatures are before moving on to
the
algorithm the objective of digital
signatures is to authenticate and verify
documents and data this is necessary to
avoid tampering and digital modification
or forgery of any kind during the
transmission of official
documents they work on the public key
cryptography architecture with one
exception typically an asymmetry key
system encrypts using a public key and
decrypts with a private key for digital
signatures however the reverse is
true the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are ink
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document therefore by
verifying the signatures Provence let's
go through each step to understand the
procedure
thoroughly in step one we have M which
is the original plane text message and
it is passed on to a hash function
denoted by H hash to create a
digest next it bundles the message
together with the hash digest and
encrypts it using the senders private
key it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender public
key once the message is decrypted it is
passed to the same hash function H hash
to generate a similar Digest
it compares the newly generated hash
with the bundled hash value received
along with the message if they match it
verifies data
Integrity in many instances they provide
a layer of validation and security to
messages through non-secure Channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender digital signatures are equivalent
to traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type digital
signature schemes in the sense used here
are cryptographically based and must be
implemented properly to be effective
they can also provide non- repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret further some
non-repudiation schemes offer a Tim
stamp for the digital signature so that
even if the private key is exposed the
signature is valid to implement the
concept of digital signature in real
world we have two primary algorithms to
follow the RSA algorithm and the DSA
algorithm but the latter is a topic of
learning today so let's go ahead and see
what the digital signature algorithm is
supposed to
do digital signature algorithm is fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures it was proposed in 1991 and
globally standardized in 1994 by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as the N it
functions on the framework of modular
exponation and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute
system unlike DSA most signature types
are generated by signing message digest
with the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data since just the message Digest is
signed the signature is generally much
smaller compared to the data that was
signed as a result digital signatures
impose less load on processors at the
time of signing execution and they use
small volumes of bandwidth DSA on the
other hand does not encrypt message
digest using private key or decp message
digest using public key instead it uses
mathematical functions to create a
digital signature consisting of two 160
bit numbers which are originated from
the message digests and the private key
DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with RSA DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication Integrity
verification and non-
repudiation in the image we can see the
entire process of DSF validation a plain
text message is passed onto a hash
function where the digest is generated
which is passed onto a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g a
random variable K and the private key of
the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by S and
R on the receiver end we pass the plane
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message d digest it is
passed onto verification function which
has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender Global variable
G and SNR received from the
sender the value generated by the
function is then compared to R if they
match then the verification process is
complete and data Integrity is verified
this was an overview of the way the DSA
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarith MC functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next
section we have three phases here the
first of which is key generation to
generate the keys we need some
prerequisites we select a que which
becomes a prime divisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus 1 mod Q
equal to 0 we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the screen
right now
once these values are selected we can go
ahead with generating the keys the
private key can be denoted by X and it
is any random integer that falls between
the bracket of zero and the value of Q
the public key can be calculated as y =
g ^ x mod P where y stands for the
public key the private key can then be
packaged as a one bundle which comprises
of values of p q G and X similarly the
public key can also be packaged as a
bundle having the values of p q G and
Y once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this
generation repeat once the keys are
generated we can start generating the
signature the message is passed through
a hash function to generate the digest H
first we can choose any random integer K
which falls under the bracket of0 and Q
to calculate the first 160 bit number of
ass signing function of r we use the
formula G ^ K mod P into mod Q similarly
to calculate the value of the second
output that is s we use the following
formula that is shown on the
screen the signature can then be
packaged as a bundle having R and
S this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver
now with the third phase we have to
verify the signature we first calculate
the message digest received in the
bundle by passing it to the same hash
function we calculate the value of w U1
and U2 using the formulas shown on the
screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of R being
sent by the sender this verification
component can be calculated using the
following formula once calculated this
can be compared with the value of R if
the values match then the signature
verification is successful and the
entire process is complete starting from
Key generation to the signature
Generation all the way up to the
verification of the
signature with so many steps to follow
we are bound to have a few advantages to
boot this and we would be right to think
so DSA is highly robust in the security
and stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the Simplicity and
the flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other
suits the key generation is much faster
when compared to the RSA algorithm and
such while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of
Frameworks DSA requires Less storage
space to work its entire cycle in
contrast its direct correspondent that
is RSA algorithm needs a certain amount
of computational and storage space to
function efficiently this is not the
case with DSA which has been optimized
to work with weaker hardware and lesser
resources the DSA is patented but nist
has made this patent available worldwide
royaltyfree a draft version of the
speculation fips 1865 in indicates that
DSA will no longer be approved for
digital signature generation but it may
be used to verify signatures generated
prior to the implementation date of that
standard the RSA algorithm is a publicly
signature algorithm developed by Ron
rivest ADI Shamir and Leonard Edelman
the paper was first published in 1977
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand root force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment RSA can also encrypt and
decrypt general information to securely
exchange data along with handling
digital signature verification let us
understand how it achiev this we take
our plain text message M we pass it
through a hash function to generate the
digest H which is then encrypted using
the sender's private key this is
appended to the original plane text
message and sent over to the
receiver once the receiver receives the
bundle we can pass the plane text
message with the same hash function to
generate a digest and the cipher text
can be decrypted using the public key of
the sender the remaining hashes are
compared if the values match then the
data Integrity is verified and the
sender is authenticated apart from
digital signatures the main case of RSA
is encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge this is
where the data encryption comes into
play when using RS say for encryption
and decryption of General data it
reverses the key set usage unlike
signature verification it receives the
receiver's public key to encrypt the
data and uses the receiver's private key
in decrypting the data thus there is no
need to exchange any keys in this
scenario there are two broad components
when it comes to RSA cryptography one of
them is key generation key generation
emploees a step of generating the
private and the public keys that are
going to be used for encrypting and
decrypting the data the second part is
the encryption and decryption functions
these are the ciphers and steps that
need to be run when scrambling the data
or recovering the data from the cipher
text you will Now understand each of
these steps in our next
subtopic keeping the previous two
concepts in mind let us go ahead and see
how the entire process works starting
from creating the keeper to encrypting
and decrypting the
information you need to generate the
public and private Keys before running
the function functions to generate
Cipher text and plain text they use
certain variables and parameters all of
which are explained we first use two
large prime numbers which can be denoted
by P and Q we can compute the value of n
as n = p into q and compute the value of
Zed as P minus1 into Q
-1 a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number D is also selected at random
following the formula Ed mod Z equal to
one and it can be calculated with the
formula given
below the public key is then packaged as
a bundle with n and E and the private
key is packaged as a bundle using n and
D this sums of the key generation
process for the encryption and
decryption function we use the formula C
and M the cipher Tex can be calculated
as c = m ^ e mod n and the pl text can
be calculated from the cipher text as C
power D mod n when it comes to a data
encryption example let's take p and Q as
7 and 13 the value of n can be
calculated as
91 if we select the value of e to be
five it satisfy all the criteria that we
needed to the value of D can be
calculated using the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91a 5 and the
private key can then be packaged as 91a
the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m Cipher text can be
calculated the formula C = to M to the^
e mod n which gives us 82 if somebody
receives this Cipher text they can
calculate the Plaine text using the
formula C to the^ D mod n which gives us
the value of 10 as selected as our plain
text we can now look at the factors that
make the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus
its competitors in the advantageous
topics of this lesson
RSA encryption depends on using the
receiver's public key so that you don't
have to share any secret key to receive
the messages from others this was the
most glaring flaw faced by symmetric
algorithms which were eventually fixed
by asymmetric cryptography
structure since the key pairs are
related to each other a receiver cannot
intercept the message since they didn't
have the correct private keys to decp
the information if a public key can decp
the information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private
anymore the encryption process is faster
than that of the DSA algorithm even if
the key generation is slower in RSA many
systems across the world tend to reuse
the same keys so that they can spend
less time in key generation and more
time on actual Cipher text
management data will be tamper proof in
transit since meddling with the data
will alter the usage of the keys the
private key won't be able to decrypt the
information hence alerting the receiver
of any kind of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
Transit the cases of which are rather
low imagine creating an account on a new
website you provide your email address
and set a password that you are
confident and you would not forget what
about the website owner how securely are
they going to store your password for
website administrators they have three
Alternatives they can either store the
passwords in a plain text format they
can encrypt the passwords using an
encryption and decryption key or they
can store the passwords in a hash value
let's have a look at each of these when
a password is stored in cleant text
format it is considered to be the most
unsafe option since anyone in the
company can read your passwords a single
hack and a data server breach will
expose all the accounts credentials
without without needing any extra
effort to counter this owners can
encrypt the passwords and keep them in
the servers as a second alternator but
that would mean they also have to store
the decryption key somewhere on their
servers in the event of a data breach or
the server hack both the decryption key
and encrypted passwords will be leaked
thus making it a single point of
failure what if there was an option to
store the passwords after scrambling
them completely but with no way to
decrypt them this is where hash comes to
play since only the hashed values are
stored in the server no encryption is
needed with no plain text passwords to
protect your credentials are safe from
the website administrators considering
all the pros hashed passwords are the
industry standard when it comes to
storing credentials
nowadays before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing
Works hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of information or
data beyond recognition we can achieve
this by using hash functions which are
essentially algorithms that perform
mathematical operations on the main PL
text the value generated after passing
the plain text information through the
hash function is called the hash value
digest or in general just the hash of
the original data while this may sound
similar to encryption the major
difference is hashes are meant to be
irreversible no decryption key can
convert a Digest back to its original
value however a few hashing algorithms
have been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in use among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification
Etc like we discussed earlier websites
use hashing to store the users passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords when a user signs up to create
a new account the password is then run
through the hash function and the
resulting hash value is stored on the
servers so the next time a user comes to
log to the account the password he
enters is passed to the same hash
function and compared to the hash stored
on the main server if the newly
calculated hash is the same as the one
stored on the website server the
password must have been correct because
according to Hash functions terminology
same inputs will always provide the same
outputs if the hashes do not match then
the password entered during login is not
the same as the password entered during
the signup hence the login will be
denied this way no plain text passwords
get stored preventing both the owner
from snooping on user data and
protecting users privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack apart from password storage hashing
can also be used to perform Integrity
checks when a file is uploaded on the
internet the files hash value is
generated and it is uploaded along with
the original information when a new user
downloads the file he can calculate the
digest of the downloaded file using the
same hash function when the hash values
are compared if they match then file
Integrity has been maintained and there
has been no data
corruption since so much important
information is being passed under the
hash function we need to understand how
they
work a hash function is a set of
mathematical calculations operated on
two blocks of data the main input is
broken down into two blocks of similar
size the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being
used hash functions are designed to be
one way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised but more secure algorithms
are being used today like the Sha F of
algorithms the digest size is also
dependent on the the respective
algorithm being used md5 has a digest of
128 bits while sh 256 has a digest of
256 bits this digest must always be the
same for the same input irrespective of
how many times the calculations are
carried out this is a very crucial
feature since comparing the hash value
is the only way to check if the data is
untouched as the functions are not
reversible there are certain
requirements of a hash function that
need to be met before they are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
Security in the long
run the hash function must be quick
enough to encrypt large amounts of data
at a relatively Fast Pace but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large amounts of data and not
make it ridiculously easy to Bo Force by
running through all the possible
combinations the hash function must be
dependent on each bit of the input the
input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digest for every
password that is being stor but what if
two different users are using using the
same password since the hash function is
the same for all users both the digests
will be the same this is called a hash
Collision you may think this must be a
rare occasion where two users have
exactly the same password but that is
not the case we have techniques like
salting that can be used to reduce these
hash collisions as we will discuss later
in this
video you would be shocked to see the
most used passwords of 2020 all of these
passwords are laugh L insecure and since
many people use the same passwords
repeatedly on different websites hash
collisions risk are more common than one
would
expect let's say the hash functions find
two users having the same password how
can they store both the hashes without
messing up the original data this is
where salting and peppering come to
play salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
each user on the system and it is called
the salt value or just the salt so even
if two passwords are exactly the same
the salt value will differ and so will
the digest there is a small problem with
this process though since the salt is
unique for each user they need to be
stored in the database along with the
passwords and sometimes even in plain
text to speed up the process of
continuous verification if the server is
hacked then the hashes will need to be
brute forced which takes a lot of time
but if if they receive the salts as well
the entire process becomes very fast
this is something that peppering aims to
solve peppering is the process of adding
a random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case the pepper isn't
stored on the servers it is mostly
hardcoded onto the website source code
since it's going to be the same for all
credentials this way even if the servers
get hacked they will not have the right
pepper needed to crack into all the
passwords many websites use a
combination of salting and peppering to
solve the problem of hash collision and
bolster security since Brute Force takes
such a long time many hackers avoid
taking the effort the returns are mostly
not worth it and the possible
combinations of using both salting and
peppering is humongous
with the consensus aiming towards an
educated public on digital privacy it's
no surprised to see an increasing
interest in encryption algorithms we
have already covered the major names
like the dees and the AES algorithm md5
algorithm was one of the first hashing
algorithms to take the global stage as a
successor to the md4 despite the
security vulnerabilities encountered in
the future md5 Still Remains a crucial
part of data infrastructure in a
multitude of
environments the md5 hashing algorithm
is a one-way cryptographic functions
that accepts a message of any length as
input and it returns as output a fixed
length digest value to be used for
authenticating the original messages the
digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input the md5 hash
function was originally designed for use
as a secure cryptographic hash algorithm
to authenticate digital signatures md5
has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non- cryptographic check
sum to verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data
corruption Ronald dest founder of RSA
data security and Institute professor at
MIT designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the
md4 as already iterated before the
process is straightforward we pass up
plain text message to the md5 hash
functions which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 128bit
digest received from this is going to be
radically different from the pl text the
goal of any message digest function is
to produce digest that appear to be
random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value Val and
second that it is impossible for an
attacker to create two messages that
produce the same hash value even a
slight change in the plane text should
trigger a drastic difference in the two
digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which take
place when two different plane dechs
have the same
digest to achieve this level of
intricacy there are number of steps to
be followed before we receive the diges
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when we receive the
input string we have to make sure the
size is 64 bits short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters this
prepares a string to have a length of
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512 here and out we can proceed On To
The Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bits short of any
multiple of 512 now we add the length
bits in such a way that the total number
of bits in the message is perfectly a
multiple of
512 that means 64-bit length to be
precise are added to the message our
final string to be hashed is now a
definite multiple of
512 The Next Step would be to initialize
the message digest buffer the entire
hashing plain text is now broken down
into 512 bit blocks there are four
buffers or registers that are of 32 bits
each named a b c and
d these are the four words that are
going to store the the values of each of
these
subblocks the first iteration to follow
these registers will have fixed
hexadecimal values as shown on the
screen
below once these values are
initial of these 512 blocks we can
divide each of them into 16 further
subblocks of 32 bits each for each of
these subblocks we run four rounds of
operations having the four buffer
variables a b c and d these rounds
require the other constant variables as
well which defer with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a random array of 64 elements since
each 32-bit subblock is run four times
16 such subblocks equal 64 constant
values needed for a single block
iteration the subblocks can be denoted
by the alphabet M and the constant
values are denoted by the alphabet
T coming to the actual round of
operation we see our four buffers which
already have pre-initialized values for
the first iteration at the very
beginning the values of buffers b c and
d are passed on to a nonlinear
logarithmic function the formula behind
this function changes by the particular
round being worked on as we shall see
later in this video Once the output is
calculated it is added to the raw value
stored in buffer a the output of this
addition is added to the particular
32-bit subblock using which we are
running the four operations
the output of this requisite function
then needs to be added to a constant
value derived from the constant AR K
since we have 64 different elements in
the array repeat since we have 64
different elements in the array we can
use a distinct element for each
iteration of a particular block The Next
Step involves a circular shift that
increases the complexity of the hash
algorithm and is necessary to create a
unique digest for each individual input
the the output generated is later added
to the value stored in the buffer B the
final output is now stored in the second
buffer of B of the output registor
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C value of C
gets stored in D and the value of D in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this subblock the values of AB CD
are moved on as input to the next
subblock Once all 16 subblocks are
completed the final register value is
saved and the next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5
algorithm regarding the nonlinear
process mentioned in the first step the
formula changes for each round it's
being run on this is done to maintain
the computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure
the formula for each of the four rounds
uses the same parameters that is b c and
d to generate a single output the
formulas being used are shown on the
screen right
now algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digest they don't consume
a noticeable amount of dis storage and
are comparatively easier to remember and
reiterate passwords need not be stored
in plain text format making them
accessible for hackers and malicious
actors when using digest the database
security also gets a boost since the
sizes of all the hash values will be the
same in the event of a hack or a breach
the malicious actor will only receive
the hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which would be
the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by Design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays a relatively low memory
footprint is necessary when it comes to
integrating multiple Services into the
same framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string this helps in creating a low
requirement for computational power and
is much easier to run on older Hardware
which is pretty common in server farms
around the world
we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
Transit once the hash is match file
Integrity checks are valid and we can
avoid data
corruption hash functions will always
give the same output for the similar
input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the
message
we use our Wi-Fi everyday for work and
we use the internet for entertainment
and communication the dependency on
technology is at an all-time high thanks
to the radical developments and
innovation in these last two decades a
big portion of this belongs to ensuring
secure channels of communication and
data
transmission the secure hash algorithm
are a family of cryptographic hash
functions that are published by the
National Institute of standards and
Technology along with the NSA it was
passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as FPS it
has four different families of hash
functions ssj 0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw sha1 is also a 160 bit
hash function which resembles the
earlier md5 algorithm this was designed
by the NSA to to be a part of the
digital signature
algorithm S2 is a family of two similar
hash functions with different block
sizes known as the Sha 256 and the Sha
512 they differ in the word size sha 256
uses 32bit words while sh 512 uses 64bit
words sh3 is a hash function properly
known as kak it was chosen in 2012 after
a public competition among non- NSA
designers it supports the same hash lens
as H2 and its internal structure differs
significantly from the rest of the sh
family as we have already iterated the
process is straightforward we pass a
plain text message to the sh hash
function which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 160 bit
digest received from this is going to be
radically different from the pl text the
goal of any hash function is to produce
digest that appear to be random
to be considered cryptographically
secure the hash function should meet two
requirements first that it is impossible
for an attacker to generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second it should be impossible for an
attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plane text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which takes
place when two different plane text have
the same
digest the Sha family functions have
some characteristics that they need to
follow while generating the digest let's
go through a few of
them the length of the clear text should
be less than 2^ 64 bits in the case of
sh 1 and
s256 this is essential to keep the plain
text compatible with the hash function
and the size needs to be in comparison
area to keep the digest as random as
possible the length of the hash digest
should be 256 bits in the sh 256
algorithm 512 bits in the Sha 512
algorithm and so on bigger digest
usually suggests significantly more
calculations at the cost of speed and
space we typically go for the longest
diges to bolster security but there must
be a definite balance between the speed
and security of a hash
function
by Design all hash function of the Sha
512 sh 256 are
irreversible you should neither get a
plain text when you have the digest
beforehand nor should the digest provide
the original value when you pass it
through the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance this is is done to reduce
the chance of Brute Force
attacks to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plane text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when you receive the
input string you have to make sure the
size is 64bit short of a multiple of 512
when it comes to padding the mids you
must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters this prepares a string to
have a length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of
512 here on out we can proceed to The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message was 64 bits short from becoming
a multiple of 512 now we add the length
of bits in such a way that the total
number of bits in the message is a
perfect multiple of
512 that means 64 bits plus the length
of the original message becomes a
multiple of 512 this becomes a final
string that needs to be
hashed in the next step we have to
initialize this chaining
variables the entire plane text message
can now be broken down into blocks of
512 bits each and like other hash
algorithms like md5 which use four
registers or buffers sha family use five
buffers of 32 bits each they are named a
b c d and e these registers go through
multiple rounds of operation but the
first iteration has fixed H aimal values
as can be seen in the
screen moving on we have to process each
of the 512 bit blocks by breaking each
of them into 16 subblocks of 32 bits
each each each of them goes through four
rounds of operation that use the entire
registor and have the 512-bit block
along with the constant array out of
those four rounds each round has 20
iterations so in general we have 80
rounds some
total the constant value of K is an
array of 80
elements of those 80 16 elements are
being used each round so that comes out
to 80 rounds for each of those
elements the value of T differs by the
number of rounds as can be seen in the
table
below a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration the formula can be AB CDE e
registor is equal to e plus a nonlinear
process P along with a circular shift of
a + WT + KT in this formula ABCD is the
register value of the chaining variables
as we discussed before p is The Logical
process which has a different formula
for each round S5 is a circular shift by
five bits and WT is a 32bit string
derived from the existing subblock this
can be calculated depending on the
iteration at
hand KT signifies a single element of
the 80 character element array which
changes depending on the particular
round at hand for the values of WT the
first 16 values are the same as that of
the subblocks so there there is no extra
calculation needed for the next 64
elements the value of WT can be
calculated as shown in the formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the
output next we use a nonlinear process P
that changes depend depending on the
round and uses the values of b c and d
as
input whatever output is generated from
the nonlinear process it is added with
the value of the E
register next the value of a is circular
shifted by 5 bits and is added with the
output generated in the previous
step the next step is adding the value
of WT and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
registor a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
subblocks are joined together to form
the single Cipher text message we will
have our hash output regarding the
nonlinear process P that uses the values
of b c and d as input the formula
changes every round to maintain a
complexity of the program that can
withstand Brute Force attacks depending
on the round the values are passed
through a logical operation which is
then added with the values of WT KT and
so on now that we understand how to get
our hash digest from the plane text let
us learn about the advantages we obtain
when using the Sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text
format digital signatures follow
asymmetric encryption methodology to
verify the authenticity of a document or
a file hash algorithms like sh 256 and
the industry standard sha 500 12 go a
long way in ensuring the verification of
signatures passwords need not be stored
in a plain text format which makes them
accessible to hackers and other
malicious actors when using digest the
database security also gets a boost
since the size of all hash values will
be the same in the event of a hack or a
breach the malicious actor will only
receive the hash values with no way to
regenerate the plane text in this case
the plane text should be user
credentials since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers the SSL handshake is a crucial
segment of the web browsing sessions and
it's done using sha functions it
consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection it relies on a
combination of symmetric and asymmetric
algorithms which ensure the confidential
ity of the data transmitted between a
web server and a web client like the
browsers you can monitor file corruption
by comparing hash values before and
after Transit once the hash is match
file Integrity checks are valid and data
corruption is avoided hash functions
will always give the same output for the
same input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the message
passwords are by far the most common
type of user authentication they are
popular because the theory makes perfect
sense to individuals and is reasonably
simple to implement for developers on
the other hand poorly constructed
passwords can pose security flaws a
well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent Insider to access all of the
systems user accounts in this video you
will learn how to crack passwords and
simultaneously try to make your
passwords as Brute Force resistant as
possible let's take a look at the topics
to be covered
today we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for
hacking moving on we take a look at the
multiple tools that hackers can use to
generate these hashes and the
passwords finally we take a look at the
steps and the guidelines that users can
follow to prevent their passwords from
being
cracked let's start by giving a basic
idea about password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources malicious
actors can engage in various criminal
activities with the information obtained
through password tracking the procedure
might entail comparing a set of words to
guess credentials or using an algorithm
to guess the password repeatedly
password cracking can be done for
several reasons but the most malicious
reason is in order to gain unauthorized
access to a computer without the owner's
awareness this results in cyber crime
such as stealing passwords for the
purpose of accessing banking information
other non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
another example of non-malicious
password cracking may take place if a
system administrator is conducting test
on password strength as a form of
security test this enables so that the
hacker cannot easily access protected
systems the best way that users can
protect their passwords from cracking is
to ensure that they choose strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and
symbols strong password should never be
actual words in addition strong
passwords are at least eight characters
long in many password protected
applications users are notified of the
strength of the password they've chosen
upon entering it the user can then
modify it and strengthen the password
based on the indications of its
strength now that we understand the
basics of password cracking let's go to
the basic techniques hackers use to
retrieve passwords from General
victims asking the customer for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwar reader
to a counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset that page then
captures their password which the hacker
can subsequently exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vital credentials and
information through social engineering
the employee tried and through tactics
to exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means to breach secure and Advanced
Technologies it has been demonstrated
that many firms either lack adequate
security or are overly friendly and
trustworthy when they should not be they
allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the correct password in
the case of a dictionary attack password
dictionaries cover many themes and of
mixture of topics such as politics
movies and music groups users failure to
create a strong password is why this
approach efficiently cracks passwords
still today simply said this assault
employs the same terms that many
individuals use as passwords a hacker
can compare the password hash obtained
to hashes of the password dictionaries
to find the correct plain text
password now that the passwords have
been hashed the hackers attempt to
achieve Authentication by breaking the
password hash they accomplish this by
employing a rainbow table which is a set
of pre-computed hashes of portable
password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting in
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves the password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necessitate
the discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches in a Brute Force assault the
attacker ATT attempts multiple password
combinations until the correct one is
identified the attacker uses software to
automate this process and run exhaustive
password combination in a substantially
shorter length of time with the growth
of hardware and technology in recent
years such programs have been
invigorated it won't be quick if your
password is more than a few characters
lengthy but it will eventually reveal
your password boot Force assaults can be
sped up by throwing more processing
resources at
them with so many different techniques
coming together to correct passwords
none of them are useful without the
right tools there are a prra of scripts
and Snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest let's go through
some of these
tools cane and able is a password
recovery tool for Microsoft operating
systems it allows easy recovery of
various kinds of passwords by sniffing
the network cracking encrypted passwords
using dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording vibe convers
ations decoding scrambled passwords
recovering wireless network Keys Etc are
some of the other features of G enable
the latest version is faster and
contains a lot of new features like ARP
poison routing which enables sniffing on
Switched L and man in the middle attacks
the sniffer in this version can also
analyze encrypted protocols such as ssh1
and https while containing filters to
capture credentials from a wide range of
authentication
mechanisms it also ships route in
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
common hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the Ripper is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for Unix based
computers it was created to evaluate
password strength Brute Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attack attacks it can use
dictionary attacks rainbow tables and
other attacks depending on the target
type Rainbow Crack is a password
cracking application that uses time
memory trade-off algorithm to crack
password hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password cracking
more easier and faster than traditional
Brute Force attacks it is like a
dictionary containing nearly every
possible password and the pre-calculated
hashes creating this kind of dictionary
takes much more time than cracking a
single hash but after that you can use
the same dictionary over and over again
this procedure might take a long time
however once the table is ready it can
break passwords far quicker than Brute
Force
methods with so many tools ready to enab
our passwords there are certain set of
rules users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
making the Brute Force mechanism tougher
to implement longer passwords and pass
phrases have been demonstrated to boost
security significantly however it is
still critical to avoid lenier passwords
that have previously been hacked or that
feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal
information as previously said most
users create passwords utilizing
personal information such as Hobbies
nicknames pet or family member names Etc
if if a hacker has access to personal
information about a specific user for
example via social media they will test
password combinations based on that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience user should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users including those who work
in the same department or use the same
equipment should be avoided a single
breached password doesn't affect your
other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word while
pass phrases serve the same objective
the length make them more difficult to
break in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phrases however the
latter is much more breach
resistant two Factor authentication or
2fa can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone tofa does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
identification PIN and a code texted to
the user smartphone or a fingerprint
before accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage unauthorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission at this
point you may wonder why you need a
strong password in the first place even
if most websites are safe there is still
a danger that someone will try to access
or exploit your information a strong
password is among the most effective
ways to protect your accounts and
personal information from hackers you
should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password password managers are also
recommended to help remember the created
passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering
today we start by learning about the
state of password cracking in today's
world and why creating strong passwords
is an absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faes have grown in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal
information let's start by learning
about why strong passwords have become
an Absol absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing passwords simple and commonly
used passwords enable Intruders to
easily gain access and control a
Computing device conversely a password
that is difficult to guess makes it
prohibitively difficult for common
hackers to break into a machine and will
force them to look for another Target
the more difficult the password the
lower the likelihood that one's computer
will fall victim to an unwanted
intrusion many individuals opt to tie
their websites to something they can
readily recall to generally easy
memorable combos however this does not
make the password unique in fact it's
the reverse passwords are handled by 53%
of individuals using their Recollections
and memory with modern computational
standards simple passwords take seconds
and a couple of minutes at worst to be
completely brute forced according to
Global surveys more than 60% of people
use the same passwords for their
personal and job application
while this may allow the user never to
forget the password it makes a single
point of failure the only pin to drop if
one of the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked to further elaborate on how you
can create strong passwords let's go
through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
Dons to understand how to create new
passwords for accounts it is recommended
to keep the password length at least 12
characters to ensure brute forcing to be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more brute for
resistant than any number of alphabets
or letters can make moving over to the d
section
it's absolutely not recommended to keep
Simple dictionary terms such as computer
or even the word password as your
credential because those are very easy
to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list similarly changing a
single alphabet or a single character in
a dictionary word does not make it Brute
Force instant considering there are
already algorithms present that can
counter this
tactic
using the same character multiple times
in a password also reduces the strength
and makes it easier to crack for
hackers apart from using single
characters multiple times following
patterns that are present on this
traditional English keyboard such as e w
e t y or the line below the main
alphabet such as the ZX c vbn m Etc make
it easier to guess since these are once
again common combinations that are
present in word list already
finally the most important part being
not using personal information such as
birthdays addresses and other important
information in the passwords more often
than not if a hacker is trying to break
into your account there has been some
amount of research done be via social
media or any other medium if they have
already this information present with
them breaking into your account becomes
all the more
easier now that you understand how to
create strong password look at how P
phrases have become prevalent as a
replacement for plain text
passwords a passphrase is a
sentence-like string of words used for
authentication that is longer than a
traditional password easy to remember
and difficult to crack typical passwords
range on an average from 8 to 16
characters while pass phrases can reach
up to 100 characters or more using a
long fast phrase instead of a short
password to create a digital signature
is one of the many ways that users can
can strengthen the security of their
data devices and accounts the longer a
passphrase is the more likely a user is
to incorporate bits of entropy or
factors that make it less predictable to
potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements AOS is a fast
and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages that pass faes have over
common
passwords
past phases are simpler to remember than
just a random assortment of symbols and
characters it's easier to comprehend a
line from your favorite song or a
quotation than a short but difficult
password passwords are reasonably easy
for humans and robots to guess or crack
online thieves have also Advanced and
created Cutting Edge hacking tools to
crack even the most complex
passwords pass phrases are nearly hard
to crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 10 characters as a result even the
most sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess brute force or
pre-compute these passwords complies
with password setting rules with ease
passphrases the usage of punctuation and
upper and lowercase password satisfy the
password complexity criteria most
operating systems and apps support P
phrases phrases of up to 127 characters
are permitted on all major operating
systems including Windows Linux and Mac
as a result for optimal protection you
can use lengthier
passphrases but when creating a strong
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass phrases this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password managers
generate new strong passwords and they
keep all of them in one place protected
by a single strong master password if
you maintain your the master password
the manager will retain everything else
including your username and pass phrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign on to a website or app on your
computer or phone there is no good
memory needed for this this implies that
everyone may use the most recent
suggestions for strong passwords such as
extended phrases symbols grammar and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each we
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players in
password managers services like bit
Warden keas and Ashlan have been running
for years now and are very worthy
recommendations if you if you want to
get started with password management now
that we understand what is hacking let's
take a look at some points to know
whether our system is already hacked or
not the first point regarding how to
check whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is Switched Off by unknown means and it
is not visible to the user this is one
of the most primary checkpoint to know
if our system is hacked or
not next point to check whether a system
is hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts performed by a professional
hacker or a cyber
criminal then we also face problems
regarding systems reaction speed which
is affected due to the execution of
unknown applications in the backround
ground of the
system which also affects the hardware
resources in the
device next we also face problems
regarding passwords which are no longer
working or are changed without the
user's Intervention which might indicate
that there was some unknown hacking
activity that took place in our
account let's take a look at some more
points regarding the topic
there are often cases when the system's
cursor move on its own and perform tasks
indicating that the system is being used
by someone else using an illegal hacking
method there are also cases when we
often see files and folders being
created in the storage disk on the
system which is unknown to us to better
understand the points regarding how to
identify with ass system is hacked or
not let's take a look then let's start
with the first
point if we want to check whether our
system is hacked or not the first point
would be to choose the settings
option and using privacy and security
and moving on to the window security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the system
if we see any problem regarding any one
of them for example opon browser control
in my system it says there's a problem
with it which might be due to hacking
attempts that was done on my
system now let's take a look at the
other option how we can check whether
our system is hacked or not that would
be checking the antivirus software that
is installed in our
system if you face problems regarding
that this might be the
issue according to my antivirus software
it says my computer is at risk this
might be due to the interference from a
cyber criminal or a hacker while using
different illegal softare during its
hacking
attempt then there are also
cases where we see there are unknown
programs being executed in the
background of a system which we can take
a look using the task manager software
using the task manager we can take a
look at each and every application that
is being executed in the system and see
the
origin if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking
attempt moving on if we want to check
further whether our system is hacked or
not we can check for files or folders
that are being created unknown to us for
example this unknown
folder which contains some security
details that are unknown to
me this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber
criminal then there are also cases when
the system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks that are not initiated by
us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is due to a hacking attempt that
was done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a
system then there are also cases
regarding login issues or password
problem for
example if I want to access into my
account and there's a problem with the
password it might be due
to the attempt of hacking into my
account by a professional
hacker seems like there's a problem with
the username which means there was a
hacking attempt by a professional
hacker we can further check hacking
attempts by accessing our web browser
and checking whether there's some extra
add-ons or unknown add-ons that wasn't
installed by us this might also indicate
a hacking attempt on the system now that
we are clear about how to check whether
a system is hacked or not let's take a
look at some of the counter measure
against hacking let's
begin the first point regarding how to
avoid hacking is do regular manual
Security checks and keep the system
security updated using certified
antivirus softwares is a basic counter
measure against hacking
attempts and if possible visit only
secure websites for surfing on the
Internet or use VPN or other Internet
Security applications to mask your
systems Network to avoid any hacking
attempts for the
device then we have avoid clicking on
random web popups and ads to avoid
Hackers from getting into a system and
accessing a device
data and lastly use strong passwords or
complex password wordss for your login
details applying these counter measures
we can avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time since then instant messaging has
revolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain old
messaging among these apps WhatsApp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms like
everyone associated with the internet a
matter of security is never far away
considering the huge user base of this
messaging app hackers are always on the
lookout for compromised accounts to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our WhatsApp account
from falling into malicious hands
we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general next we cover some of the most
important steps that should be followed
in order to protect our WhatsApp
accounts from
hackers finally we learn what we should
do when a WhatsApp account gets
compromised let's start by learning why
we need to focus on the safety of
WhatsApp in the year of 2020 the big
news was about about Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos and his phone being haed by Saudi
Arabia a report coming from the guardian
suggested that bezos's phone was hacked
via a video file sent on WhatsApp the
report said that bezos's mobile phone
was hacked by Saudi Arabian prince in
the year 2018 and gigabytes worth of
data was stolen from the device while
there are some issues being raised about
the report which states with the medium
to high confidence that Jeff piz's phone
was hacked it does raise a security fear
for regular users after all if the the
phone of one of the world's most
powerful men can be hacked the same can
happen to any one of us as
well when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics the
information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging
habits WhatsApp users and end to end
encryption to protect all communication
on its platform these encryption keys
not only make it impossible to decrypt
messages but they also prevent third
parties and even WhatsApp from accessing
messages or calls but not entirely
although end to encryption makes
WhatsApp more secure than other
communication apps no app is 100% safe
to use like any application or digital
device WhatsApp is often targeted by Bad
actors it also has access to your
contacts and tracks where and how long
you use it putting your privacy and
personal information at
risk we all have access to our cell
phones so it's no surprise that sms2
factor authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tied to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multiactor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your
organization to a host of risk hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
network be it via spoofed SIM cards or
message hijacking WhatsApp toofa using
SMS isn't a full-proof
solution now that we understand the
variety of reasons why WhatsApp needs
extra security let's go through some of
the ways we can achieve
this it is more than probable that one
fine day you might receive a WhatsApp
message or even an SMS that reads that
your order is delayed please check its
data here here or your account is locked
and please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here some of them may
sound intimidating and some of them may
be lucrative but they all have one
purpose to trick you into clicking that
link and once you do that it's already
over it will install malware on your
phone and you won't have a clue about it
only when you start noticing that your
phone bills are abnormally high or your
bank account has been used without your
permission the realization will Dawn
upon you that something is wrong with
their phone but by then it may be too
late WhatsApp in itself provides various
privacy options to users the messaging
platform provides users with option to
choose who they want to share their
profile photo status and other details
with it's a good idea to change the
settings to contacts only this means
only phone numbers that are saved on
your smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
autod delete status as
well
make sure you enable the option to lck
the screen every time WhatsApp is closed
this will ensure no one else but you can
open your WhatsApp account just head to
the settings menu privacy and select the
screen lock option you will then need to
register your fingerprint after the
process is completed you will have to
scan your fingerprint every time you
open the WhatsApp app this adds an extra
layer of
security the two step step verification
works as an extra layer of security and
helps WhatsApp users to protect their
otps and documents shared through
WhatsApp it's very easy to set up a PIN
to activate a two-step verification
users have to enter it periodically once
it is activated WhatsApp will sometimes
keep asking users to enter this
six-digit passcode users cannot disable
this without disabling the two-step
verification feature
altogether in case users do not provide
WhatsApp with an email ID and want to
disable two-step verification then the
number will be permitted to
reverifying messages upon reverifying
we often have the tendency to log into
to Whatsapp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
this habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp web before
leaving the office it just takes a few
seconds to log in Again by just scanning
the code and you're
done all WhatsApp users should ensure
that the chats are end to endend
encrypted to verify that a chat is end
to endend encrypted open the chat tap on
the name of the contact to open the
contact info screen and then tap
encryption to view the QR code and a 60
digigit number WhatsApp end to end
encryption ensures that only you and
your contact can read the messages that
are being exchanged and nobody in
between not even
WhatsApp
with the necessary guidelines out of the
way let us go to the recommended course
of action should our WhatsApp accounts
be
compromised the first and most important
thing that you need to do is report the
issue to the WhatsApp support team for
assistance make sure that you reach out
to the support team through its help
desk and Report the hacking attempt
WhatsApp help center will take the
shortest time to resolve the issue via
email or within the app itself this will
help you to take prompt legal action
against the hackers if you can't access
your email call the support team in some
cases the support will deactivate your
WhatsApp account and request you to
reactivate within 30 days if you don't
want it to be deleted
completely when someone compromises your
WhatsApp account they can now send
messages to your contact stating that
the company sent your verification code
and gain access to the account that's
why one of the first things you'll want
to do is send a message to your friends
and family letting them know that you've
lost access to your account this action
prevents further exploitation of your
account and others another reason you'll
want to let your contacts know you have
no access to your WhatsApp account is
that they may fish for personal
information from your banking number to
your email address hackers will cleverly
attempt to gain as much access to a
personal information as
possible WhatsApp web is an extension of
WhatsApp messenger over the web that
facilitates easy synchronization of our
smartphone and personal computer this is
the biggest security threat that hackers
can easily exploit to get into your
personal data over WhatsApp therefore it
is highly recommended that you use this
WhatsApp feature carefully once you
notice that your what messenger has been
hacked go to your WhatsApp web and tap
or click on the log out from all
computers option this will deactivate
all the web extensions of your
account under the unfortunate
circumstances where the account recovery
doesn't seem likely you can always ask
WhatsApp support to delete your account
permanently while far from the ideal
solution it can act as a failsafe option
if you want to protect your personal
data at any cost possible you can always
open a new account later with the
security issues mitigated it's no secret
that the majority of our internet usage
is at the risk of being hacked be it via
unsafe messaging applications or
misconfigured operating systems to
counteract this void of digital security
penetration testing has become the norm
when it comes to vulnerability
assessment K Linux is an operating
system that has become a well-known
weapon in this fight against hackers a
Linux distribution that is made
specifically for penetration testers K
Linux has layers of features that we
will be covering in today's lesson let's
take a look at the topics to be covered
in this
video we start by learning about Ki
Linux and a basic explanation of its
purpose we take a look at the history of
K Linux from the story of its origin to
its current day
exploits next we learn a few distinct
features of Kali that make it an
attractive choice for penetration
testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start a journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general Kali Linux which is formerly
known as backtrack Linux is an open-
Source Linux distribution aimed at
Advanced penetration testing and
security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools that are targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
pettion testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering color Linux is a multiple
platform solution accessible and freely
available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users we did not get K Linux since the
first State how did it come into
existence let's take a look at some of
its
history K Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called wopex which stands for white hat
noex as can be inferred from the name it
was based on the npix operating system
as its underlying OS Pi had releases
ranging from version 2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as vax or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name change
was because the base OS was changed from
KNIX to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from warix there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being shorted to just auditor
which was once again using npix its
efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack backtrack was based on
slackware from version one to version
three but switched to uban to later on
with version 4 to version 5 using the
experience gained from all of this K
Linux came after backtrack in 2013 Ki
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when khi Linux became a
rolling operating
system now that we understand the
history and the purpose of K Linux let
us learn a little more about its
distinct
features the latest version of Khali
comes with more than 600 penetration
tools pre-installed after reviewing
every tool that was included in
backtrack developers have eliminated a
great number of tools that either simply
did not work or which duplicated other
tools that provided the same or similar
functionality the Kali Linux team is
made up of a small group of individuals
who are the only ones trusted to commit
packages and interact with the
repositories all of which is done using
multiple secure protocols restricting
access of critical code bases to
external asset greatly reduces the risk
of source contamination which can cause
K Linux users worldwide a great deal of
damage as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in their native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since Arm based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that ki's armm support would need to be
as robust as they could manage with
fully working
installations K Linux is available on a
wide range of armm devices and has armm
repositories integrated with the
mainline distributions so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if kala
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
their penetration testing
Journey the first way to use scal Linux
is by launching the distribution in the
live USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the K Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the Thum Drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the c that any changes made to the
OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USBS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations but what if the user wants to
store data permanently in the installed
OS the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is a full-fledged hard disk
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtual box the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and K Linux can
be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the allotted
Ram to the virtual hard disk
capacity the usage of both host and
guest operating system like K Linux
allows users a safe environment to learn
while not putting the systems at risk if
you want to learn more about how one can
go forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where K Linux is being
installed on VMware while running on a
Windows 10 operating system you can find
the link in the description box to get
started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install Kali
Linux is by using a dual boot system to
put it in simple words the k Linux OS
will not be overriding any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and K Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system now for the convenience
of explanation we're going to install K
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware VMware is able
to run multiple operating systems on a
single host machine which in our case is
a Windows 10
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file we go to get Kali and as you can
see there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64-bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet after clicking on the
download button you can see we have of
wi archive which will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already present with me
so we can start working on the VMware
side of things once the ISO file is
downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more Advan and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well versed with
virtualization software but for 90% of
the cases typical setup will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later in some operating
systems we can use the ISO file here
directly and VMR will install it for us
but right now in the case of K Linux the
third option is always the safest
K Linux is a Linux distribution so we
can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels every distribution has of a
parent distribution for example K Linux
has Debian and there are other
distributions which are based or forked
from some parent distribution kinu is
based of Debian so we can go with the
highest version of Debian which is the
Debian 10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux so that it'll
be easier to recognize the virtual
machine among this list of virtual
machine instances the location can be
any location you decide to put by
default this should be the documents
folder but anywhere you put it will hold
up all the information of the operating
system all the files you download all
the configurations you store everything
will be stored in this particular
location that you provide
when we go next we are asked about the
dis capacity this dis capacity will be
all the storage that will be provided to
your virtual machine of K Linux think of
your Windows device if you have a 1 TB
of hard drive you have the entirety of
the hard disk to store data on how much
data you give here you can only store up
to that amount of data not to mention
some amount of capacity will be taken up
by the operating system itself to to
store its programs and applications for
now we can give around let's say 15 GB
of information or if a recommended size
for Dean is 20 you can just go ahead at
20 it depends all on the user case if
you're going to use it extensively you
can even go as high as 50 or 60gb if you
have plans to download many more
applications and perform multiple
different tests another option we get
over here is storing virtual discs as a
single file or storing them into
multiple
files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on
VMware sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either system to
system or software to software let's say
if you want to switch from VMware to
Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual L as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine even if you do it's
not a complete stop that it cannot be
ported it's just easier when using
multiple files but in order to get the
best performance out of the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the ISO file yet which
is the installation file for the K Linux
that we downloaded from this
website as of right now we have only
configured the settings of the virtual
machine so we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now to make the changes further we press
on edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine so
devices with ram of 8 GB or below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance issues and the host system
if the memory has some some amount of
free storage left let's say on idle
storage my Windows machine takes about 2
GB so I have 6 GB of memory to provide
although if you provide all of the 6gb
it will be much more difficult for the
host system to run everything properly
so for this instance we can keep it as
2GB of memory for the virtual machine
instance similarly we can use the number
of processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can s them as
well hard disk is preset up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or a USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this we going to select use
ISO image file we're going to click on
browse
go and go to downloads and select the
IMO file over
here select
open and we can see it is already loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine in this screen we can choose how
we want to proceed with the
installation we have a start installer
option over here so we're going to press
enter on
that we're going to wait for the things
to load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system for this we can go
with English as
standard this is a location this will be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings which depend
entirely on the Lo ation of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's
always recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always preferred to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is NE required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect
Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a host name for the system
this host name can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a land cable let's say if we
use the name
Kali domain name you we can skip it for
now it's not necessary as such for the
installation this is the full name for
the
user let's say we can provide the name
as simply learn as a full
name next we're going to set up a
username this username is going to be
necessary to identify the user from its
root accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one 2
three now we have to choose a password
for the user now remember since this is
the first user that is being added onto
this newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the administ
trator we can use whichever password we
like over
here and use the same password below and
press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here there are multiple
options like the use entire disk use
entire dis and set up lvm this entire
disc can set up encrypted lvm for
newcomers it is recommended to just use
the first one since lvm encryption is
something that you can learn afterwards
when you're much more Hands-On with the
Linux operating system for now we're
going to use the use entire disg guided
installation and press on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on VMware we had set up a dis
capacity that we gave a prose 20gb that
is the hard disk which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual disk on VMI it acts as a normal
hard disk on which an operating system
can be installed so we select this one
and press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system all the operating
systems that are installed have
different components one is used for the
a keeping of the applications one for
the files other for the RAM management
and other things for newcomers it is
always recommended to keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on
continue this is just a an overview of
the partition it's going to make as you
can see it has a primary partition of
20.4 GB and a logical partition of 1 GB
used for swap memory now these kind of
naming can be confusing for people who
are not well versed with Linux operating
systems or in general virtualization but
for now you can go ahead and press on
continue as this will be fine you can
press on finish partitioning and write
changes to dis and
continue it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it's WR that scsi3 is our
virtual hard disk of 20gb dis
capacity write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine with only 2 GB of RAM
we're going to speed up this part of the
video so we don't have to waste any more
time just watching the progress
bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating systems is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple
devices it's an interface to install
external applications which are not
installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the
internet at this point of time is ask us
to select a network mirror we're going
to select as yes and move forward with
this next it's going to ask us for an
HTTP proxy which we can leave it as
blank and press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the Kali Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest
version now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the graub boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press
continue remember the installation was
conducted on dev
SDA so we're going to select
installation of the gr loader on the
same hard disk that we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the graub bootloader is
being installed the graub is highly
essential because it it shows the
motherboard where to start the operating
system from even if the operating system
is installed correctly and all the files
are in correct order the absence of a
bootloader will not be able to launch
the OS
properly as you can see the installation
is finally complete so now we can press
on
continue and it's going to finalize the
changes now you can see K Linux being
booted up straight away it doesn't check
for the ISO file anymore since the
operating system is now installed onto
the virtual hard disk storage that we
had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up
before and we have the coloru system
booted
up and this is your homepage we can see
the installed application over here
which are being used for penetration
testing by multiple security analysts
worldwide all of these can pre-installed
with K Linux and others can be installed
using the AP package manager that we had
configured we can see a full name over
here and with this our installation of
the K Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet users is at the risk of getting
hacked be it by unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment par security OS
is an operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a l distribution more cater
towards penetration testers specifically
parent security has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson let's take a look at the topics
for this video
we start by learning about what par
security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to col Linux of pettion
testers next we take a look at the
minimum system requirements necessary to
obtain Optimum performance from an
installation of parot security moving on
we learn about some unique features that
make parot Stand Out Among the multiple
ethical haing operating systems
available on the market and finally we
look at the multiple ways that par
security OS can be installed be it on a
single system or for portable
media so let's start out by learning
what parro security
is parat is a Dean based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux kernel while
being founded in
2013 parro security contains several
hundred tools targeted to reps various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbies it features a distinct forens
six mode that does not Mount any of the
system hard diss or partitions and has
no influence on the host system making
it more stealthy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is is a need for executing
forensic
procedures in software development a
rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions this ensures that the software
is constantly up to date rolling release
distribution such as parro security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market with the basic introduction to
the operating system out of the way let
us have a look at the bare minimum
system requirements necessary to be able
to run this operating
system first up we got a CPU requirement
which states that a 1 GHz dual Coe CPU
is the absolute minimum in order to use
baros while multiple core systems will
provide more Optimum performance a small
beginner has been
included a very distinct thing to be
noted is that the operating system can
be installed on all variance of chipsets
be 32-bit 64bit and the newly popular
armm portfolio of
devices unlike K Linux which requires
some amount of graphical acceleration
needed to display the operating system
correctly paratos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of
machines taking into account the ram
issue a minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free
Ram provides the optimum usage
scenarios even when the OS is installed
on a hard drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB of
inform which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box when it comes to booting
options we have the option of going with
the Legacy BIOS settings or with the
more modern ufi settings these are just
some of the requirements for the
installation of parot security OS to
understand this process more vividly and
to learn how visualization can help
install an OS in our existing computer
please follow the link to a parate
security installation video linked right
above
let's understand what some of the things
that make parot security unique among
all the other penetration testing
operating
systems along with all the giant catalog
of scripts par security has its own
custom hardened Linux kernel which has
been modified explicitly to provide as
much security and resistance to hackers
as possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of malitia requests and dropping
them off
this is particularly beneficial since
should there be a scenario where the
latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parto development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an
update the custom hardened kernel wasn't
reasoning enough parid security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Gali Linux
users all the tools you found in Gali
are present in parto and then a few
extra ones for good measure this has
been achieved while keeping roughly the
same size of the installation file
between both operating
systems however it's not all
productivity points for parro OS they
provide a choice between two different
desktop environments the M desktop which
comes pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system being highly modular in nature
one can use Ki Linux or parat while
adding another dtof environment which
they find appealing while kalii has only
a single option paratto has managed to
provide two optimized Wheels with made
desktop and KD desktop ready made on the
website one of the primary advantages of
parat os over Kali is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes frequently less dis space and
computing power to function properly
with as little as 320 MB of ram required
in reality
parat OS is also designed to operate
successfully of a USB stick but Kali
liux does not work well from a USB stick
and is generally installed in a virtual
machine parat can be seen as more of a
niche distribution if you're searching
for something lighter than G Linux there
are multiple ways to go about with this
installation many people prefer to
install it directly onto a hard disk
where the parro security OS will
override whichever data the hard disk
already has now this is beneficial if
you want to preserve your data for the
long term but this might pose some
trouble to people who do not have a
spare hard disk or do not want to lose
their current installation of Windows
operating system another way to use par
security is by using the live boot but
whatever changes you make to the live
boot operating system those changes are
removed the moment we restart or shut
down the
system a very good Common Ground between
both these installations is
virtualization using virtualization
software like VMware or virtual box we
can install par Security on our systems
while simultaneously saving our data and
having the convenience of a host machine
such as a Windows operating system in
case things go
wrong to start the installation we first
need to get a ISO file for the parot
security operating system this can be
found on the current
website parats sec.org
once we enter the website move into the
download
section and select the get security
Edition over
here parage security OS has multiple
desktop environments to you to choose
from these desktop environments serves
as a different user interface for the
user for example right now we have the M
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to
them for our example let's go with a M
desktop we have two two options either
we can go with the direct download or we
can get the torrent file for this
example if you press on the download
button and our download will start I
have already downloaded this file but
the ISO file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around 4 and 1/2 GB of space it will be
used to install this operating system in
VMware once the file is downloaded we
can close this and open VMR Workstation
vmw can also be used as a player version
or the Workstation version if you have
much more familiarity with using virtual
box of virtualization application we can
use that as
well once the VMware is open we click on
file and select a new virtual
machine for the first time installation
we're going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine oses going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with the
typical
option moving on it will ask us for a
source to where to install the operating
system from since we're going to use a
live ISO first we're going to select the
third option which will be I will
install the operating system later and
press
next as we already know parent security
is a debent derivative so When selecting
the guest operating system type we're
going to go with Linux and in the
selection we're going to choose
whichever the highest version of Debian
is along with a 64bit
OS we're going to click on next we're
going to name our virtual machine let's
say par security
OS we're going to select the location
where we want to save the virtual
machine this will have all the hard disk
of the operating system
installation we're going to click on
next next for the disk size we're going
to specify how much of the current
memory are we going to allocate this is
the hard disk memory of the operating
system installation whatever changes you
make in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage we
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20gb as
written when given the choice of storing
the virtual dis as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable people change
systems and sometimes they want to swap
their instances between the work and
their personal computer if there is no
portability in mind storing the virtual
dis as a single file gives the best
performance and should be the
recommended goto when installing for the
first time we click on next here and
it's going to give us a summary of the
settings we have already settled till
now now we're going to press on
finish and there we go we have our
installation First Step
completed here on out we're going to
click on edit virtual machine
settings here we're going to have a look
at some of the requirements that the
parro security OS will need it is known
to be a memory lightweight operating
system but just to have the most Optimum
performance we're going to provide
around 2 GB of RAM from our host system
which is a Windows 10 machine when it
comes to the processors I'm going to
increase it to two and the number of
goes to two as well so giving out a
total four processor CES to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can Justified so these
need to be customized according to the
system at
hand hard size has already been set at
20 GB and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on one thing that
we need to make sure is selecting the CD
DVD IDE here we have to use a ISO image
file over here previously it should be
used physical drive and at Auto detect
we're going to use a use ISO image file
over here we're going to click on
browse we're going to go to where we
have downloaded the ISO file which is
over here and select
it press okay
here and we can now power on this
virtual
machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode to get a better user
experience we're going to go with the
try install mode specifically press
enter and it's going to start the live
boot ISO meanwhile vmw has an prompt
over here where it will try to install
some VMware tools on it while this is
not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we're going to close this
prompt
as you can see this is the live boot ISO
of the Barett security operating
system currently it's running the mat
desktop as we have downloaded in the
website the liveb boot ISO is necessary
to get a good feel of the operating
system there are many good Linux dor
that have this live boot option so that
you can give a try of the operating
system before installing it permanently
once you into the live board we can
start up with the installation using the
shortcut as you can see install
parot going to double click
it and this is a calamaras installer
choose your language as American
English and press
next you can select your time zone
according to a
location
C and we can go
next at this point of time you have to
choose the correct keyboard now what
many people go get confused is choosing
their own language keyboard but people
must keep in mind is what keyboard the
laptop
provides most of the systems that come
pre-built provide the English US
keyboard so whatever keyboard you choose
make sure to type here and test that all
the buttons include including the
superscript and the subscript buttons
are working correctly before moving
forward with this
step once you settled on the keyboard
that you need to install can go
ahead here it will ask you to select
storage device and the only option
you're going to get is the amount of
hard disk storage you have given in the
virtual machine settings we have already
provided 20 GB of storage we're going to
choose that and we're going to erase
this
disk manual partitioning can be useful
when you're going to install parot
security on an operating system or on a
hard disk where it is already including
a Windows OS for now we're going to
select erase disk and press next we're
going to give our full name Let It Be
simply
learn you can give the name of the
computer and this is the username which
we will use to log
in this is your root password that we
going to give over here the root
password of this Cali Linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary for making changes to the
system or installing an updating
software enter the password and repeat
it over
here you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this
disabled click on next this is another
summary of the installation that we
going to move forward with have a look
that whatever changes we have made is
according to your requirements and once
everything is checked we can press on
install click on install
now and we're going to let it complete
the
work as you can see the installation of
parot security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart now button over here
disabled I'm going to click on
done we're going to shut down this live
boot
ISO going to click on
menu turn off the
device and shut
down we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO
file please remove the live medium and
press enter to continue we can just
press enter to
continue and it's going to shut down now
to move on we're going to click on edit
virtual machine
settings going to CD DVD and we're going
to use physical drive now we're going to
remove it from the ISA image file
because the installation has already
been completed and we don't want to use
the same ISO file again and again by
using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20gb hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it going to
press
okay and we're going to power on this
virtual machine for
testing make sure this you click the S
over
here this is the grub menu at this we
get different choices for example which
NVIDIA drivers off or with some other
Advanced options more often than not
we're going to choose the first option
and press
enter if you remember clearly we did not
get the option of try install or a
terminal run just like we did in the
live boot ISO since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the OS
directly now with the login screen you
can see our username over here as we
provided in the
installation we're going to enter our
root
password and press
enter and this is a currently working
desktop of the par security operating
system we can open the terminal over
here and we're going to try a root
password and
installation to install any software
we're going to use the keyword Pudo
a install and Neo
fetch they're going to use the root
password that we used to log
in going to press y for
yes this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had
provided now that we have installed neof
fetch we can write the command NE
Fetch and this is going to give us some
information about our
installation you can see the OS name as
parro OS 4.11 is running on a VMware
host the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once and some other things
you can see the memory is supposed to be
1951 MB which is supposed to equal
around 2 GB of RAM usage that we had
provided K Linux and parat Os are two
popular penetration testing
distributions while these operating
systems each have unique offerings the
overall Choice can differ between
Personnel thanks to the various tools
and Hardware specifications today we
will look at both these distributions
and settle on the perfect choice for
each type of user let's go through the
agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pirot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers next we know
about some features of these operating
systems that stand out of their
package finally we directly compare K
Linux and parro security OS thereby
making a clear-cut conclusion on which
OS is perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open-source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiplatform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system deian
has been a highly dependable and a
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the K Linux
desktop while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at par
security operating
system paret security OS is a Debian
based Linux distribution with an
emphasis on security privacy and
development it is built on the demian's
testing branch and uses a custom Harden
Linux
kernel par security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer
forensics reverse engineering and
security research it is seen as a
generally lightweight distribution that
can work under rigorous hardware and
software
specifications it features a distinct
forensics mode that does not Mount any
of the systems hard diss or partitions
and has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to execute forensic
procedures a rolling release is a
paradigm in which software upgrades are
rolled out constantly rather than in
batches of versions and software
development this ensures that the
software is constantly up to date a
rolling release distribution such as
Pate security OS follows the same
concept it provides the most recent
Linux kernel and software versions as
soon as they become
available with the basic introduction to
the operating systems out of the way let
us take a look at the unique features of
both K Linux and parent security
OS the latest version of K Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar
functionality the K Linux team comprises
a small group of individuals ual were
the only ones trusted to commit packages
and interact with the repositories all
of which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external assets
dramatically reduces the risk of source
contamination which can cause SC Linux
users worldwide a great deal of damage
as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Kali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that ki's armm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage but fully working
installations Kali Linux is available on
a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
mainline distribution so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts par security OS has its own
hardened Linux kernel modified
explicitly to provide as much security
and resistance to hackers as possible in
the first line of
defense the configurations in the
operating system Act is the second
Gateway taking care of malicious
requests and dropping them off this is
particularly beneficial since should
there be a scenario where the latex
Linux kernel is causing some particular
issue the parat O development team will
most likely iron it out first before
passing it on as an
update
if the custom hardal kernel wasn't
reason enough parette security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure and this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
operating system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a Cho
between two different desktop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with Linux terminology
you can think of desktop environments as
a main UI for a distribution being
highly modular in nature one can use
parad security OS while adding another
desktop environment that they find
appealing while K Linux has only a
single option par security has provided
two optimized bills with M desktop and
KD desktop
one of the primary advantages of parro
os over Kali Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less disk space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality paratos is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB Thrive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine paratos
is more of a niche distribution if
you're searching for something lighter
than K
Linux features are great but what about
Performance Real World metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability in the end
we can decide on what distribution is
fit for each type of
user for our first point of comparison
let's take a look look at the ram
required for Optimum performance of the
operating system which is highly
essential when trying to crack hashes or
something of similar nature RAM usage is
a very important facet while K Linux
demands at least 1 GB of RAM par
security can operate optimally with a
minimum of 320 MB of
RAM for correctly displaying graphical
elements K Linux requires GP based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parro security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user
side once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos they take up a minimum amount of
hard disk storage both of these
operating systems have a recommended
disk storage of minimum of 20 GB in K
Linux and a minimum of 15 GB in parro
security so they can install all the
tools necessary in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has
always been the first in securing every
single tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry par
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless pen
testing par security makes it a point
that all the tools that K Linux provides
has been included in the iso while
simultaneously adding some extra tools
that many users will have to install
from third party sources in K
Linux being a decade old penetration
testing distribution K Linux has formed
up a very big Community with strong
support signature par Security on the
other hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers a primary drawback of K Linux is
the extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parro security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hardk Storage parro
security on the other hand was initially
designed to run off a USB drive directly
thereby requiring very minimal
requirements from a hardware perspective
like just 320 MB of RAM and no graphical
acceleration needed this means parro
security is much more feasible for
people who are not able to devote
massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk
directly with the comparison done
between both of these operating systems
let's take a look at the type of users
both of these are catered
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with par
security if they want to go with a very
lightweight and lean distribution that
can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on G
Linux it is much more suitable for under
DS where users do not have a lot of
Hardware resources to provide to the
operating system and thereby it is much
more feasible for people with
underpowered laptops or no graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux parad
securi desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking par
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and and to the various stools without
having to dump them into the entire
intricacies with ethical hacking and
penetration testing becoming mainstream
and corporate environments trained
personnel and relevant equipment are in
high demand the right software framework
can be the Tipping Point in a hacking
Campaign which deals with intricate
Hardware one such tool that has become a
main stay for decades is nmap when it
comes to scanning machines for open
ports and services nmap has always been
the first choice for hackers being
lightweight and an open source and map
has strong Community backing and
receives regular
updates let's take a look at the topics
to be covered
today we start by learning about the
different phases in ethical hacking and
where nmap is most valuable to ethical
hackers we learn the basics of nmap and
its purpose during a penetration testing
campaign next we take a look at the top
level approach of nmap as a scanning
tool and how it conducts these scans on
host
machines moving on
we cover the multiple modes and types of
scans that can be performed using nmap
on unsuspecting
users we also look at some Alternatives
that users can prefer if nmap is not
something they are comfortable with
while a live demonstration of the powers
of nmap will help in shedding light on
the topics being taught
today let us first understand where and
why and map is
essential there are essentially five
phases in ethical hacking the
reconnaissance phase is the first phase
of the penetration test here the
security researcher collects information
about the target it can be done actively
or passively or both it helps security
firms gather information about the
target system Network components active
machines Etc this activity can be
performed by using the information
publicly available and by using
different
tools the scanning phase is more tool
oriented rather than being performed
manually the tester runs one of more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the Target by using various
scanners such as war dialers port
scanners Network mappers and
vulnerability scanners the penetration
tester collects as many vulnerabilities
which help in turn to attack a Target in
a more sophisticated
manner in the gaining axis phase the
penetration tester tries to establish a
connection with the Target and exploit
the vulnerabilities found in the
previous phase the exploitation may be a
buffer overflow attack denial of service
attack session hijacking and man Mo
basically the penetration tester
extracts information and sensitive data
from the servers by gaining access with
different tools in the maintaining
access phase the penetration tester
tries to create a back door for himself
it helps him to identify hidden
vulnerabilities in the system while
allowing him to come back to the system
to retrieve more data further
on in the clearing TRX phase the tester
tries to remove all logs and Footprints
which might help the administrator
identify his presence this helps a
tester to think like a hacker and
perform corrective actions to mitigate
those
activities nmap is most beneficial in
the early stages of ethical hacking
where a hacker must figure the possible
entry point to a system it is necessary
to know this before running the
necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage any insecure
openings and breach the device so the
reconnaissance and the scanning phase
are the points where nmap finds the most
use let us now understand what n map is
from a Layman's
perspective nmap which stands for
network mapper is a free and open source
utility for network discovery and
security auditing many systems and
network administrators also find it
useful for tasks such as Network
inventory managing service upgrade
schedules and monitoring host and
service uptime the program is most
commonly used via a command line
interface and is available for many
different operating systems such as
Linux free PSD and gento
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits nmap was developed for
Enterprise scale networks and can scan
through thousands of connected devices
however in recent years nmap is being
increasingly used by smaller companies
as well nmap uses raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what services
these host are offering what operating
systems they are running what type of
packet filters and firewalls are in use
and dozens of other
characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fine against single horse as well the
rise of the iot in particular now means
that networks used by these companies
have become more complex and therefore
harder to secure since every application
that connects to a network needs to do
so via a port the wrong port or server
configuration can open a can of worms
that leads to a too breach of the system
the recent emergence of iot Bot Nets
like meai has also simulated interest in
N map not least because of its ability
to interrogate devices connected via the
UPnP protocol but also to highlight any
devices that may be
malicious now that we understand what
nmap is let us take a look at the
workflow of how an ethical hacker uses
this tool in penetration
testing at a practical level nmap is
used to provide detailed real-time
information on your networks and other
devices connected to them we have the
hacker running nmap on a system with a
victim machine running a standard
installation of the operating system be
it Windows Mac OS or
Linux the nmap interface will send
specially crafted package to generate
some reply from the victim machine the
victim machine in return will send some
information back to the nmap host with
replying some of the services and host
that are being run on the computers nmap
allows the network admins to find which
devices are running discover some open
ports and other services this in turn
help discover the the vulnerabilities
and the possible entry points for
hackers to breach
into we are now aware of how nmap works
on a basic level but there are many
varieties of cans that users can run on
local machines let's take a look at some
of
them the Ping sweep is a simple type of
nmap scan where it pings to all the
available IP addresses to check which
IPS respond to icmp protocol if the
users need to know only the number of IP
addresses and not many details the Ping
sweep is very useful it's fast and hence
the results to be known are fetched very
easily the SN scan is the most useful
type of nmap scan which does work very
quietly it sends an SN packet via the
TCP protocol or the transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgement pack is received to the
system it is sure that a port is opened
there no response means that the port is
either closed or not available here the
acknowledgement pack is not sent back to
the system assuming that the connection
is not valid the scan is not shown in
most of the scan logs and hence it is
safe to use SN scan to identify the open
ports the TCP connect scan is similar to
SN scan in many aspects as it uses the
TCP layer to send packets and is passed
to all the ports here the difference is
that the full connection is done by
sending the acknowledgement back at back
the logs can easily find the TCP scan
and need more power from the machines to
do the work but it is more
accurate if all the accesses related to
the OS are available to the user it is
better to do a TCP scan than an S scan
as all the lowlevel and high level
accesses are required for the scan the
network is also loaded more and hence
users must be careful about overloading
the system and the
networks the idle scan is really used to
check whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular
Network users need not control the
external host but an IP address and a
port should be given to the same all
other requirements are taken from the
scanner
itself the RPC scans or remote procedure
calls are done by hackers to make the
system vulnerable to virus attacks it is
thus necessary to know whether our
systems answer such calls and make our
system open to
malware RPC scan is done to check this
by finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by
RPC the windows scan is a simple scan
with the application scan SC the
acknowledgement packets received from
the polls once the SN packets are sent
if there are any abnormalities in the AK
packets received the scan reports the
same and helps in recognizing which
ports are functioning in a different
manner the boun scan is used to check
the security in the file transfer
protocol layer FTP layers mostly do not
accept any packets and once it is
rejected from the FTP layers there are
chances that it might be sent to an
internal layer so that it can access the
internal machines bounce can check this
loophole by doing exactly the same
process and identifies whether our FTP
layer is open to vulnerability or
not the FN scan is similar to SN scan
where the system that sends the packets
receives the response back and it will
be mostly be a TCP FN packet if the
system sends an RSD packet it is a false
alarm and users need not be worried
about the
same the null scan is useful for other
systems than Windows where the systems
can easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either TCP packets or null responses
null scans are not useful for Windows as
they may not always produce the desired
results when it comes to looking at
Alternatives there's a wide range of
free network monitoring utilities as
well as free open source vulnerability
scanners available to network
administrators and security
Auditors what makes nmap stand out as a
tool it and network security managers
need to know is its flexibility and
power there are some alternatives to to
n map but most of them are focused on
providing specific Niche functionality
than the average system administrator
does need frequently M scan for instance
is much faster than nmap but provides
less detail in reality however nmap
provides all the functionality and speed
that the average user requires
especially when used along with other
similar tools like netcat which can be
used to manage and control Network
traffic and zenmap which provides a
graphical user interface for nmap but as
an allrounder solution to network
scanning nobody can go wrong with nmap
as their tool of
choice let's now take a tour of nmap
based on all the things we have covered
today in this live demonstration we
start by learning on how to install nmap
on a fresh operating system that doesn't
come pre-installed with the tool we also
cover the different types of scans that
can be run on local machines along with
checking multiple inferences on ethical
hacker can gather based on the scan
output of an nmap screen finally we run
scans on vulnerable machines to get an
idea of how to proceed with the outputs
We Gather using this tool if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more the
first step in our demonstration is
installing
nmap now it depends heavily on what
Linux distribution you're going to use
to perform ethical hacking right now I'm
using parot security operating system if
you're not aware of what parro security
is or even what K Linux is we highly
suggest that you check out the videos of
those two operating systems on a YouTube
channel so that you can get a fair idea
of what they serve now if you are using
any of these two operating systems nmap
should come pre-installed by default to
check if nmap is pre-installed or not
you can just press on applications over
here go to the pen testing
section go to this information gathering
tab
and you should be able to see nmap right
here now let's say you do not have nmap
pre-installed maybe you're using a Linux
distribution like Ubuntu or Linux Min or
something that is based on depn
operating systems one thing you have to
make sure that nmap should be in the
distribution repository once you check
that or even if you do not know if it is
present you can just this command should
be pseudo which is to give root
permissions for installation a AP AP is
the package manager of all Linux
distributions that are based on Debian
that goes for Debian stable ubu Linux
Min K Linux par security and anything of
that
nature AP is the package manager which
handles the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems once you're here just write
install and end map press enter and it's
going to ask you for the root password
that you said when you install the
operating system in the first place
enter your root password and press enter
again as you can see it's saying that
nmap is already installed the newest
version since I'm running parro security
operating system now should you be
running this operating system or even G
Linux you should receive a similar
message and the installation is already
done if you are using some other
distribution let's say even black o Arch
Linux or Manjaro anything like that that
the installation steps will be slightly
different this pseudo AP install nmap
command is for distributions that are
derived from Debian and abantu if you
want to install in Arch Linux based
distributions you have to use their
package manager which is known as
pamac but that is for a different step
and if you want to get an ethical
hacking the best way to start is by
learning either K Linux or par security
now that the installation is done done
we're going to learn how to use nmap one
of the most basic functions of nmap is
to identify active hosts on the network
we can do this by using a ping scan the
ping scan identifies all of the IP
addresses that are currently online
without sending any packets to these
hosts now to run the ping scan we're
going to write end map the flag we're
going to mention over here is sp now
these flags are the different
traits of the nmap scan depending on
what flag we use we can send different
kinds of requests to the host that we
are scanning now before moving forward
with this let me open another terminal
over here and check the IP
address we're going to write the command
if config and find the Subnet in which
this system is present as you can see
the IP address is
192.168
72131 now this operating system is is
being run on a virtual machine software
known as VMware the VMware in itself is
running on a Windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network this IP address is of par
security and the Windows operating
system which is the host system in my
scenario will fall in this particular
subnet so to run our
scan we're going to
Target
192.168
72.1
-24 this command then returns a list of
hosts on your network and the total
number of assigned IP
addresses this is going to be capital P
yeah if you spot any host or IP
addresses on that list that you cannot
account for you can then run further
commands to investigate them further as
of right now you can see the machine
that is the parro security this IP
address can be detected in the subnet
the 1 192.168 72.1 is my local Windows
machine that is running VMware software
and ultimately this virtual machine the
72.2 is the DHCP server that hosts the
internet connection of the par security
this we can ignore for now now the
Windows machine that we have over here
let's run some tests on that going to
clear our
terminal and we can close this
actually when scanning hosts nmap
commands can use server names ipv4
addresses or IPv6 addresses a basic nmap
command will produce information about
the given host to run a basic port scan
we can just use n map along with the IP
now as we remember the IP
192.168 72.1 this is the IP of my local
Windows 10
machine as you can see it shows the
ports that are open and the particular
servers that these ports are
running now we can also have a detection
of the operating system now mind you
this is not 100% correct and the
reliability depends on the installation
and what kind of fingerprinting measures
are available now since this does TCP IP
fingerprinting it needs some extra
permissions the flag that we going to
use is n map minus o along with the same
IP
address like I said since this just TCP
I finger printing it requires root
privileges now to provide root
privileges we're just going to add the
nmap and Pudo
keyword going to repeat the same command
that we wrote
above as you can see it has successfully
detected that I am running Microsoft
Windows
10 with this Mac
address it has also shown the correct
build number of the Windows 10 system
that I am
using this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated now to get the necessary
information about these services for
example what versions they are using we
have a command known as SV which stand
for service version we use the same IP
address and press
center now as you can see the scan is
complete and if you can check the
results of the scan above here we don't
see any version number for the
services here we can actually check what
version they are running now this
becomes helpful when we are trying to
find specific versions to exploit for
example if VM workstation 16. 1.2 had
some particular vulnerability we can
exploit it by checking this
command apart from the host scanning
Port scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are few ways that this
command can be customized as well for
example I have already checked that the
443 command is open but I have found out
after running this lengthy scan let's
say I only want to check if command if
the port 443 is open and map I'm going
to use
the flag of minus P which stands for
port and give 443 as an argument here
using the same IP
address and you can see it says it's
open but we already knew it is open
let's say there was something else uh if
let's say we're going to scan if the
Apache web server port is open which
usually runs on
80 obviously since I'm not running an
Apache web server it says it's
closed now we can combine these two
commands by running both ports
simultaneously to do that we can just
put a
comma and complete the rest
similarly expected 80 is closed and 443
is open another feature of n map for
Port scanning is showing of ranges now
ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example n map minus P we're going to
check what ports are open between 100 to
let's say
2,000 this aess a
range everything else is the
same and it checks all ports in the
range of 100 to
2,000 whatever ports is open in between
that range it can be mentioned over
here we're going to clear the screen now
another flag that can be used with n map
is the SS command this runs a steal scan
which is a little harder to detect if
you're the it admin of the system that
is being
scanned the results will more or less be
the same although this will need
elevated root
privileges
2.1 as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan just adds an
extra mac address as well for good
measure but like I said it's more about
the stealth the normal scans usually are
easier to detect when the logs are being
checked style scans are relatively
tougher to check on much more intricate
systems this takes longer as
well now that we're done with post
scanning let's look at a vulnerable
machine the system that is scanning
right now is this my own personal system
with everything is pretty locked on as
much as it can
be there is an attack box
running in the cloud the IP address of
which is over
here now to be able to get into this
network we need to connect to their
personal network using a VPN so what I'm
going to do is switch to a different
workspace over here I'm going to open a
terminal and if you can see over here
there is a hack test. ovpn file I'm
going to connect to their VPN network
using this ovpn
file and once we get the initialization
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been
established like we discussed this is
the vulnerable device IP we're going to
copy
this and we're going to try to Ping this
let's open a new terminal we're going to
try to Ping this and check if we are
able to reach this
machine and as you can see we're getting
a reply back which means we are now part
of the local network where the
vulnerable machine is
present let's run a service scan map
with the respective
versions We ran the similar scan on my
local machine where we were able to
detect what version each service was
running what we're going to do over here
is by checking what kind of services are
open on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we're going to see if in
map alone can point us to a Direction
Where We can gain access to the
machine
as you can see the scan is now
completed and we have some of the ports
that are being opened over here and what
kind of service they are
running now like we discussed this is
the first stage or sometimes even the
second stage of ethical
hacking what we can infer from here is
what are the services that are being run
now these two ports 139 and 445 are
actually Windows SM SMP server ports
which are above the windows Samba server
now every service has a particular put
attached to it that will be consistent
whichever machine you may use Apache
server will always run on Port 80 SM SMB
servers will function on these two
ports now SMB servers have had a
vulnerability known as the Eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known as
of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not but
since it has the assmbly server open
it's worth a shot that we try that
exploit on this
machine now to start the exploit on this
we're going to open another terminal
over
here and we're going to use Metasploit
for trying the exploit there we're going
to write pseudo msf
console msf console is the keyword for
launching the Met plit
console enter the root password and wait
for metas plit to
launch other than the ports we can also
see that it has checked the host name of
the system and the operating system as
well now that the metas spit is
open we're going to launch the
exploit now before launching we're going
to have to to check what exploits are
there for the Eternal blue
vulnerability we're going to write use
exploit blue and we're going to check
what kind of results we are getting over
here as you can
see serial number n exploit Windows SMB
ms710 Eternal blue it was first
disclosed in
2017 and SM SMB remote kernel bull
rtion let's say we're going to use this
particular exploit now all of this may
be confusing if you're not aware of
Metasploit but remember this is the next
stage of ethical hacking which comes
into the gaining access part we're going
to use exploit number n as we found
above to use exploit number
nine we're going to set a
payload which is our malicious code that
will run on the victim
machine now we're going to
check some options as you can see it has
by default pointed it to the 445 Port
since that is the port where SMB server
can be accessed
from the parameter that's missing over
here is our host the our host is is the
IP address of the vulnerable machine
basically the machine in which we want
to attack now I'm going to use the set
command to set the IP
address now if we
check we now
have a victam IP address
set another parameter that we can change
is the lhost this is basically the IP
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access now if you have
remember we had connected using a VPN so
we're going to be assigned a new IP
according to the VPN so if you write if
config and check this one tu10 is the
VPN adapter this is our IP address that
we have been assigned in the server in
the network where the vulnerable machine
is present so we're going to copy this
IP address you to to move over this
workspace and we're going to set L host
with that IP
address with that our options are set
now we're going to run
exploit and it's going to check if samb
server vulnerability is
present as you can see it has written
that the target is vulnerable to this
particular exploit it's going to send
the malicious code and the malicious
code is set in the p Lo that is sent
above and we now have the shell command
of the Windows
machine as you can see C Windows system
32 to be sure that this is in fact this
Windows machine that is being used we're
going to write ip config which is a
Windows only shell
command
as you can see this is the IP address
that was assigned to the victim victim
machine now while the major part of this
process was done on
Metasploit we would not have reached the
stage had we not found out that the 139
and 445 ports are open which basically
pointed us that we can try the internal
blue exploit of the windows Samba
servers similarly all the scan that we
run serve as a preface to the actual
stages or the actual hacking stages of
the
campaigns this SV command was necessary
because we could check what are the
exact services that are being running in
some cases if if it Apache server is
being run there are particular versions
which have particular exploits those
exploits will not work on other versions
so we're going to have to check what
particular version is being run and
accordingly apply the exploit that can
be done in the metlo or you can run some
other tool but what exact exploit you
have to run and which vulnerability we
have to Target that is where nmap comes
to help with the world moving towards
the next generation of computer hardware
the software side of things still has a
lot left to be discovered with the
majority of laptops coming with Windows
pre-installed many users are devoid of
the Linux operating system experience
which is more resource friendly than the
mainstream operating systems
it can be attributed to the difficulty
people used to face when installing a
new operating system like Linux in the
old days however a lot of these issues
are fixed nowadays thanks to the big
names like Debian and Ubuntu who have
been instrumental in making Linux based
operating systems as userfriendly as
possible but which one of them is better
for you let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today as we answer this
question for
you we start by learning about the op
operating systems from a Layman's
perspective and uncovering the basic
offerings of both
entities next we cover the unique
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
how they stack up against each other and
other industry
counterparts moving on we take a look at
some pointers before installing each of
these operating systems and the
respective download
links finally We compare the contrasting
features of both OBU and Debian and
infer the kind of users each OS skaters
to so let's start by learning about ubu
and Debian in
general Ubuntu is an open- Source free
Linux distribution it is an operating
system for cloud computing in accordance
with support with open stack Ubunto is
developed by the canonical community and
it is freely available also canona
limited is responsible for the funding
of Ubuntu basically Ubuntu is released
every 6 months free support is available
for 9 months after every release and
long-term support which are the LTS is
released every 2 years the first release
of Ubuntu was in October
2004 you must have heard about uban 2 no
matter what it is the most popular Linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for Linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start of course Ubuntu
managed to simplify the Linux experience
years back and that is the reason why it
is still so popular even with several
impressive Linux distributions available
right now every new release is more
polished and comes loaded with new
features and
improvements thanks to its huge user
base a number of software vendors have
made the applications compatible with
one2 while the catalog may not be as
extensive as Windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
advantage of Linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open-source alternatives to Major
proprietary software by lacking some
Polish and overall feature set most
alternatives are enough to get the job
done for majority of the users the
never-ending Community Support also
helps in troubleshooting should things
go wrong at any point in
time the default desktop environment in
ubo is gnome or a Unity the unity is a
modern desktop environment with a
powerful Search tool for finding all
your applications and doents with its
base setup as noome it integrates well
with common applications such as audio
players video players and social media
there are a few other desktop
environments for OB 2 as well with unity
as its Flagship
environment Dean on the other hand is a
free operating system for your computer
which started in 1996 and is maintained
by global
contributors if the operating system a
set of basic programs and utilities that
make your computer run it's score is the
kernel the kernel is the most
fundamental program on the computer
Debian uses the Linux kernel a
completely free piece of software which
are started by Linus trowal and
supported by thousands of programmers
worldwide a large part of the basic
tools that fill out the operating system
come from the gnu project and those
rules are free as
well Debian is the mother of rux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good-looking drro is so
popular inside the Linux developers
community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful UI later
on they found out the power of Debian
after using a bunch of distributions
from other developers you'll be
surprised to know that almost all other
popular consumer level dros are based on
Debian even U it is so stable and
feature Rich that the developers find it
easy to build their dros based on Debian
rather than building it from
scratch Debian is run and maintained on
its GitHub repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
CommunityWide feedback and holistic
approach to open source development of
the Debian operating system thanks to
this variety of personnel the source
code of Debian comprises around 70
different programming and scripting
languages Debian supports all kinds of
graphical environments ranging from full
feature desktop environments to lighter
Alternatives and emaa minimalist window
managers you want to ships with unity
desktop by default where the package
manager can install the gome environment
if needed while also including cinnamon
lxd xfc KDE and mate on the other hand
Debian gives you the choice of choosing
which desktop environment you want from
the getco by providing ISO files for
each desktop environment
individually now that we understand
where both these operating systems stand
let us take a look at some of the best
features offered by each of these
distributions open 2 is the closest
thing to a household name among desktop
Linux distributions it is a great
distribution to start with and it's even
a great distribution to keep using after
you more experienced if you're happy
with it it is user friendly in a lot of
ways it provides a simple desktop has an
easy installer and provides a checkbox
during the installation process that
will automatically install Flash plugins
and various codecs that you will need
for multim media support there's an
additional drivers tool that will detect
closed Source or proprietary drivers
that might be necessary to get all your
Hardware working and easily install them
for
you ubu is produced by canonical and
their friends it is run as an open
project to enable others with diverse
ideas to benefit from all the work the
developers do to deliver the world's
best open platform still canonical is
responsible for delivering six monthly
Milestone releases and regular LTS
releases from Enterprise production use
Enterprises can count on canonical to
support secure and manage uban
infrastructure and devices with more
than 500 employees in over 39 countries
the company underpins the critical
infrastructure for thousands of
businesses and millions of OBU users
around the
world Unity desktop was originally
developed by canonical and introduced
earlier for Netbook computers with UB to
10.10 then it went on to be the default
desktop environment for uban 2
eventually it has been dropped by
canonical and replaced by gnome however
it has made a comeback after uban to
18.04 while being completely stable the
HUD and Global menu hold up just fine
with major application such as lib
office Thunderbird and other web
browsers that means that the unity
desktop works as it is supposed to while
making you more productive when some
desktop environments have a steep
learning curve Unity is very intuitive
for new users in spite of deviating from
the traditional start menu format that
the windows users are generally
accustomed
to the calamaras installer is a
framework by design it is very
customizable in order to satisfy a wide
variety of needs and use cases calamaras
aims to be easy usable beautiful
pragmatic and more importantly
distribution agnostic calamaras includes
an advanced partitioning feature as well
which supports for both manual and aut
automated partitioning operations it is
the first installer with an automated
replace partition option which makes it
easy to reuse a partition over and over
for distribution
testing coming to Debian it is a
community distribution through and
through it's governed by a board of
elected developers it has its own
internal structure and laws and just
about everyone working on it is a
volunteer making it completely Community
Driven it is maintained and developed by
programmers and developers all around
the world
this form of development ensures
continuity if one of the developers
decides to stop working on the project
another developer might come in and take
place and keep the project going on it
is completely free of centralized
control and this is also one of the
reasons for an undecided stable release
cycle Debian Sid is the permanently
unstable development version of Debian
it's where the latest versions of
programs are being considered for
inclusion in the deban release cycle are
uploaded and tested because has no
official installed media and the few net
boot images that are built often don't
work even people who are willing to risk
using a development version may have
trouble installing it however it Still
Remains the best place to test new
features that have not yet made their
way onto the stable
Branch Debian has only free and open
source software in its repositories this
is mostly ample for users except for
users who use Hardware that only has
proprietary drivers these repositories
work well in most cases it is possible
to add other repos as well that have Pro
priority software if that is the
requirement Dean Standard Version is
very stable as software and libraries in
it go through rigorous testing the
stability makes Debian a perfect server
OS and it's also the same reason why
average user shy away from using Debian
as a primary OS on
desktop this is also one of the reasons
why many developers use Dean as a base
for their derivative one of which is
also UB
now that we are aware of each
distribution's unique features let's
take a look at how we can go ahead and
install these operating systems and
where we can get the downloadable
images when it comes to ubu ubu has
dropped the support for 32bit systems
currently it supports only 64bit devices
and armm devices installation is easy
with the calaris framework coming into
iOS pre default and the latest ISO can
be downloaded from the link being shown
on the screen right now in the case of
dbn the support for multiple range of
devices is still present that can also
include 32-bit systems and other smaller
devices which are not
modern even though it does not use the
calaris installer even downloading the
ISO file can be a bit hectic for newer
users considering this is a distribution
aimed at developers and intermediate
users finding the right link can be
difficult
because of which we have mentioned the
link on the screen below where you can
get the latest ISO depending on which
desktop environment you choose to go
with with the installation out of the
way let's take a direct comparison of
the features between both ubu and
Debian Debian is a community-driven
open- source Linux distribution and is
primarily aimed to be robust capable and
most importantly free on the other hand
ubu is also and free on open source like
Debian but it's backed up and developed
by a canonical which is a corporate
company Debian and uban 2 are both
fundamentally fast regarding performance
as Debian comes bare minimum and is not
bundled or prepacked with additional
software and features it makes it super
fast and lightweight at least when
compared with uban 2
directly both Ubuntu and Debian use the
same AP software packaging management
system but provide a different software
Repository
Debian is more like promoting freedom of
choosing free software thus it does not
include any proprietary software by
default you can always install the paid
versions but you have to enable it
manually Urn to focuses on usability
including all the software including
free paid open source closed Source Etc
Ubunto also introduced a universal
package management system called Snap it
will be used across dros and thus
prevent more drro based software
fragmentations as the Debian distro does
not contain any proprietary blobs there
might be some problems with drivers and
firmware that means Debian lacks some of
the essential proprietary firmware by
default but the users can enable the
repository and install it manually like
other PID software on the other hand UB
2 does not care how much whether it's
paid free open source or clone source so
it includes as many drivers and firmware
as possible ubun to also lets you
install and configure the necessary
drivers in firmware automatically during
installation or
afterward if you are a gamer then you
will probably be concerned with the
latest software drivers and Hardware
support while Debian can potentially
provide that it is likely that you might
end up breaking your installation as
mentioned before uban to supports
certain proprietary packages as well
which often consist of graphic drivers
which are essential to gaming Debian
focuses on the open-source aspect of the
software hence it can be a well-known
fact that with gamers to and some other
distributions like popos have been
working much better regarding both
software and Hardware
support regarding the audience they
cater to both Ubuntu and Dean have their
pros and cons Ubuntu is a very good
distribution for amateur users with
little to no experience and if they want
to have the latest versions of packages
and applications at all times on their
systems it is also for users who do not
want a lot of customizability in spite
of unity being very customed as a
desktop
environment it is also perfect for users
with newer Hardware since it comes
updated with all the latest graphical
devices and their respective
drivers Debian on the other hand is
cater towards a little bit of
experienced users who can fix some minor
bugs on their own or with minimal
Community Support it also is for users
who want to support an open- Source
approach rather than an operating system
which is devoid of any contribution from
other end and is primarily backed by a
corpor oration it also doesn't favor
gaming since it does not guarantee
compatibility with all the newest
graphic cards or even Wi-Fi cards in
some
cases however due to the low memory
overhead Debian is very useful for
people who are looking to run home
servers or even corporate environments
where running servers on Debian will
provide much more use data protection is
of Paramount importance in today's world
the vast amount of data flow between
corporations and consumer needs to be
secured considering that they entrusted
with a lot of belief a company can spend
millions of dollars on the most secure
servers but it takes a single hacker to
ruin all the Goodwill between the
organizations to prevent these malicious
attacks many automated security systems
have been developed but none of them
have been as used as ideas platforms
which are also known as intrusion
detection systems welcome to this
introductory lesson on intrusion
detection systems so let's go through
the topics that we are going to cover
today we start with a basic definition
of idea is from a Layman's perspective
then moving on we cover the multiple
types of intruders that seek to access
confidential information without any
authorization next we cover the basic
ways to detect intrusion signatures from
the perspective of a network
administrator we then take a look at the
different types of IDE systems that can
be used in corporate environments today
a small explanation of the two types of
protection is Then followed by an
introduction to some of the most
well-known ideas tools on the market so
let's get started started with what is
an
IDs an intrusion detection system is an
app or device that monitors inbound and
outward Network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes and
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior an
administrator then reviews alarms and
take action to remove the threat for
example an IDs might inspect the data
carried by Network traffic to see if it
contains no malware or other malicious
content if it detects this type of
threat it sends an alert to your
security team so they can investigate
and remediated once your team receives
the alert they must act quickly to
prevent an attack from taking over the
system to ensure that the ideas doesn't
slow down Network performance the
solutions often use a switched Port
analyzer or a text access port to
analyze a copy of the inline data
traffic so that they do not meddle with
the actual
traffic however the do not block threat
once they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do regardless of
whether you set up a physical device or
an IDs program the system can recognize
attack patterns with network packets
monitor user Behavior identify abnormal
network activity or ensure user and
system activity do not go against
security
policies the main goal of an ideas is to
detect the anomalies before the hackers
complete the objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any ideas fit its own unique needs
expert advised what this means is that
an IDs cannot be a one siiz fits-all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively and this requires a Savvy
ideas analyst to tailor the ideas for
the interest and needs of a given site
and knowledgeable train system analyst
are SC the trick with ideas is that you
have to know what the attack is to be
able to identify it the ideas has always
had the patient zero problem you have to
have found someone who got sick and died
before you can identify it it can
usually go for two types of protection
active protection and passive in a
passive system the idas detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
ideas responds to the suspicious
activity by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious
source so now that we understand what an
ideas is let us go through the different
types of intruders IDs platforms must be
aware of to understand the type of
intruders let us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the ideas Platforms in place so let's
say a hacker tries to breach the system
from outside the organization this can
be done using multiple attacks like dos
attacks injection attacks Etc the
category of individuals that are not
authorized to use a system but still
exploit users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques
are known as
masqueraders a masquerader is an
intruder that is an outsider who does
not have direct access to the system and
aims to attack unethically by stealing
data or
information however there is another
Intruder who is theoretically harder to
detect and approve than a masquerader
these are the people within the
organization who want to weaken the
security defenses be for corporate
Espionage or to Aid other
masqueraders the category of individuals
that are authorized to use a system but
misuse the granted access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as
Miser misers are people that are
insiders and have direct access to the
system which they aim to attack
unethically by stealing data or
information let us now go through some
of the ways the idas platforms can
detect intrusion before it is too late
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature
page intrusion and the anomaly based
intrusion signature based intrusion
detection is designed to detect possible
threats by comparing the given Network
traffic and log data to existing attack
patterns these patterns are called
sequences and could include bite
sequence which is also known as
malicious instruction sequences
signature based detection enables you to
accurately detect and identify possible
known attacks anomaly based intrusion
detection is the opposite it's designed
to pinpoint unknown attacks such as new
malware and adapt to them on the Fly
using machine learning machine learning
techniques enable an intrusion detection
system to create baselines of
trustworthy activity which is known as a
trust model then compare new behaviors
to verifi trust models false alarms can
occur when using an anomaly based ideas
since previously unknown yet legitimate
Network traffic could be falsely
identified as malicious activity now if
you combine both of those you have the
hybrid intrusion detection they use
signature based and anomaly based
intrusion detection to increase the
scope of your ideas this enables you to
identify as many threats as possible a
comprehensive intrusion detection system
can understand the evasion technique
cyber criminals use to trick and ideas
to thinking there isn't an attack taking
place these techniques could include
fragmentation low bandwidth attack
patent change evasion and many more
we can now take a look at the type of
protection offered by IDs
platforms there are a couple of phase
that can be set up so let's go through
each
method the first is a network based
ideas the sensors are deployed at
strategic points within the network such
as within the DMZ or at the Network's
parameter the sensor can monitor
individual packets of inbound and
outbound traffic to and from all devices
on the network it analyzes them for
malicious activity and depending on the
networ Network architecture and amount
of traffic involved multiple instances
of network based ideas may be necessary
the second category is host based
intrusion detection systems or
HIDs an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal Network intrusions
identified by analyzing operating
specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or Access Control list and the
monitoring system appc application logs
as well they augment network based idea
systems by detecting animalist traffic
which originate within the organization
or from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that is attempting to spread it to other
internal host is an issue that a network
based idas could potentially fail to
detect the third variant is a cloudbased
intrusion detection
system because of the internet facing
nature of the cloud on premises IDE
Solutions are not necessarily optimized
for
monitoring for example network-based
sensors need to be deployed within the
cloud at an environment's Network
perimeter and yet a cloud service
provider may or may not have a way to
facilitate this cloud-based servers use
purpose-built cloud sensors that use
cloud service provider application
programming interface or cloud service
provider apis to get as much visibility
as possible into your Cloud
environment now that we understand the
different types of idas deployment
tactics let us go through some tools
that excel in this field offering
top-of-the-line implementations in a
corporate and consumer
environment the first tool being covered
is the solar wind security event
manager the solar wind security event
manager is designed to integrate
real-time log data from across your
infrastructure enabling it to act both
as a network based idea system and a
host based idea system the solution can
let you discover all kinds of malicious
attacks and help you protect your
network from H it is also designed to
enact both signature based and anamaly
based intrusion detection by comparing
sequences of network traffic against a
set of customizable
rules next we have the McAfee life Safe
macafe Life safe is an intrusion
detection system designed to bring a
real-time threat awareness to your
physical and virtual networks it uses
signature based inion prevention and
anomaly based intrusion detection along
with emultion techniques to spot and
identify malicious activity
maafe is also built to correlate threat
activity with application usage which
can further prevent network issues
stemming from cyber
attacks next we have bluma bluma is a
security information and event
management platform built to enact a
detection and responses across your
cloud and on premises environments it is
designed to continuously monitor your it
infrastructure for suspicious activity
and misconfigurations both of which
could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches
it enables you to respond to an attack
in progress and stop malicious actors in
The Tracks monitoring usage of corporate
data and access to privilege information
had been a daunting task before the
Advent of IM am encompassing numerous
apis single sign on Frameworks and data
handling policies imem has established
itself as a key component of every it
department but how does it enforce these
rules and who are the key benefactors of
these policies what about the advantages
of these Frameworks and the the workflow
of these systems we are here today to
answer these questions let's take a look
at some of the topics to be covered
today we start by learning about IM am
that is identity and access management
from a surface level so as to put a
clear idea of what it is next we cover
the general workflow and process of how
I am Works moving on we cover some of
the tools that find the place in an IM
am framework and are crucial
components finally we go through some of
the advantages of the IM am learning
what makes them a lucrative deal for
organizations so let's get started by
learning about IM am from a surface
level
perspective identity and access
management or am is a set of processes
policies and tools for defining and
managing the roles and access privileges
of individual Network entities to a
variety of cloud and on premise
applications the users can include
customers Partners employees devices
like computers smartphones routers Etc
the core objective of IM IM systems is
one digital identity per individual or
item once the digital identity has been
established it must be maintained
modified and monitored throughout each
users or devices access life cycle
access and user are two vital IM
Concepts access refers to the actions
permitted to be done by a user like view
create or change a file
users could be employees Partners
suppliers contractors or even customers
furthermore employees can be further
segmented based on their roles IM
systems are designed to perform three
key tasks identify authenticate and
authorize meaning that only the right
person should have access to computers
Hardware software apps any it resources
etc for the entry of new users or the
changing of the roles of existing users
the list of access access privileges
must be up to date all the time IM
functions usually fall under it
departments or section that handle cyber
security and data
management now that we understand the
importance of IM am in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework we have
multiple components that Aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them
individually principal is an entity that
can perform actions on an awsc Source or
any Cloud management system a user a
role or an application can be a
principle it's always the principal who
raises a concern to access or modify
data on servers serving as the first
point of contact in the IM am
workflow authentication is the process
of confirming the identity of the
principle trying to access the product
the principal must provide s credentials
or required keys for authentication this
step can be further enhanced by multiple
authentication factors and Googs among
other things once the ENT identity is
confirmed the principal has the ability
to view the data behind the wall of
security and take the necessary
steps when it comes to requests a
principal then sends a request to the
cloud management system specifying the
action and which resource should perform
it in this step the user can ask to
modify delete edit or affect other users
in this particular bucket of
organization by changing the data or the
information when it comes to
authorization it carries out the of an
organization identity and access
management processes once the user has
been authenticated users are granted
authorizations according to the role at
an organization the practice is referred
to as role based access control or
rbac authorizations determine a roles
resources and level of access in the
network these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more for example an accounting
department employee who regularly works
with payroll software must be authorized
to do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it well
authentication is fully straightforward
authorizations and their management are
far more challenging authorizations
consist of complex set of rules and
policies and groups which are permitted
explicitly configured per user
account with the working of IM
Frameworks out of the way let's cover
some of the tools that these systems
work
on SSO is an IM tool that enables a user
to log into one an organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a designed set of other
properties for example when you log into
Google you're automatically logged into
your Gmail and your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single sign on
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application for organizations SSO
helps in collecting valuable insights
about user behavior and preferences
since it attacks them as they move from
one application to another connected by
one single
login next is multiactor authentication
or
MFA implementing multiactor
authentication is crucial to protect
your organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of
MFA however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security for example in business to
Consumer scenarios you need to consider
ux and try not to create unnecessary
friction for users who don't want to be
subjected to heighten scrutiny every
time they log in for Workforce am you
may want a more stringent MFA since the
consequences of an unauthorized party
gaining access to your private Network
can be so devastating a modern IM
solution will allow you to implement MFA
only when it's needed this can be
accomplished through setup
authentication or adaptive
authentication in which users only
trigger MFA if they're trying to access
sensitive data or their behavior is
flagged as
risky in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted fishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box there are multiple ways IM
systems can help detect and mitigate
these malicious attacks IM Solutions
detect attacks by monitoring signals
such as the velocity of traffic
detection of login patterns that differ
from a user's routine
use of a breached password use of
devices and IP addresses with a poor
reputation among other things these are
some of the most widely used tools when
it comes to IM Frameworks but why do we
go through setting up so many tools and
firewalls let's go through some of the
advantages of using IM systems in both
corporate and consumer
environments IM solution helps identify
and mitigate security risks you can use
IM to identify policy violations or
remove inappropriate access privileges
without having to search through
multiple distributed systems you can
also leverage IM IM to ensure that
security measures are in place to meet
Regulatory and auditing
requirements IM am provides a common
platform for Access and identity
management information you can apply the
same security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the
organization the IM framework can help
you enforce policies related to user
authentication privileges and validation
and attend to the privilege cre
problems IM simplifies signup and user
management processes for application
owners end users and system
administrators it makes it simple to
provide and manage access and PR mostes
user
satisfaction IM Services can also lower
operating costs using Federated identity
Services means you no longer need local
identities for external users this makes
application Administration easier
cloud-based IM Services can reduce the
need to buy and maintain on premise
infrastructure so importance of a cyber
security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is there for the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is the
certification itself which which allows
me to be eligible to apply for a
particular job rule so obtaining a cyber
security certification ensures or shows
uh to the organization that you're
applying to that you do have that pre
prerequisite knowledge and you should be
shortlisted for an interview the
knowledge that you have gained during
the training will help you when you
attend that interview and when you
attempt to answer the questions asked to
you so these certifications are designed
for a specific rule uh for example a
forensic investigation certificate will
teach you how to investigate a crime
scene forensically a digital crime scene
for a matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
Advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
cred certifications can be classified in
three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
uh in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
uh the price points for each and every
exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish the routing uh the pathing of
how data packets will travel across the
network this certification covers all
the basic concepts that you require to
understand networking the basic
requirements for this certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that
there are no other prerequisites so it's
just that you need a bachelor's degree
and then you can apply uh you can study
for this you can undergo a training and
then you can attempt the exam uh the
certification provider obviously is
Cisco so the knowledge that is limited
to this training and certification is
for Cisco devices only the exam fees for
this certification is approximately
$325 the exam when it is conducted uh it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 90 minutes the
type of questions that you going to get
is multiple choice questions where you
have a question and four answers and you
have to choose the correct answers among
those drag and drop where you have to
click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate Place probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular uh position if you
place it correctly you answer the answer
the question correctly otherwise it's
wrong and a simulator where you where
there could be a configuration you need
to configure it in a particular Manner
and then check whether the configuration
is correct or not the pass Mark is
around 800 to 850 out of a possible
thousand marks so each question will
have a different weightage depending on
the depth of the question depending on
the difficult level of the question or
the difficulty level of the question
which uh would then count towards your
marks and if you score 800 to 850 that's
when you clear the exam the job roles as
we have discussed over here would be
more more on the network administrator
side or a network engineer side
depending on the level of experience
that you have the salaries that are
expected from this job roles in the US
are around $5,000 to $90,000 annually
the next one is the comcha certification
called Security Plus comcha is also a
global certification Authority for uh
infosec courses so this certification
teaches candidates on how to secure
applications networks and devices it
focuses on Hands-On practical skills in
the field of network security I have
trained people on this certification
myself so uh I know this certification
is quite Hands-On it deals with the
concepts to the core it helps you
understand the concepts and then in the
Practical Hands-On demo uh you need to
execute the Practical yourself so that
uh you can gain that knowledge the
recommended level for a candidate to
attempt this training would be at least
around 2 years of experience in the it
sector in addition if you have already
been certified for Network plus
certification from comia which is the
Baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is
$339 the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's 1 minute
per question it sounds like a lot of
time but believe me the questions can be
a little bit confusing can be a little
bit lengthy so you will require all
those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technically nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance- based the pass Mark for
this exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900 the job profiles for this
kind of a certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security engineer position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this uh person
would be around
$72,000 then comes the CH or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC Council now this is a very well-known
course and also uh EC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from ethical
hackers perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a
pentester where you go into an
organization you test their security
controls or you'll test their devices
find out flaw flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have 2 years of experience at least
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking maybe a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary uh before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC counil and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
4 hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for CH
there are two exams one is the multiple
choice questions and the second is a
practical exam where uh you need to
solve some given problems to you in a
iLab scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for CH practical the cut off
varies from 65 to 85% depending on the
questions that you have answered and the
weightage associated with each and every
question as said the job roles would be
as a penetration tester a security
engineer and your salaries would start
from around $90,000 annually then comes
the CND or the certified Network
Defender also from EC Council now this
is more on the network defense side so
here again the job roles would be where
you uh where there's a network that you
have and you're going to try to secure
the network and the communications that
are going to travel over the network so
you need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or uh in a
similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is EC Council
and the certification is placed ear a
little bit below C so it becomes Network
defense then C where you're going to
become a penetration Tester the exam
fees for this certification is $350 US
the exam the exam is of 100 questions to
be answered in 4 hours again it's just a
multiple choice questions so you get a
question with four options you answer
the correct one and you move on to the
next question the pass percentage again
varies from 60 to 85% depending on the
questions answered and the weightage of
that question job rules to be applied
Network defense technician CN analyst or
a security analyst from a network
perspective salaries would range from
$65,000 to $75,000 per anom then comes
the forensic investigator course which
is exactly what it is digital forensic
investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has uh
taken place so the candidate must have
at least 2 years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how Network work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is s after mainly in the
law enforcement areas but there are a
few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to uh conduct their own
investigations the certification
provider for this is also EC Council and
the exam fees are5 $100 this is an
advanced level certification so uh
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
you attemp this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in 4 hours again
it's just a multiple choice question
exam the cut off again is from 60% to
85% depending on the questions and the
weightage of each and every question job
rules it security specialist network
security pro the job roles foreign sake
investigators law enforcement agencies
security specialist lists homeland
security jobs and your salaries would be
around $88,000 and above all right now
let's talk about the managerial level
certifications Coit stands for control
objectives for information and related
Technologies it's a certification that
will give a candidate an in-depth
knowledge of the framework which kit is
all about and the framework helps you
manage and govern Enterprise it
environments now this is Advanced
certification so around 8 years of
managerial experience is suggested
before you attempt the Coit 5 certific
ification to understand all the aspects
and to help you implement the framework
properly the certification certificate
provider is isaka the exam fees is
around
$175 now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's a very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50% the job roles associated with
this certification would be to uh when
you apply for for a information security
manager or as a security consultant or a
cyber security manager and your roles
and responsibilities would be to govern
the and uh it space that the
organization owns so all the servers
desktops the network the data flows the
datab basis everything and how it needs
to be managed and how it needs to be
governed in a secure manner annual
salaries would be around $100,000 plus
then the cism also called as cisem it
stands for certified information
security manager and as the name
suggests it's a security manager
certification it helps the candidate in
understanding the relationship between
business goals and information security
so now you're going into the space where
you're not only technical in nature but
you also have to understand the business
needs the goals of the business and you
have to align the information security
of your infrastructure along with the
business needs and the business goals so
it is your inputs that are going to go
to the management to see if the
infrastructure is aligned to to the
business goals or if the infrastructure
or the business goals need any
fine-tuning around 5 years of work
experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the 5 years
the candidate must have a background as
an information security manager for 3
years so you have some experience as a
manager uh you have implemented those
things yourselves which will give you a
better understanding and then you
attempt the certification again
providing by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members is
$575 for non-members it is
$760 the exam is where you have to
answer $150 questions in 4 hours uh
quite a bit of time but questions are
going to be uh scenario based questions
where they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of 800
your job profiles would be either a risk
manager or a risk consultant analyzing
the business business requirements to
the infrastructure security that uh that
you have and to identify if there any
risks associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around $88,000 and above then the cisa
or the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
5 years of work work experience in the
field of Information Systems auditing
control or security is necessary now
here the question would be what's the
difference security is where you're
technical in nature you have done let's
say a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even uh UTM
and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
uh ISO 270001 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members are
$575 whereas non isaka members will have
to pay $760 for the certification 150
questions again in 4 hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand the real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanisms should be in place
pass Mark is 450 out of 800 your job
rules would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or a Information
Technology consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103,000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as krisk uh
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field of is controls
that means information security controls
you should have knowledge about
Fireballs you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after which you're going
to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risk and
treat those risks in their lifetime
certificate provider again is isaka $575
for isaka members $760 for non isaka
members for the exam fees a similar
question 150 questions to be answered in
4 hours multiple choice based on
performances so they may give you a
scenario where you have to perform a
risk analysis and provide a report and a
solution based on your findings again
the pass Mark is 450 out of 800 the job
profiles Associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to identify risks
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact anal analysis
to a certain how the organization is
going to be affected and then you will
also be looking at compliances as far as
these job roles are concerned average
annual salary would be 119,000 and above
moving on to advanced level
certification now this is where we come
across a cissp or the cisp certification
certified information system security
professional this is the gold standard
of all certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the IT world now
just to qualify you'll have to have 5
years of experience in the information
uh security field there are eight
domains that are specified by cissp and
you have to prove that you have
knowledge and you have work experience
of around 5 years in at least two of
those domains if you do not have those
kind of experiences you can still
attempt the exam but you become an
associate of ISC Square which means that
You' get six years to accomplish the 5
years of uh experience requirement for
this certification before taking up the
syst certification is suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact I've seen people do the
other way around they qualify for cissp
they give the exam once your cisp the
cisa or cesm CIS or cism exams are way
easier to crack but you need to have
that kind of experience I have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more fail at this certification in the
first attempt the certificate provided
is IC Square the exam fees is 6 $99 like
I said this certification is where most
sought after the gold standard in fact
there is hardly any other certifications
after this that you might want to do the
questions now the exam has changed if it
is the English version that you're
giving it's 150 questions to be answered
in 3 hours if it is a non-english exam
that you're attempting then it is 250
questions in 6 hours it's a marathon and
if you're opting for the 6 hour exam you
need to plan it really well it sounds
really easy but the questions are quite
tough they're scenario based and the
answers are quite confusing as well you
would get multiple choice questions you
would get drag and drop and you might
get simulators as well uh the pass Mark
is 700 out of 1,000 but each question
has a different weightage so uh it
depends on which questions are asked of
you and which questions you've answered
correctly the job rules associated with
this certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the ceso role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is
$18,000 for this certification
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives hence it is no
surprise that the need for skilled cyber
Security Professionals is on the rise
cyber security is a lucrative field and
there is a dir of skilled cyber Security
Experts therefore currently a career in
cyber security is something you should
consider if you're looking for an
interesting job role on that note hey
everyone welcome to yet another exciting
video by simply learn which will take
you through the top 10 highest paying
cyber security jobs for 2022 but before
we begin if you're new here and haven't
subscribed already make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and the bell icon for
interesting Tech videos every day so
let's get started at number 10 we have
the job role of a cyber security
analyst cyber security analysts are
professionals who keep a constant check
on any threat and monitor the company's
Network for potential vulnerabilities
they react swiftly to restore protection
if compromised they identify and correct
flaws uncovered in the company's
applications programs Security Systems
computer networks and more cyber
security analysts even recommend ways to
improve the business's overall security
and communicate the specific measures to
be taken they compile ongoing safety
reports document security issues and
measures taken to resolve
them now let's have a look at the salary
of a cyber security
analyst according to glor a cyber
security analyst in the United States
earns about
$80,000 per anom and in India you can
earn nearly 6 lakh rupees
annually next on a list we have the job
role of an network engineer a network
engineer is a person who understands the
structure and network Essentials of the
entire organization at a macro level
they design and maintain any network
that supports the company's life cycle
and growth opportunities Network
Engineers take charge of the
configuration and installation of
network devices and
services they also collaborate with the
security team and ensure network
security through the implementation of
tools and procedures in line with them
they monitor Network performance and
ensure reliability and
availability according to glassor a
network engineer in the US earns over
$85,000 per anom and in India the
average salary is 4 lakhs annually
moving on the next job role on our list
is that of an ethical hacker ethical
hackers are Network Security Consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do there also known as white hat
hackers they scan the network and
systems for vulnerabilities before a
black hat hacker would ethical hackers
probe and test their network using
various penetration tools and software
additionally they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results according to pay scale in the US
a certified ethical hacker earns around
$96,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 5 lakh rupees
per anom
moving to our next job role we have
malware analyst a malware analyst
analyzes malicious software that
includes BS worms and Trojans to
understand the nature of their threat a
malware analyst has a dual mentality by
being both Forward Thinking and reverse
thinking moving on to the
responsibilities of a malware analyst
firstly they use tools and expert level
knowledge to help decide what kind of
malware they are dissembling and if they
have encountered this particular kind of
malware before four you will use Dynamic
malware analysis tools to achieve
insight into software attacks secondly
they also uncover hidden indicators of
compromise that should be blocked and
keep an organization software updated to
protect against the latest malware
threats according to glasto in the US a
malware analyst can earn about
$997,000 and the average salary for a
malware analyst is around 5 lakh rupees
in
India up next we have have another very
interesting job role that is information
security analyst an information security
analyst is an expert who plans
implements upgrades and scrutinizes
security protocols to safeguard an
organization's computer networks and
information these professionals play a
vital role in the public private and
nonprofit business sectors because they
Shield a company's sensitive and
fundamental information they use data
encryption firewalls and other relevant
security tools and applications to cover
and protect transfers of secret digital
information information security
analysts perform risk assessments Audits
and tests to ensure the proper
functioning of data processing
activities and security
measures as per glass door the national
average salary of an information
security analyst is around
$99,000 per anom in the states and as
per indeed.com in India you can earn
nearly 7 lakh rupees per
anim let's have a look at the next
highest paying cyber security jobs that
is cyber security engineer a cyber
security engineer helps to design and
Implement methodologies to secure the
organization cyers space they also help
in testing and monitoring systems
frequently to make sure that all of the
systems are up to dat and work perfectly
to defend the
information they troubleshoot security
and network problems and ensure that the
organization's data and infrastructure
are protected by enabling the
appropriate security controls cyber
security Engineers also conduct tests
and scans to identify any
vulnerabilities in the network and
system talking about the salary in the
United States a cyber security engineer
earns over
$101,000 per anim as per pay scale the
average salary for a cyber security
engineer in India is nearly 7 lakh
rupees
moving on to the next job role we have
senior security consultant a senior
security consultant protects their
client's Network through regular
situational
assessments senior Security Consultants
are required to carry out an assessment
of security networks to sport A System's
vulnerabilities strengths and
weaknesses following which they guide
different it teams in strengthening
their security by helping them pick the
right Solutions like new techniques or
tools they also create preventive
measures against future cyber
attacks according to indeed the average
annual salary of a senior security
consultant in the states is around
$104,000 and in India it is nearly 12
lakh
rupees next we have the role of an
application security
engineer application security Engineers
work with product managers and
developers to plan and Implement
security releases in order to understand
any vulnerabilities Within products they
carry out threat modeling tests Dynamic
tests and Security reviews following
this they optimize a given product's
efficacy they ensure that every step of
the software development life cycle
follows best security practices they
also help in testing the application
against security risks before
release according to glassor in the US
an application security engineer earns
around
$110,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 9 lakh rupees
per
anom moving on to our next job role we
have security architect a security
architect researches and plant the
security elements for their firms they
formulate company procedures and user
guides they designed robust security
structures that are capable of
preventing malware
attacks additionally they also approve
the installation of VPN routers and
firewalls according to glassor a
security architect in the US makes a
handsome sum of
$150,000 a year on an average and in
India they make around 20 lakh rupees
per
Anum and finally at number one on our
list we have the role of a chief
information security officer
ciso cisos are senior level officers in
an organization that duty is to ensure
the safety of the information they
develop Implement and maintain
information security and risk management
programs additionally they also interact
with stakeholders and regularly brief
them with information security
concerns according to glasto the average
annual salary of a chief information
security officer in the states is a
whopping
$195,000 and in India it is1 19 lakh
rupees per
anom so those were the the top 10
highest paying cyber security jobs for
2022 now let's have a look at the
company's hiring cyber Security
Professionals here we have Deo net app
KPMG Bosch HP Samsung CGI and GE to name
a few in this series we are going to
discuss about the interview questions
that will be asked to candidates uh in
the cyber security field we are going to
look at multiple options over here and
we're going to discuss various fields in
which these questions will be asked in
this video we are going to look at 10
different questions on networking then
we'll have 10 more questions on software
and programming another 10 questions on
operating systems and applications 10
questions on cyber attacks and then the
finally 10 questions on cryptography so
we're going to discuss over 50 odd
questions each in these different fields
which will help you crack your
interviews as far as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions let's start off
with question one what is the OSI model
explain the different layers of the OSI
model OSI largely is a theoretical model
uh utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcpip the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite so OSI
is known as the open systems inter
connection model it is a reference model
that describes how applications are
going to interact via the computer
network there are seven different layers
that we need to understand they are as
follows so in this diagram there are
these seven different layers we start
off from the bottom first is the
physical layer the data link layer
Network layer transport layer session
layer presentation and application when
uh such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identify these seven layers explaining
what the OSI model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after uh this basic
question so let's start off with the
physical layer this is the lowest layer
of the OSI model now this is where any
and every physicality of your computer
comes into the picture so it could be an
uh network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or a CAT 5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link
layer so on the data link layer as far
as networking is concerned we just need
to understand that data packet is
encoded decoded into bits at this layer
this is also the layer that deals with
Mac addressing so the physical address
of every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data packets over the network this
is where the MAC address resides on the
data link layer the next layer is the
network layer here datagrams are
transferred from one to another the
function of this layer are routing and
logical addressing the moment we talk
about routing and logical addressing IP
addresses come into the picture IP
version 4 IP version 6 so Network layer
will deal with IP addressing and the
routing of those packets then comes the
transport layer this is the layer
responsible for end to end connections
that automatically signifies that this
is where TCP and UDP will be working TCP
stands for transmission control protocol
UDP for user datagram protocol TCP is a
connection oriented protocol whereas UDP
is a connection L protocol these two
Protocols are utilized to establish
connectivity between two machines TCP is
a more reliable method of connectivity
because there are a lot of packets that
are sent across to verify that the data
has been sent data has been received and
so on so forth whereas UDP is a Connect
ction L protocol where data is just
dumped without verifying whether the
receiver actually receives that data or
not so in a nutshell on the transport
layer TCP and UDP make their appearance
and this is where that functionality
lies then comes the session there this
control signals between the computer it
establish maintains and terminates
connections between processes so in the
transport layer we talked about TCP and
UDP UDP being a connection less protocol
where data is just trans without
verifying whether the receiver received
that data or not whereas TCP we studied
is more of a reliable protocol does
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and then the next uh
segment of that data is being sent so
those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of TCP the acknowledgement
packets and uh those kind of packets
will be taken taken care of on the
session layer of the OSI
model then comes the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mine or encoding that is being utilized
the utf8 character set that we utilize
for presentation encryption mechanisms
all of these work on the presentation
layer and finally comes the application
layer where the application itself uses
a particular protocol so that the other
uh machine on the receiving end the
application on that machine will be able
to understand what the communication was
about right so in a
nutshell if if I start from up top the
application layer will deal with any of
the data that the application uh is
generating so maybe an user input you're
logging in you're typing the username
password all that data will be
constructed let's say into an HTTP or
https format that's where application
layer comes into the picture then the
formatting of which into
utf8 uh and the encryption of which
would be done at the presentation layer
then the transport layer and the session
layer would kick in to establish a TCP
session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity IP
addressing would be done on the network
layer Mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer and when everything
is ready on the physical layer the
packet will be sent out at the receiving
end the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen of the
recipient so this is the way you want to
explain this question you want to be
very concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete Al with the layers you just want
to give the basic functionality want to
demonstrate that you understand what the
OSI layer is how the computer functions
and you want to move on from there if
the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions so that's question
one moving on to the question
two question two is Define unicasting
multicasting and
broadcasting now this is a question
which can be very lengthy but again most
of your interview questions are designed
that way it's B basically to understand
how much conceptually you are aware
about these Technologies so you have to
be very concise don't go uh rattling
about technology too much but in a
concise manner just try to explain what
these things is so when data is being
transmitted over a network it can be
trans transmitted either in one of these
particular manners it can either be a
unicast multicast or a broadcast so what
is
unicost unicost is when a message is
sent from a single user to a single
receiver so one to one right so uh one
machine talking to another machine and
nobody else so also known as Point too
Communications one point to one other
point if you have to send information to
multiple receivers then you will have to
send it using
multicast right so this is where your
multicast networking comes into the
picture so in our case uh let's assume
it's a network where there are uh
there's a Class C Network approximately
255 odd machines and with in these there
are two machines that want to talk to
each other if they want to talk between
each other it would be a point to-point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place if one machine wants to
talk to multiple machines then the
multicast comes into the picture as the
name suggest in this mode of
communication data is sent from one or
more more sources to multip mple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines uh are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever a message needs to be sent
through those groups it will be
identified by the igmp protocol and then
that particular message will be sent to
those multiple machines that are members
of those particular
groups and then comes the broadcast the
third method is known as the broadcast
as it says it is going to broadcast to
all so this is one to all that is
communication between a single user and
it is going to be sent to all the
machines in that particular Network
right so the three ways unicast is one
to one multicast is one to many and
broadcast is one to all then question
number three what is DNS DNS stands for
domain name name system it is like the
internet's phone book that is
responsible for mapping the domain name
into its corresponding IP address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a Google Chrome browser we type
in w.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
Google comes in front of us the website
rather now how does the computer know
who Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google and
words like that computers don't
computers deal with binary zeros and
ones right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in in the browser window in the
address bar google.com and press enter a
DNS query is generated automatically by
the browser where a packet is sent to
our DNS servers asking what the IP
address is is so in short DNS resolves
domain names to their corresponding IP
addresses there is a DNS server which
will have this index a database of all
the domains associated with their IP
addresses if one particular DNS server
does not have that information that
you're looking for it may query another
DNS server who may have that particular
response so the first thing is when you
type in domain name it gets resolved
with the DNS it identifies the IP
address corresponding to that particular
domain name and thus allows the computer
to route that packet to the particular
server where that domain name resides so
in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local PC you have typed in
cyers security.com there's a DNS
resolution that a query that goes to the
DNS server what is the IP of cyers
security.com the DNS server looks it up
in its particular uh database if it has
the corresponding IP address it will
then respond back the IP address is
2521 after which the packet is sent off
to cyers security.com moving on to the
question number four what is a
firewall now this is a very good
question and normally a very basic
answer that I've ever heard is that a
firewall is a hardware and a software
firewall but that's the functionality of
a firewall that is what how you can
install a firewall but there are
different types of firewalls and there
is a specific functionality that a
firewall is created for
right so firewall is either a hardware
or software but its responsibility is
for blocking either incoming or outgoing
traffic from the internet to your
computer they secure a network so
essentially the firewall will allow a
connection to happen or dis connection
to happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a
firewall okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on
the firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that Network or some traffic
is to be blocked from entering that
Network so as the screen shows the
firewall rules will analyze whether the
traffic is good if yes it will allow if
the traffic is bad it will block the
traffic and not allow that connection
from happening in the first place now
there are few common types of firewalls
that also need to be included in the
answer to this question and the first
one is a packet filtering firewall these
are the most common types that you will
come across which analyze packets and
lets them pass through only if they
match an established security rule set
now here people do get confused when we
say that we analyze packets people think
that these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct when a definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of deep packet
inspection or DPI as it is known if that
capability comes into the picture you're
basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or an intrusion
prevention system in today's world
called as a nexgen firewall okay so a
packet filtering firewall essentially
will only analyze data packets for its
source and destination IP addresses port
numbers and the protocol that is being
utilized it will then map that
information to the rules that are there
on the firewall and based on those rules
it will either allow that connection to
happen or disallow that connection from
happening the second type of is a proxy
firewall these firewalls filter Network
traffic at the application Level So when
you say application Level they work at
the layer seven of the OSI model packet
filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they work on IP
addressing and port numbers will work on
the network layer of the OSI model also
on the transport layer because because
they also look at protocols proxy
firewalls will work at layer 7even which
is the uh application layer of the OSI
model and will deal with application
Level protocol such as HTTP https FTP
SMTP and so on so
forth and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall uh these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do the job of the first and the second
type of
firewalls the packets are compared to
known uh trusted packets but now the
first question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and pro proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the option
saying it is a hardware or software this
is the responsibility the functionality
of a firewall is to allow good traffic
and disallow bad traffic based on the
rules that have been configured on the
firewall and then You' got basically
three types of firewalls packet
filtering proxy and stateful multilayer
and just include a brief description of
each of these firewalls if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a VPN VPN is also called a virtu
ual private Network it is a connection
between a VPN server and a VPN client so
it basically creates a encrypted tunnel
between the client and the VPN server
which is then utilized to secure the
connections that you're making with the
internet so as you can see in the
diagram the user has a VPN client
installed on the machine the VPN client
then creates an encrypted tunnel to the
VPN
server and through this tunnel encrypted
data is trans transmitted which can then
be processed by the VPN server uh sent
to the internet information can received
can be received back by the VPN server
the VPN server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to Eaves
drop on the communication mechanism they
will not be able to do so because of the
encrypted Tel it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunnel the it is possible but
it is very difficult to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing now before we go into
advantages of distributed processing we
first have to understand what is
distributed processing so it is a term
which describes various computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an
application here multiple computers
across different locations share the
same processor the advantages of
Distributing processes are as follows
but before we go into the advantages
distributed computing is basically
basically where multiple machines will
pull their resources together to run a
singular application so an application
that has multiple resources and can
scale up and scale down as and when
required the advantages are that it can
be very uh very useful in data recovery
for example raid where you're striping
data on various hard disks it is
reliable it is cheaper lower cost can be
achieved and it is easy to expand
because of the scalability factor that
we just talked about if there is loss of
data in one computer it can then be
recovered by another interconnected
computer and one of the examples would
be blockchain in today's world right
what is blockchain that this data is uh
created live and stored on a connection
of computer so if one of the computers
goes offline the other computers in that
network will still have that data and
the the blockchain will still function
without any issues the second point a
glitch in one machine does not affect
the processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost-effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe machines so instead of having
a server bank I can have multiple
machines connect interconnected together
and they can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing
mechanism depending on the amount of
data processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is
tcpip tcpip or transmission control
protocol over Internet Protocol is a set
of communication protocols that are used
to interconnect networking devices on
the internet this protocol defines how
data should be transmitted over the
Internet by providing endtoend
Communications so essentially if you
want networking to be established on
your machine you will need TCP IP
without TCP IP there will be no work
groups there will be no domains basic
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss tcpip is a software that once
installed on your machine will then
interact with the hardware which is your
network interface cards and then your
switches wires cables and all those
through protocols that have been already
pre-configured in it so within the tcpip
suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer and each and every protocol
that works on each and every layer will
be predefined and pre-configured to work
in a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you're talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient so the TCP IP model is the
compressed version of The OSI model the
seven layers will get converted into
four layers the network access layer
internet layer transport layer and
application layer going on to question
eight what do you mean by ip config and
if config both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine so ip
config is known as the Internet Protocol
configuration this is a command that is
used on the command line interface of
Microsoft Windows to view all the
adapters and the configuration of each
and every adapters for their network
interfaces so as you can see on the
right hand side in the command prompt
screen if uh once you type in the IP
config command on the C prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there so you can see
wireless land adapter local area
connection the media is disconnected it
doesn't exist at the bottom you'll see
the Wi-Fi connection wireless landan
adapter and it can give you the IP
version 6 IP address IP version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the machine to know on what
network it is on what what is the
default gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well if config is the same
thing on a Linux Mac or Unix operating
system so the command will also give you
the list of interfaces and the
configuration of each and every
interface it is used to configure
control the TCP iip network interface
parameter from the command line
interface it allows you to see the IP
address of these network interfaces so
here you can see uh
the wlp1
19s the IP address being 192 168
43215 subnet mask being
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being
43255 question n what is the difference
between a domain and a work group this
can be a very interesting question and
can can be a very lengthy question at
the same time a work group is nothing
but a decentralized network where you
have interconnected multiple machines
together and each machine acts in its
own individual capacity thinks of itself
as a server right so a decentralized
network you every user manages the
resources individually on their PC so
local users on their own PCS managing uh
the network shares what can be shared
from that particular machine what data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth it is good if you got a small
network uh a few machines alog together
uh and you want them to interact with
minimal management effort right so each
computer each user will decide what they
want to allow other users to see on that
particular Network and all of them would
be connected over a land a local area
network either a wireless or a wired one
so if you look at your home Wi-Fi right
now that is one of the best examples of
having a a work group The Domain on the
other hand is a centralized Network
model so in a corporate environment
whenever you go there and you got a
domain based username and password which
when entered onto a particular machine
gives you access to the entire network
or whatever applications and whatever
resources have been allocated to you
that is where the domain comes in so it
it also uses a single sign on mechanism
for all the resources that are that are
to be made Available to You whereas in a
work group you're a local user only
meant for that particular computer right
so coming back to the domain it is an
administrator who's going to manage the
entire domain and all of the resources
connected to the domain the resources
could be switches routers servers data
stores applications web servers Mail
Exchange servers and so on so forth so
all of these are administered by an
administrator through the domain it is
the most reliable and the optimum
solution for a large Network where
multiple users are going to interconnect
and share that data among amongst each
others right the computer can be
connected to any network that means you
can be on the internet and through the
internet using a VPN you can connect to
your corporate Network authenticate in
and get access to whatever resources you
are allowed to access whereas in a work
group you have to be a part of that
Network to access that particular
network if you change your location you
go and connect to another Wi-Fi you will
lose access to your previous Wi-Fi then
the last question for the networking uh
section what is data encapsulation in
networking data encapsulation refers to
the process of adding headers and
trailers to the data the data link layer
binds each packet into a frame that
contains the hardware address of the
source and the destination computer so
in this example when you're talking
about data encapsulation we have talked
about how data that has been created by
the application layer would have a
header and a trailer that will give the
various informations of where that data
needs to be sent so the hardware address
which is the MAC address comes into the
picture and gets added to the header and
the IP addresses port numbers and all of
those things would then be added to this
uh trailers as well so that the data can
be then routed to the intended recipient
of that particular
communication with this we end the first
10 questions in networking and in this
video we are going to look at software
and programming so we're going to look
at the first 10 questions first question
being how do you keep a computer secure
now this is going to be a very generic
question so you want to put your best
foot forward and you want to identify
the most common methodologies on how you
can keep a computer secure so when we
talk about computers the first thing
that you want to talk about is
authentication mechanisms where you want
multiactor authentication or two-way
authentication to ensure that your
accounts are kept secured now if you
look at using passwords depending on how
passwords are being stored by the
application uh password attacks can be
possible either a Brute Force attack or
a dictionary base attack uh or even
password guessing attacks are possible
to mitigate those kind of attacks you we
need multiactor
authentication to ensure that accounts
are kep secure now even if we are using
multiactor authentication we also want
to look at secure passwords which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as uh meet has at
least one lowercase one uppercase
character has numerics and special
characters and his randomize is not
based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user third keep regular
updates which means that there will be
patches that will be released for the
application for the software that you're
utilizing download the patches install
them on a regular basis to ensure that
you are secured against the most recent
attacks that have been
identified install a good
antivirus could be a Internet Security
Suite which will have an antivirus
intrusion detection system a firewall uh
and will help you protect yourself
against Ransom Wares malwares and any
script based attacks also have a
specialized firewall on your system
could be a host based firewall or a
network based firewall to ensure that uh
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices have anti
fishing softwares installed as well to
ensure that you are not getting any spam
mails even if you do you're able to
identify that and not fall pre or victim
to those spam mails fishing attacks are
generic where they are directed towards
individuals uh and they pray on the
cility of that particular individual so
our Nigerian frauds or the lotteries
that we in on a regular basis of
hundreds of million dollars uh those
messages the emails that we received
they are all fishing emails where uh
they're basically prone to victimize the
user and then Rob them of money or
install some
malware or do some other malicious
activity if you want to enhance
encryption about data that you have
stored on your devices or on your or
that is accessed by your software or
being transmitted by your software use
encryption encrypt your data whether it
is at rest whether it is in motion or
whether it is at use thus reducing data
leakage and data loss uh possibilities
and finally and the foremost secure your
DNS DNS is the domain name server which
is utilized
by computers to resolve domain names to
IP addresses
if a DNS poisoning attack is possible
where your DNS settings have been
modified by an attacker and you're
redirected to a malicious DNS server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload also you don't want people
to know your DNS servers and the queries
that you're making so you want to use
secure DNS or uh DNS over https to
encrypt your DNS queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps your devices your computers
your applications are going to be as
secure as possible the next question
discuss security related aspects between
cc++ and Java now this is an open-ended
question it depends on which level
you're giving an interview on but you're
looking at it from a fresher perspective
or a less experienced perspective and
thus these are some of the aspects that
we want to look at and the comparisons
between cc++ and Java so the five
aspects that we're looking at are
Pointers code translations storage
allocation
inheritance and overall Security based
on cc++ and Java so when we say pointers
we are looking at how we going to uh uh
we using pointers and uh stacks and
heaps to point to functions and how we
exit those functions and how those
functions are then recalled into the
next function so C supports pointers it
is most secure C++ also supports Point
pointers but it is a little bit less
secure than C Java it is not supported
direct access is given to memory
allocation and thus it is the least
secure as far as pointers are concerned
when we look at code
translations C is able to compile but it
is not secure same with cc++ but in Java
it is an interpreted language and it is
abstracted and secured in storage
allocation in C we use maloc and uh cck
memory allocation uh Which is less
secure because it does not have internal
checks on verifying what memory is
allocated and the user input that is
being compiled or that is being input to
that memory right thus this can allow
buffer overflow errors uh to creep in
because of the uh non-verification of
the input data so it is the least secure
in cc++ it uses new and delete options
and is comparatively secure but Java
uses a garbage collector and does is the
most secure as far as storage allocation
is
concerned when we talk about
inheritance the most secure is
cc++ C has no inheritance so it's not
secure in C++ it is supported th it is
the most secure whereas in Java there is
multi- inheritance that is not supported
and does is comparatively secure overall
the most secure out of all these based
on these five aspects is
Java the least secure is C and the
midlevel is C++ moving on to question 13
what are the different sources of
malware now malware stands for malicious
software right malware is basically a
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload of errosion
virus pyware key logger or some
malicious software that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device so the question here
is what are the different sources of
malware we want to identify the most
common sources through which malw infect
end user devices in today's world and we
can start with popup ads so most of the
websites if you're visiting unrusted
sites if you're being redirected to
sites that you don't know about there
will be a lot of popups coming your way
where it says you're the one millionth
visitor to this site please click here
to download your gift or it will say say
uh congratulations on winning a
particular product for visiting this
page and so on so forth there are some
instances where you can see a banner
which is flashing at you on top of the
page and says that there are eight uh
infections that have been identified on
your computer click here to download an
antivirus to clean the infections so all
of these
popups are there as a social engineering
attack as a fishing attack to make
gullible people click on those links and
download those map
now the software that is posing as a
security software itself can be a
malicious software which is going to
install a Trojan or a virus or a bot on
your machine compromising the security
of that machine the second is removable
media USBS and humans have a fascination
with USB so if you find a USB lying
around it's a free USB you get excited
about it and you want to take it home
you want to plug it into a machine and
see what's on the USB worst case
scenario you format it and you got a
free USB to utilize higher the capacity
the better but that is one of the most
easiest way people use malwares to uh to
be deployed on unsuspecting users if
there is a USB lying around why would
why would somebody want to forget a USB
it's most likely planted over there as a
social engineering attack so that a
gullible person is going to pick it up
plug it into their device if the device
is not secured enough it is going to
install the malware
right uh then documents and executable
files this is where your viruses and uh
all those creps in so let's say you're
surfing on the internet you're looking
for a software uh and you find the
software on a particular website you do
not verify the trust wor of that site
and you just download and install that
software now that software could be
malware as well thus if you're surfing
on the internet you're downloading files
from different locations you have to
research the website you have to
research the source to ensure that it is
trustworthy and only then are you going
to download and execute those files does
internet downloads as well and when we
say internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrent uh
we go to uh dark the dark web or the
Deep Web and we are searching for other
softwares especially uh those who are
researching security right we always
want we always on the lookout of new
softwares and we're always on those
forums which may not be so much
trustworthy and we just download those
files and start installing them that is
a very bad scenario right so you have to
be very careful what you're downloading
from the internet your antiviruses your
uh anti fishing uh mechanisms your
threat intelligence mechanisms uh have
those uh mechanisms installed and you
want to verify where your downloads are
coming from then your network
connections if it is a P2P connection it
is a local area network connection or a
metropolitan area network you have to
verify whom which devices are connected
to your machines and you have to
validate those connections before you
want to trust those devices uh and
before you connect to them if you are on
a public Wi-Fi you probably don't want
to connect to a public Wi-Fi in the
first
place then comes email
attachments there are so many
attachments that come across in today's
world most of them in a zip format or a
RAR format uh some of them come as
document files where there are macros
hidden within them macros are scripts
that are recognized by Microsoft Office
files right and then finally there are
these malicious advertisements that we
find online right uh Let It Be Facebook
let it be WhatsApp let it be uh any
social media platform that you go or
even your search engines their job is to
display ads their job is not to verify
whether the ad is legit or not it is for
us as consumers to be careful and
validate that ad and verify whether it
is a genuine ad ad or not so just don't
start clicking on uh any of the ad
trusting uh the platform that you are on
be uh be sure that you are investigating
that ad so these are the most common
sources of malware and the end
user will always get infected by one of
these mechanisms moving on to question
14 how does email work now this is a
very uh can be a complex question uh but
we have to keep it as simple as possible
and we have to identify that there are
uh two
servers both of them either using SMTP
where which is the simple message
transfer protocol where uh in this
scenario John wants to send an email
thus they've got an email client
installed on their machine which is
connected to the mail Exchange Server
which has a DNS server which Maps the
routing and uh which maps The Exchange
Server and
inboxes so when John composes that
message and clicks on send John should
be connected to a Mail Exchange Server
where the email is sent through that
particular person's inbox so John's
inbox will then uh be validated and that
email will then be sent through the DNS
server uh through the internet and will
be received by the recipient mail server
so at this point in time John also
requires the recipient's email address
so in this case this is Jack so Jack
something.com would be uh the email
address so when John is composing uh the
two field will have Jack's email address
the from field will have John's email
address the subject field will have uh
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself and then when uh John
clicks on send it will go to their
Exchange Server The Exchange Server will
then validate the Inbox and identify
where that inbox is located for Jack and
then through the internet it will be
sent to the uh to the mail server of
Jack the mail server will then identify
the proper inbox that that that email
needs to be sent to and it will store
that email in that particular inbox when
Jack opens their computer and accesses
their inbox this email from John will be
already waiting for them and they can
respond to it the same way John had send
that email if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know
more moving on to question 15 what are
the types of threats a company can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at softwares you're
looking at operating systems and the
company comes and asks you uh what are
the threats that are most likely that a
company will face so on a broader scale
the threats that a company will always
face would be classified as natural
threats man-made threats technical
threats and a supply system threat so a
natural threat would be an act of God
which is outside the control of human
beings could be storms or any natural
occurrences like volcanoes uh
thunderstorms flooding earthquakes fire
and so on so forth so anything that is
natural so it depends on the geographic
location that you're in and what kind of
climate that area faces and you need to
identify the immediate threats and
prepare for them so if it is flooding
that you're looking at uh and you want
to look at an office uh and the
possibility of the office getting
flooded is real you probably want to uh
take office at a higher
floor so that the threat of flooding is
minimized for fire we always have a fire
drill where we practice our fire
mechanism so that we can evacuate all
humans as soon as possible and then
worry about the technicalities of it
under any circumstances under under any
threats humans will always have the
first priority and then everything else
comes in man-made threats are where man
themselves are a problem so strikes
lockouts hackers theft uh War rioting
all of those are man-made threats uh
which we ourselves cannot be in control
of but we need to plan for them and we
need to have uh a business continuity
plan or a disaster recovery plan for any
of these threats that have been
identified then come the technical
threats technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that uh that come with the applications
that we have or a hardware failure where
a server crashes a hard disk crashes
maybe uh the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working Ram gets
corrupted uh any of the technical
aspects stopping uh stop functioning
does creating a break in the business
can come under technical right so uh
anything to do with
computers let's say a server failing or
uh patch that is not installed on a
particular software those would come
under technical threats and then the
supply system the supply system are your
environmental threats which dep depend
on your supply chain fa uh failures what
is the supply chain for office to
function there are a lot of dependencies
that office goes through right there are
a lot of other vendors that suppose that
support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function for first and foremost
electricity without electricity nothing
is going to be powered on and you're not
going to be able to function so if there
is a electricity service provider and if
there's an electric outage that's that
comes under Supply system so that's a
supply chain failure where the vendor
that provides electricity to you has
failed in providing that particular
service and now now you need a business
continuity or a disaster recovery plan
so you probably have an inverter or you
already have a power generator plant
that is going to generate your own power
and Supply to your system right there
could be short circuits because of
fluctuation in the electricity uh maybe
the internet service provider fails and
your internet caches so you have a
backup line for the internet from a
different vendor right and so on so
forth maybe your Hardware vendors who
are supplying you servers desktops
laptops and whatnot they fail because
they they are facing a strike or they go
bankrupt and suddenly you can no longer
purchase Hardware from your vendor
because they no longer are in business
so that's a supply chain failure so any
of these Systems Failing would also come
under threats so under a broad category
these are the first four threats that
you need to identify and then you can
elaborate by providing more scenarios
based on the experiences that you have
had towards each and every of these
threats so a natural threat where you
may have had experience where there
would have been let's say a flooding uh
or any natural disaster which caused a
problem for the continuity of your
particular business so identify each and
every example for each of these threats
and provide that as an example in the
interview what is blackbox and white box
testing so when you are testing a
software or you're testing your
infrastructure there are two different
tests that you can conduct the first one
is a black box the second one is a white
box in a blackbox test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so let's say you're a ethical hacker and
you have been awarded a contract by an
organization to test their current
application that they have developed now
they're not going to give you any
information they're not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an IP address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to fire in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
lead to an security incident so without
any knowledge zero knowledge of the it
infrastructure or the source code that's
a blackbox attack or a blackbox test a
white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the it
infrastructure or the source code is
shared so the ethical hacker has
complete knowledge and based on the
knowledge they going to test out the
system to see if there are any flaws
that they can identify right so why
would these two audits be important
because the first one a blackbox audit
emulates the attack of a Outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an Insider so a
disgruntled employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights to make uh
unvalidated profits right so somebody
who's corrupt who has been bribed who
wants to sell out company Secrets based
uh so they're going to try to find out
visabilities try to steal data and try
to sell it on the uh gray market right
so a white box would emulate a internal
attack a blackbox would emulate an
external attack moving on to question 17
what is use case testing now use case
testing is a functional test and it is
also a blackbox test
right what is a functional test it tests
the functionality of a particular
software once it has been
created why is it a blackbox test
because the user doesn't know what the
functionality is they just want to find
out each and every scenario and try to
see what that scenario generates as a
response they are not sure whether that
is the appropriate response that should
be generated or not they're just trying
to find out the response that is going
to be generated after they fire off a
query so thisch technique is used by
testers to get the test scenarios to
exercise the whole system from start to
finish so let's say it's a login
mechanism for an application right now a
user at this point in time the tester
since it's a blackbox testing will know
that it is a login mechanism they will
not know the details of what logging
mechanisms are being utilized so they
wouldn't know whether uh input
validation is done they wouldn't know
where the output encoding is done they
wouldn't know how the CGI calls are
being made they will not know how the uh
queries are handled at the server side
and how the database is going to treat
that particular query so they have no
idea where the SQL injection attacks are
possible and so on so forth so for them
with whatever input they're going to try
to insert for that login mechanism
that's a functional blackbox test the
functionality mean whether the login
mechanism works and based on the type of
inputs that they're going to put in
whether it creates an unwarranted output
whether they can bypass the mechanism or
they can
hack into the system because of some of
the flaws that were left behind right
another example here is a software made
for users to use for documentation the
testers will test all the cases that the
user can do so can the user view a
document can they add new documents can
they edit documents and can they delete
documents so this
functionality will depend upon the
access controls that have been granted
to a particular user so for this
particular user the tester at this point
in time they would not know whether they
are an administrative user or they are a
regular user they'll just try to do all
of these and then write the responses
saying I was able to view I was able to
add I was able to edit and I was able to
delete now the result will be then sent
to a manager the manager will look at
the results and then based on the actual
access controls that were supposed to be
there for this particular user then
we'll try to identify whether this is an
acceptable case or whether there were
any flaws within this case moving on to
question
18 what is static and dynamic testing
now this is again in application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now software
development life cycles there are
multiple of those what are these life
cycles there are different stages in
which a application is uh
created and provided to the customer so
your first stage would be determining
the scope of the application determining
the hardware requirements for that
application then creating a flowchart
for that application a functional chart
for that application and then maybe
start coding then an architect comes in
test the code verifies the code then the
testing phase comes in then the security
testing phase comes in and then the user
acceptance testing comes in but in every
stage at the very earliest of All Stage
a static test will always be started to
see whatever code has been developed
whatever uh scope has been developed
whether that scope is going to be
correct or not this will include
walkthroughs and code review what is a
walk walk through a walkth through is
going through documents that have been
generated and trying to find faults in
the documented Journey that has been
that has been created so far so let's
say somebody has created a workflow or a
flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed so a walk
through would be where uh all these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that and then Rectify
them if there is any code that has
already been written this code will be
reviewed manually and any flaws within
that code would then be identified
static testing will always be 100%
accurate in a very short amount of time
because it is immediate uh you have
created it and then the expert is going
to test it to see whether everything is
fine or not right it is all about
prevention mechanism so since you're
doing it at the Inception itself if you
find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from creeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas Dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application everything is ready now you
want to do Dynamic testing includes
functional and non-functional testing
functional testing is where the
application itself is being tested the
functions to see that all the parameters
that are given to the application are
functioning properly non-functional
testing would be where security
parameters uh administrative parameters
all of them are being verified right
this is where your test case scenarios
come in and uh you're going to test each
and every scenario by generating inputs
and analyzing the output that the
application is going to give you Dynamic
testing is all about cure so here you're
going to identify vulnerabilities report
them to the management and the
management is then going to figure out a
way of patching those vulnerabilities so
that they can be mitigated moving on to
the next question what are the test
levels in software testing so as far as
software testing is concerned there are
four test levels module testing
integration testing system testing and
the final one is acceptance testing so
in the testing phase of your development
life cycle the first thing is a module
test you're going to check your routines
your sub routines your subprograms
procedures that have been written in a
program so all your functions all your
uh mechanisms for that application are
going to be tested when you going to
integration testing the software may
have been integrated with multiple
softwares there may be different API
calls coming in maybe a third party
software on which you're uh depending
upon to supply for information so all of
these integration of various softwares
various apis are tested to ensure that
they're functioning properly and there
are no flaws errors or mistakes left
behind in the integration of all of
these
softwares then the system testing is
where the entire system so including the
hardware including the software right it
starts from the installation so now the
software is complete we know which
Hardware we are going to support for it
we start by installing the software and
see whether the installation is going to
be completed properly if there are any
errors in the installation process
itself then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application the uh write speeds the read
speeds on the hard disk uh the
transaction speeds that the application
is capable of the network dependencies
that the application may have all of
those would come under system testing
and then the acceptance testing which is
basically a quality assurance exercise
that the application meets the client's
requirements so the client in the first
stage would have given the scope of what
needs to be achieved in the acceptance
testing you're verifying that that scope
has been met and the client requirements
have been met and you can assure the
client about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application coming to the last question
in this uh software programs what are
the valuable steps to resolve issues
while testing so in the previous
scenarios where we have started testing
now if you find out a when you execute a
particular use case and then you find
out a flaw what would be the steps that
you would utilize to address those
particular flaws in those tests the
first step will always be record then
you're going to report it and then
you're going to introduce a Control
process for it so when you say record
you're going to create logs and you're
going to try to resolve all the problems
that have happened now when you say
resolve you're not going to recode the
application but you're going to test the
system again and again to ensure that
whatever is being recorded is
accurate and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps all of those
that have been generated due to this
particular log or due to this particular
error are being captured so that they
can be reported to the higher level
managers so the next step is once you
have uh once you have accumulated all
these logs and Records you're going to
report them to the higher level managers
who are then going to investigate it and
go back to the developers trying to
figure out the best way to mitigate
those particular flaws so the report
writing needs also also needs to be
accurate uh it needs to be to the point
uh it needs to detail what the problem
was it will document all the steps that
there were that you took all the inputs
that you put in and it will also record
all the errors and it will also record
called all the mechanisms that were
utilized and the uh errors that were
generated and that report will be given
to the higher level managers who can
then forward it to the developers who
based on those reports can start their
troubleshooting and then the control
mechanism comes in you're going to uh
Define the issue management process so
this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you're doing a
test you're recording whatever is
happening you're creating a report out
of it you're sending it to the
management the management will then take
those those reports study them take it
to the developers the developers will
test based on their criterias they might
interact with the testers at that point
in time to identify particular flaws and
then they might want to record that
application or develop a patch which
once installed will mitigate that
particular flaw and then it can come
back to the testing phase again where
you can repeat those tests and validate
that the flaw is no longer existent so
these are the three steps that would be
uh U ized for testing
purposes and that brings us to the first
10 questions on the software platform in
the next video we'll be looking at
operating systems and applications the
first question is on virtual memory what
exactly is virtual memory for a computer
we have two types of memory we first is
the primary memory which is your random
access memory which is also known as a
volatile memory and the secondary memory
is your hard disk where your data is
stored permanently but for a computer
when it it has let's say a 4GB memory or
a ram as in this scenario on your screen
it is going to replicate that and is
going to create another 4GB of virtual
memory on the hard disk and it is going
to use it in tandem along with the
ram so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize the 4GB of
the virtual memory that is created on
the hard disk and it is going to swap
data from the ram to the hard disk this
can also be known as a page file or a
swap file the next question is what are
different scheduling algorithms now the
context for this question is you're
talking about a Prof a processor and
you're talking about how processes are
going to be fed to the processor and how
the processor is going to treat these
processes so the first is first come
first serve so the process which
requests the CPU first gets the CPU
allocation first now whenever there are
processes that are being run by
different applications they make request
for some CPU typ now in first come first
serve the first service or the first
process that is going to request some
processing time will get that much
allocated to them they will run through
the process first and then the next and
the next and so on so
forth the second one is the shortest job
first this is the process where the
shortest execution time for that process
is calculated and that process is
selected first for the
CPU then there is priority scheduling
this schedulers selects the task to work
as per priority so there would be some
tasks that are marked with high priority
some would be normal and some would be
low So based on this high normal or low
priority uh all the processes will be
classified higher priority will be dealt
with uh first then the normal and then
the least
priority the fourth option is multiple
level cues where processes are assigned
to a que based on the specific property
like process priority the size of memory
Etc so it will be classified based on
the attributes given to that particular
process and uh multiple cues will be
created and then based on the attributes
the processes will be uh processed by
the
CPU then shortest remaining time the
process will be allocated to the task
Which is closest to its completion so or
you look at it this way the process that
will take the least time to complete its
processing would be chosen
first and then the Round Rob method
where each process comes in turn gets an
equal share of time so if there are 10
processes each process will be allocated
a certain amount of time after which the
next process will be processed and so on
so forth and it will continue in a round
robin fashion till all the processes get
executed so in short six different
scheduling algorithms depending on how
you uh how the operating system deals
with
it the next question is what are the
steps involved in hacking a server or a
network so this is more of a ethical
hacking question you're looking at
devices and for uh and the interviewer
asks you uh what kind of steps are
involved what are the activities that
you would do in hacking a server or a
network now there are no specific steps
that you would Define because every hack
is going to be unique but it has a hack
can be classified in five different
steps which are quite generic right so
the first step will always always be the
recognizance step also known as
information gathering phase also known
as foot printing or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase the attacker gathers
all the evidence all the information
that is possible about the targets that
they want to attack so here you're
trying to get to know the victim so you
can launch specific attacks towards them
you want to identify what operating
system they're utilizing what IP
addresses Mac addresses the versions of
the operating systems and applications
the patch levels find out
vulnerabilities find out whatever
information is possible find out the
information about the uh person who's
using those computers so you can launch
social engineering attacks and so on so
forth so the first step is all about
gathering enough information based on
which you can launch further attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase this is more of a
technical phase so you have uh in the
first step you have got your IP
addresses domain names maybe even
Network maps and you have identified
which devices are available now in the
scanning phase you're going to identify
live
devices and then you're going to scan
them for open ports processes protocols
Services you're going to identify
vulnerabilities you're going to
enumerate them to identify more
information from them thus at this point
in time you will have identified a
certain set of vulnerabilities or a
certain set of security Loop holes that
you can
misuse once you have identified those
you're going to the next step which is
the gaining access St in this you're
actually going to execute your attacks
based on the V abilities that you have
found and you're either going to gain
access to that particular system by
installing aosion or destroy the system
by installing a virus or install a
spyware or a key logger whatever you
wanted to achieve so in the gaining
access phase you would have based on the
knowledge you have G in the first and
the second phase you're going to launch
your attacks and you're going to try to
gain access to that particular
device then the next step is where
you're going to maintain that access now
that you have hacked into that device it
is not necessary that you will always be
able to get access to that device uh
suppose you have cracked the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password after a few days
your attack is worthless so what you're
going to do here is you're going to
maintain your access so this is where it
is assumed that you want repeated access
to that device and thus you're going to
install a key logger or a Trojan or some
mechanism which will still allow you to
get access to that device without the
knowledge or the authorization of that
particular user and finally the last
step is where you're going to cover Your
Tracks so whatever activity that you
have done so far will have created logs
and will have created information based
on which the victim will come to know
that they have been compromised and may
be able to trace that activity back to
you so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked and to prevent them to discover
who has hacked them you want to cover
your tracks by deleting logs and any
references that point to that particular
activity you're going to hide the files
that you have created so you have
installed a droan or a key logger these
will create files and directories you're
going to hide them so that they are not
discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you're
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that that to
conceal the actual attack and preventing
the user from realizing that they have
been compromised so these are the five
steps that will be involved in hacking a
server Network application or any
Computing device you'll come across the
next question refers to what are the
various sniffing tools now this is a
network based attack where you're trying
to capture data package that that are
being transmitted over the network and
then you're going to analyze them to see
if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
Bank details or anything of that sort
now these tools will also depend on
which operating system you utilizing for
example MSN sniffer would work on
Microsoft uh operating systems eer cab
would be based on Linex and so on so
forth so on the screen you'll see six
different sniffing tools that work on
different operating systems wire shark
is uh something that is common both on
Windows and
Linux uh it is used to analyze Network
in detail because it is the defacto tool
that you will come across in most of
your ethical hacking trainings in most
of your organizations when they want to
do uh data
captures now data capturing or packet
capturing is not only done by hackers to
gather more information but is also a
known troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so the first tool you see on the
screen is wire shark like we stated is
is available for Windows Linux uh as
well then there is TCP dump which uh
again has the same capability of wire
shock but is a command line version
whereas wi shock also has a GUI a
graphical user interface TCP dump is
available online next MSN sniffer it's a
very old tool uh when we had MSN
Messengers uh MSN Messenger is no longer
there but Microsoft does or did have a
Microsoft message analyzer tool
uh which they have stopped development
since 2015 uh but that's another tool
that is specific for Microsoft operating
systems from Microsoft that can be
installed to gather more information
then you got eer cap which is a tool to
launch man inth the midle attacks data
capturing and is is essentially a Linux
command line based tool then D sniff is
another password and network capturing
tool which can help you capture data
packets prominently a Linux uh tool same
with
eate this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to uh capture data data
traffics and map protocols and identify
which IP addresses have been
communicating with what essentially all
of the tools have similar functionality
except that uh some have additional
functionality like launching man in the
middle attacks or uh capturing or having
specific filters that will help you
identify and troubleshoot some network
issues that you may be facing moving on
to the next question what is is an
operating system now this is a very
difficult question to answer because uh
we normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right uh we try to describe what Windows
does or what Linux does or what Mac OS
does and then we trying to figure out
what an operating system is in the first
place but an operating system
essentially as the slide says is a
software program that provides a
platform for computer hardware to
communicate and operate with the
computer software so but is basically an
enabler for human interaction with the
hardware that you have if you take the
operating system out of the question
it's just some Hardware which cannot
interact with you but essentially when
you have operating system like Microsoft
Windows or Linux or Mac you're ENT
essentially installing an instruction
set on that particular device which will
allow you to
interact and manipulate the hardware to
do whatever you want that Hardware to do
right essentially uh when we talk about
uh drivers for your various devices like
a driver for your Lan card or for your
sound card or for your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards uh
for functionality right it allows us
input and output
functions uh for example the basic
example you open up Microsoft Office
Products like Microsoft world or Excel
and you get a GUI on the screen uh which
you can interact with you got a key
keboard and you typee on that keyboard
and the computer knows what you're
typing and reflects those actions on the
screen by showcasing it on that
particular uh Excel file or a word file
so how does the computer know what to do
or what you're exactly intending to do
at this point in time it is all the
operating system that is providing you
all these Services analyzing what your
inputs are and then based uh on the
programming it is going to execute that
and show it to you on the screen right
some of the most common commonly used
operating system or Microsoft Windows
you have them in desktop as well as
server variants Unix Linux again Linux
has desktop and uh servers You Got U 2
in Linux red hat and so on so forth and
then you got Mac OS uh for uh Apple
related components the next question
what is the difference between micro
kernel and macro kernel now the first
thing we need to know is what is a
kernel kernel is
the heart of the operating system that
allows that input and output to happen
it allows those drivers to be set up so
that the hardware can interact with the
software and we can then instruct the uh
software and the hardware both to
function in a particular manner so there
are two types of kernels micro kernels
and a macro kernel micro kernel is
something that we normally use micr
kernels are for uh operating systems
that use processes directly handled by
the processor the micro kernel is very
small in size uh micr kernel is large
because it basically is the entire image
of the operating system the execution
for a micr kernel is slow the micr
kernel is going to be faster because it
is more evolved there's a lot of
programming involved extendability
micr kernels are easy to extend micro
macr kernels are hard to extend as far
as security is concerned if a macr
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire operating system is
going to crash but in case of a micr
kernel it is only that particular
process that is going to get ected micr
kernel there is a lot of coding
involved macr kernel less coding is
involved examples of micr kernels would
be Symbian OSS most popularly used on
yeru phones nokas if you remember those
uh QX and so on so forth macr kernels
your Linux or BSD operating systems
essentially use macr kernels next
question what are the different types of
operating systems so as you can see on
the screen five types of operating
systems batched OS distributed operating
systems time sharing multi-program and
real time what are batched operating
systems the computer operator places the
jobs coming from input devices into
batches so consider this not from a
desktop perspective but from a server
perspective where these devices are used
by organizations to compute and to
crunch some processes that is going to
make some business sense out of it so
when there are multiple processes coming
in multiple jobs that are going to be
scheduled a batched OS is going to place
these jobs in batches and they're going
to Crunch those based on the uh inputs
that have been given by these operators
distributed OSS where there are multiple
computers which are interconnected and
are communicating through networks so in
a corporate environment you don't use
one single computer to do everything you
got a Data Center and the data center
will have a cluster of servers where
they're going to share some resources to
Crunch one particular task right so
that's where your distributed OSS come
into the picture then you have time
sharing OSS where you're renting some
time so time sharing OS minimizes the
response time example in today's world
Cloud right uh you go onto the cloud you
have a virtual service over there uh you
schedule something you schedule a job
over there it is uh it is executed and
for that time being that operating
system Services your particular request
and provides you that particular job
any application that you see online that
is executed for example Facebook uh from
a consumer's perspective uh could be a
time shared
experience then multiprogrammed OS the
operating system uses CPU sheding to
separate jobs so you're scheduling the
CPU to complete certain jobs in this
particular Manner and in realtime OS the
operating system gives maximum time to
critical operations so it identifies uh
the priority of of these operations it
knows the high priority items the medium
low priority items and based on that it
is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done moving
on to the next question what is the
difference between logical address space
and physical address space now when
you're looking at address spaces this is
where applications come into the picture
and when you execute an application it
is going to create a particular address
in the memory where it is going to
create a buffer to store its own
information so that it can be provided
to the processor processed and then can
be returned back to the application as
an output right so as far as definitions
are concerned a logical address is
generated during running of an
application or a program a physical
address is a physical address or a
physical location on the memory module
itself right visibility you can view a
logical address because it is programmed
into a computer so if I'm looking at uh
C C C++ and I'm using maloc or memory
allocation uh that's where the logical
address is going to be created where a
buffer is going to be created for that
program and whatever the user input is
going to be it's going to be stored in
that buffer but whereas physical address
is concerned this logical address will
be created on a physical store or a
physical memory module which will have
its own addressing mechanism thus you
you can see the memory module but you
cannot see the specific address on that
particular memory module but as far as a
uh a logical address is concerned while
you're programming or you're debugging
the application it will show you the
logical address that has been created
the start point and the end point of The
Logical address that has been created
for that particular program it it can be
shown in a debugging
environment right address space logical
and physical address is physical like
this case it's the memory module itself
you can access only the physical address
on that particular memory because
logical addresses can be viewed but you
cannot access them physically uh
generation uh The Logical addresses are
generated by the CPU uh during the
processing time whereas physical
addresses are generated or computed by
the memory management unit or the mmu
that you have on your
computers and as far as logical
addresses they will always they are
variable whereas the physical address is
always going to be constant looking at
the next question what is the difference
between logical address space and
physical address space so moving on from
the previous question to this The
Logical address is a address created by
the CPU for the processes that need to
be addressed and that need to be stored
as a buffer in the uh physical memory
whereas the physical memory itself is
going to be a address that is going to
be there on the physical part of that
memory which is uh which is going to be
assigned to it by the mmu then the next
question discusses uh shells so what
shells are used in Linux now what is a
shell Shell Shell is the command line
interface that we utilize on a Linux
machine so the terminal window as we
call it is a shell and there are
different variations of a shell based on
what lineu operating systems you're
using the desktop operating systems that
you use uh or the server operating
systems in real in today's world that
you're going to use normally will always
have a bash shell which is the first
shell that you see on the screen known
as a bone again shell it is a default
for Linux distribution so as as far as
end consumers regular consumers are
concerned it is always going to be a
bash shell a bone again shell that
you're going to utilize for scripting
and to execute regular commands but when
it comes to high level programming or it
uh comes to specialization tasks then
you got the rest of these uh shells that
you can utilize for example the ksh
known as a con shell is used for high
level programming which supports
associative arrs and built-in operations
the CSH or the C shell
uh has different functionality like
spelling Corrections and job controls
the zsh or the Z shell provides unique
features like file generation startup
files and fish friendly interactive
shell which provides features like Auto
suggestions and configuration so all of
these have different functionalities
depending on what uh usage that you have
for that particular shell the most
common shell like I stated is the bash
shell that you'll always come across in
your desktop Linux operating systems
then looking at the next question what
are the process States in Linux now what
is a process process is basically a
service that is running for a particular
application for that application to
function right uh this process is going
to direct user input to the processor
process it get that output back to the
application execute it and then show it
onto the graphical user interface for
the user so in Linux there are five
states for a process first is the ready
phace now in ready
in this state the process is created and
it is ready to run so it is waiting uh
it is waiting for input it's ready uh
the application is executed the running
is when the process is being executed
itself blocked or weight is when user
input is being looked upon so it's
waiting for user input so that it can do
the processing completed or terminated
it has completed its execution or was
terminated by the operating system for
some reason or the other so this is
where things have uh the process has
been completed and then last state state
is zombie where the process is
terminated but the process table still
holds the information or maybe it is
waiting for the kill request before it
gets terminated so these are the five
states for a Linux process to be in and
that brings us to the 10 questions in
the operating system and application
space in the next video we'll be looking
at 10 more questions on cyber attacks
interview questions based on cyber
attacks let's start off the first one
the first question is what is SQL
injection SQL stands for structured
query language which is a language that
is used by most of your databases or
your relational databases uh the the
variations of your database would be
myql Microsoft SQL Oracle
SQL you'll have IBM databases all of
these databases utilize the structured
query languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax ta so you'll have
to study most of these databases based
on which applications and which
databases you want to provide security
for but as the name suggests SQL
injection vulnerability or a structured
query language injection vulnerability
is where a user can maliciously inject a
SQL input or a SQL statement in a query
and send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it so this
varability is not specifically to the
database it uh the varability lies more
in the application and the coding of
that application so when the application
receives a query which it needs to be
forwarded to the SQL uh database we need
to configure at the application Level of
what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various aspects of how to
manage a SQL injection varability but
the basic flaw lies in the application
where uh invalidated input is accepted
and sent forward to the database where
the database might confuse it into an
executable statement and thus create a
response that was not warranted there
are various types of SQL injections as
shown on the screen inband SQL injection
where you can look at an error based or
a union based injection a blind SQL
injection where it is either Boolean
based or a Time based attack and then an
outof bound SQL injection this
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security where you want to encourage
secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is
mitigated then the next question is what
is spoofing now in spoofing you're
basically assuming the identity of
another person so here the attacker
pretends to be some other person or an
organization and sends you an email that
appears to be a legitimate email it
looks almost genuine it has been
constructed to replicate what a genuine
email would have been and it is very
difficult to spot a fake one there are
different ways to identify whether an
email is genuine or not but that's for a
different video moving on to the next
question what is a distributed denial of
service attack or a Dos attack now
generally a denial of service attack is
an attack where legitimate users are
prevented access to the resources that
they legitimately can access right so
for for example if it is a bandwidth
based attack the attacker consumes the
bandwidth of the network in such a way
that there is no more bandwidth left for
legitimate users to access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of uh traffic
to consume the bandwidth of a HTH server
thus the attacker will construct a
botnet and through that botnet they will
launch a distributed denal service
attack to the Target victim right so a
botnet uh there are two uh terms that we
want to look at over here the first term
is a bot and the second one being the
bot net itself bot is a software that
once installed on a victim's machine
allows the hacker to send remote
commands to that machine that will make
it do generate some
activity once we have enough machines uh
on which such Bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botnet so an attacker
would then instruct this entire botnet
to start generating data traffic to be T
to be sent to the targeted Network or to
the targeted server which will then bog
down the server thus crashing it and
preventing users from accessing that
particular resource the next question is
how to avoid ARP poisoning or ARP now
first let's understand what ARP is ARP
stands for address resolution protocol
which is a protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network once your
computer boots up it starts a discovery
process of identifying its neighbors so
if I'm in a particular subnet my machine
will proactively send out ARP request
and address resolution protocol to find
out which other machines are within the
same network and which are live once it
sends out a query a live machine will
respond to that query along with its Mac
address this information is then stored
in what is known as a ARP table or an
ARP table on the machine's cache so
whenever my machine now wants to send
out a packet to this particular machine
it will go to the ARP table it will
identify the IP address and the
associated Mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination uh IP and destination Mac
and send that packet across to the
switch the switch will then identify the
MAC address send the packet to the
relevant machine that is connected to
that particular switch now to confuse
the switch into sending it to a
different machine our poisoning attack
is created this attack is generally
launched to create a man in the middle
attack now to prevent this AR poisoning
from happening in the first place there
are three different aspects that we can
utilize first we can use packet
filtering which will fil filter out and
block packets that have the same Source
address data so you have identified some
malicious IP addresses and you want to
block out some IP addresses so you're
using a packet filter firewall where you
have instructed the firewall to filter
out certain
packets originating from particular
range of IP addresses this firewall and
this technique will then block those
kind of packets coming in second keeping
away from trust relationships
organizations will develop protocols
that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to keep
this protocol away from that once you
have created a trust
relationship uh these machines should
not be sending out ARP request to other
machines in the first place since uh the
trust relationship has has been defined
and these machines know whom to
communicate with such kind of protocols
should then be disabled or you can use
an ARP spoofing software so there are
some there are softwares out there that
will look for ARP spoofing and prevent
that from happening in the first place
so if somebody has sent a out a spoofed
ARP packet that packet will be picked up
by this software and it will be
mitigated of network visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like so force uh
they have inbuilt capabilities of
identifying uh ours op spoofing attacks
and mitigate them in the first place in
the next question we're going to discuss
what is
ransomware now ransomware is a type of
malware that blocks victims to access
personal files and demands Ransom to
regain access there are three categories
before we go into the categories let's
just revisit what ransomware is let's
start with the word malware malware is a
malicious software that poses as a
legitimate software but has a payload
that will have a security impact on your
machine so in this instance uh viruses
Trojans all of these can be classified
under malis so can Ransom w a troan is a
software that will give you a backd door
access to a to a particular device a
virus will do some destructive activity
on that device a ransomware will
basically encrypt the data of that
particular user from on that particular
machine thus rendering that that data
inaccessible to the users themselves and
in turn we'll demand a ransom to provide
access to that particular data so the
three types of ransomwares the first one
is scareware which uses social social
engineering to cause anxiety or the
perception of a threat to to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this prays on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a popup appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now the
malware will be in this software that
you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted screen lockers uh
where
locking users computers by preventing
them from logging in and displaying an
official looking message you will see a
screen saver once you boot up which
prevents you from accessing the login
page so it will not allow you to log to
your own machine but it will give you a
warning that your data has been
encrypted and you need to connect to a
particular email address and send bit
send Bitcoins over there uh to get a
decryption key to access your own data
and then the encrypting ransomware
displays a message demanding payment in
the for the private asymmetric key which
is needed to decrypt the symmetric keys
for encrypted file so once your files
have been encrypted you might just have
a blank screen in front of you where
you'll receive a warning message uh
where it instructs you to pay up a
ransom in Bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency to some particular
digital ewallet which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
then talking about the next question
what is the difference between an active
and a passive Cyber attack now when we
talk about cyber attacks Cyber attack is
activity that is caused by a malicious
user who wants to try to get access or
do some security incidents on the
victim's devices so there are two ways
that can happen it's either in an active
manner or passive manner in an active
manner the Intruder attempts to disrupt
a Network's normaly modifies data and
tries to alter the systems resources so
this is more active where the attacker
will proactively uh try to destroy the
network so that Communications fail or
they might try to modify the data where
using a ransom where they can encrypt it
or they might delete that data using a
virus or steal that data using a troan
or they might even alter the data so
that it is no longer trustworthy whereas
in a passive attack the Intruder
intercepts data traveling through a
network here the Intruder EES drop but
does not modify the message so they're
just listening in they're just observing
what is going on they're not
manipulating the data they're not
stealing anything it's just that they
are monitoring the activity that's going
on then the next question what is a
social engineering attack now social
engineering attack is a people-based
attack the victim here is the Human by
itself the vulnerability also lies in
the human it may be executed through a
computer but end of the day the Gil is
of the human so it is the art of
manipulating people so that they end up
giving up confidential information now
we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated the passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out right because they shared
the OTP with someone or they shared a
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share this kind
of personal information
to unknown people that is where the
social engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information now there are
three categories in this attack one the
first one is a fishing attack second is
a spear fishing attack and a third is a
veiling attack now fishing attack is
basically a generic attack it is
targeted To The World At Large whoever
Falls pre to that attack will be a
victim whereas a spear fishing attack is
a targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into spear
fishing where you analyze the victim you
try to figure out what their
vulnerabilities are and you tailor make
or you customize the attack to that
particular vulnerability once you have
that attack you launch it against those
people those people will then fall prey
to this attack and a veiling attack is
where you're attacking
uh top level Executives so the sea level
Executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people uh so any of these
people when they're attacked it will be
known as a veiling attack next question
what is man in the- Middle attack now
this is something that we had touched
base when we talked about ARP where the
ARP poisoning attack needs to be
executed to leverage a man in the middle
attack now in the man in the middle
attack the attacker attacking comp takes
the IP address of the client unaware of
this the server continues to communicate
with the attacker now if you remember in
a previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario uh
attacker has spoofed their IP address to
replicate themselves as a genuine client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either through a r poisoning
attack or just because of the spoofed IP
address become a man in the middle that
means that they are now e dropping on
the conversation between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now a go between between
the client and the server and can EAS
drop and can copy the data if they want
they can modify the data as well so as
as you can see on the screen the
attacker becomes man in the middle which
means that they are now EES dropping on
the conversation that is happening
between the client and the server the
next question who are blackhead hackers
and whad hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a blackhead
hacker and a whad hacker now a blackhead
hackers are skilled individuals who
illegally hack into a system the motive
behind such an attack is mostly for
monetary gain these individuals are
known also known as security crackers
now if you look at your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the a matter of
disruption the main thing thing that
blackhead hackers lack is authorization
they are not authorized to do the
activity that they are about to do and
they're going to get unauthorized access
to devices or to data which is going to
cause losses to the organization
involved whereas on the other side a
whad hacker are are also known as
ethical hackers these are the
individuals who discover vulnerabilities
in a computer
network and they help the organizations
mitigate these vulnerabilities they help
the organizations defend themselves from
black hat hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so blackhe hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack from by finding out V abilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whad hackers
will be hired by organizations they will
be provide authorization for certain
activity that the white hacker can do to
find out those vulnerabilities once
those vulnerabilities have been find out
found out by the whad hacker they will
report it to the management and guide
them in implementing security controls
to mitigate those vulnerabilities the
main difference between a black hat and
a white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are honey
pots now honey pots are a very
interesting device that can be
introduced in a network uh these
basically are decoy servers that are
implemented in a network to attract the
attention of a attacker it is there to
lure an attacker uh into attacking that
particular device thus creating a
security blanket blanket for the rest of
the devices so if an attacker has been
able to bypass a firewall and is now
trying to scan a particular Network when
they Scan they will come across various
devices that are there in the network
they will then proceed to do a avability
scan on these devices the honey poot at
that point in time will provide as an or
prove as an attraction to these
attackers because it will demonstrate
some vulnerabilities to the hacker which
will divert their attention so these
vulnerabilities are simulated on these
devices these actually do not exist but
the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the honey poot the
honey poot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the warn
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the honey pod of what activi is
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server uh that
will showcase or simulate some Vol
abilities to an attacker thus to lure
them and Safeguard the rest of the
network these are the 10 questions for
cyber security in the next video we'll
be talking about cryptography the first
question Define cryptography encryption
and decryption now cryptography
is used by Security Professionals to
scramble data into non-readable format
uh which is used in securing that
information so it involves converting
data from a readable format into a
non-readable format and then reversing
it back to readable format again for
example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like a unreadable
format now if you look at this word that
it has been scrambled into it would be
very difficult for a human to figure out
what the actual word was now in this
scenario we have taken an algorithm
where we have made a shift of the
alphabet where we have added two
alphabets to the current one so C + 2
becomes e o + 2 becomes q m + 2 becomes
o so we have done a shift of two and
thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphabet + two so any
person who who figures that out will be
able to unscramble this and convert this
back into readable text the fact of
scrambling a readable text Data into
something that is unreadable by using a
particular key is What cryptography is
all about now as we discussed the
decryption again is replacing the
alphabet and taking it further back by
two characters so e - 2 becomes c q - 2
becomes o o - 2 becomes m and so on so
forth so anybody who knows this key u
the shift
key anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if I want to utilize alphabet +
5 then the spacing the shifting of that
character will be the fifth character
from that particular character and so on
so
forth the next question what is the
difference between Cipher text and clear
text Cipher text refers to the text
which is encrypted and totally unded
F the message received after decryption
is known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it is what it is intended to be
however if the moment we encrypt it that
means we scramble it into unreadable
text by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at that text is known
as a cipher text and without the key
this becomes unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we using the
English language in this instance so the
plain word computer is the clear text
once we add the encryption layer to it
uh we get the cipher text to
it moving on to the next question what
is a block Cipher this refers to the
method of encrypting the plain message
block by block the plane message is
broken down into fixed size blocks and
then encrypted now a block Cipher is
normally used used for data that is
stored so a data that is stored on a
hard disk and we want to encrypt that
data that is known as block encryption
or a block Cipher so a block Cipher is
an algorithm that will allow you to
encrypt data that is stored onto a hard
disk so in this example we've got plain
text which is 64 bits in size and we
have added a layer of encryption to it
so plain text plus the key that we have
studied in the previous questions and
then The Scrambled data out of it which
is unreadable and thus encrypted then
the next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptography Keys public and private so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques which are standardized in
nature and are globally accepted which
allow us to use digital certificates to
encrypt data
and decrypt the data at the other end we
use a symmetric encryption over here
which means that we are used two keys
one is a public key to encrypt and the
private key to
decrypt the other part of encryption is
a symmetric encryption where the same
key is used to encrypt and the same key
is used to
decrypt now in a public key
infrastructure uh like I said we have
standardize that so in in the
standardizing part of it these are the
various players that have been defined
in the public key infr structure the
first is this user or the sender in the
scenario the one who requires this
digital signature to digitally sign a
particular transaction or a
communication a registration Authority
with whom they're going to register for
that particular key the certification
Authority who issues that key the
verification Authority who validates the
uh key itself and the recipient who's
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized a sender or the user who
requires this digital signature will
request or apply for a digital signature
with the registration Authority the
registration Authority would validate
the genuinity of the user so they might
do some uh identity verification or uh
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the person
and they have validated the information
they will then send the request to the
certification Authority stating that the
sender has been validated
and we can and the certification
Authority can issue the digital
certificate to the particular
user they will send the public key to
the sender which will be utilized by the
sender for a further transactions so
when the sender is going to sign some
data and uh wants to send it across to
the recipient they will use the public
key to sign it and send it across the
recipient will then validate with the
verification authority to see if the
data the sign data is correct or or not
now while the certification Authority
sends the public key to the sender the
certification Authority updates the
private key with the verification
Authority so whatever is signed by the
uh sender uh received by the recipient
and they want to validate it they will
send it back to the verification
Authority the verification Authority
will validate using the private key once
the private key is validated it will
then send the okay signal back to the
recipient does allowing the validation
of that particular
transaction if the signature is tampered
with or is not the verification
Authority is not able to validate the
signature it will then send a denial
message back to the recipient and the
transaction will not go through so the
pki enables trusted digital identities
for people so the pki grants secure
access to digital resources based on the
infrastructure that has been created and
the core of the pki is a certification
Authority which ensures that the
trustworthiness of the Digital Data is
is ensured so going back to the previous
slide these are the key players that
have been standardized in the uh public
key infrastructure the certification
Authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
Authority is the one who validates that
uh digital certificate moving on what is
RSA RSA is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for R Shamir
and Adelman now these are the three
people who have created this algorithm
Rond reest adish Shamir and Leonard
Edelman who are the inventors of this
technique it is a asymmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private Keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas
asymmetic cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to RSA now RSA is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized uh
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what RSA is it stands for
uh R Shamir and AD the three creators of
that particular algorithm but there are
a lot of alternatives to this algorithm
depending on how secure you want that
data to be and some of them are listed
here on your screen Duo security OCTA
Google Authenticator and last pass last
pass is a password
manager so is Duo security Google
authentica is something that we all
utilize it is an application that we can
download and store on our mobile devices
and we can set that up to authenticate
ourselves with certain portals so it
issues a unique ID to us which once
utilized will allow us access to those
particular portals OCTA is an identity
manager where you have you have created
different digital identities and you
have assigned them certain permissions
and based on your authentication
mechanisms OCTA will allow or disallow
access to those different applications
or different portals as you have
configured it so all four are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to RSA
if getting your learning started is half
the best ble what if you could do that
for free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more next question what are the
prime objectives of modern cryptography
and this is a very important question
because we've we've so far looked at
what cryptography is and what public
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to uh
gain out of it so the main and the prime
objectives of modern cryptography are uh
as follows uh mentioned mention on your
screen the first one is
confidentiality the second one is
non-repudiation third one is
authenticity and the fourth one is
integrity now if I go back to the first
one confidentiality uh that is where I
want to uh keep data confidential that
means it will only be visible to the
authorized users right so here I have
created a list of people who have deemed
as authorized users and have created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is ensured so uh
when we want to keep data confidential
we create a list of users who we are
going to allow access to certain
resources and we are going to Define
what access controls are to be utilized
what access are allowed whether they got
an administrative access or user level
access and only those authorized users
are going to be uh able to access this
resources that is how we maintain
confidentiality the next one is nonre
reputation non- reputation is the
prevention of denial of having being a
part of that particular transaction so
in the public key infrastructure that we
discussed where a digital signature was
utilized to sign a particular
transaction and then sent to the
recipient the sender would not be able
to deny of having gen originated that
transaction because it was using their
digital certificate th non- reputation
comes into the picture uh one more
example that we can have here is uh on
our mobile phones when we use SMS short
messaging service and we send a message
to uh to another person the person when
they receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator and
thus the sender cannot uh deny having
sent that message the sender at the same
time can have a delivery report sent to
them uh from that the message was
delivered to the inbox of the recipient
and thus if the recipient denies having
received that message that delivery
report becomes proof of having uh that
message being delivered to their inbox
thus both the parties cannot deny of
have a of being a part of that
particular
transaction then comes the part of
authenticity now in confidentiality we
have created a digital identity assigned
it to a particular person and we have
given them digital signatures where they
cannot deny having being a part of that
transaction but authenticity is the part
where they try to prove that they are
who they claim to be so if I'm claiming
a digital identity I have to prove that
I am that person who I'm Who I'm trying
to claim to be and an example do that is
when we go to our gmail.com websites it
first asks us what is our username our
username is normally our email address
which identifies the account that we are
trying to access right so this account
is confidential because it is only
authorized for a particular person and
once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address that's
when the authentication part comes into
the picture where it asks for the
password now it has never ever happened
that we just go on to the gmail.com type
in a password and then it figures out
which account we are talking about so
the first step is always the
confidentiality part where we identify
which account we are talking about and
then we try to authenticate as the owner
of that particular account by providing
the appropriate password to that account
if both of these match only then do we
get access to that account and we are
able to make uh whatever transactions we
want to make now when we are making
those transactions non reputation comes
into the place where all our activities
also being logged so we have identified
our account we have authenticated
ourselves by providing the password so
the proof is there that it is us who are
trying to access it and then whatever
activity we do send an email receive an
email delete something attach something
all of those activities are logged and
stored as proof of what actions have
been done so tomorrow if we deny having
sent that email gmail can still prove to
us through those logs that the that that
activity was done by
us and the fourth part is in Integrity
which ensures that the data received and
sent and the re uh sent by the sender
and received by the recipient has not
been modified while in uh motion so the
Integrity part is the trustworthiness of
that data that the data has not been
modified by any hacker or any other uh
entity and is still trustworthy
so these are the four Prime objectives
of modern cryptography once I have
scrambled that data
using my public signature it is only my
private signature that is going to
decrypt it right uh using these
mechanisms I will be able to achieve all
these four aspects of cryptography and
security next question what is safer now
safer stands for secure and fast
encryption routine which is also a block
Cipher as we have discussed pre
previously block Cipher is a cipher that
is used to encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and bite
oriented algorithm uh safer encryption
and decryption procedures are highly
secure this technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment card
so when you're using your a digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you have gone onto an online
portal you want to purchase a particular
item and then it takes you to another
payment Gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your uh
expiry dates CVV information and then
the OTP or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on PCI DSS which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards ensure that
certain Protocols are utilized to attain
that level of security safer is one of
those block ciphers that is used under
the digital payment Gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work now we have already
discussed this in the previous diagrams
uh we have identified the key players
the certification Authority the
registration Authority the end user who
requires the digital certificate the
validation Authority who's going to
validate it and then the recipient the
end user with whom the transaction is
going to be uh conducted so the first
point here is uh the request for the
digital certificate is sent to the
registration Authority they validate it
and then they okay to the certification
Authority who then process the request
and the digital certificate is issued to
the person who has requested it so when
the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that uh digital
certificate to sign that transaction
with the end user the end user validates
that with the validation Authority and
once validated the transaction goes
through and now the last question what
is the Blowfish algorithm it is a 64-bit
symmetric encryption algorithm so this
is an algorithm that uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret Keys used to encrypt and
decrypt the messages here the operations
are based on exclusive ORS and additions
to on 32-bit words the key has a maximum
length of 448 bits now this is a little
bit technical uh you might not want to
go this technical in an uh in an
interview question you just need to
identify what the algorithm is used for
so whether it is a symmetric algorithm
which means it uses the same key or uh a
a symmetric algorithm where it uses a
public key to encrypt and a p private
key to decrypt uh thus the Blowfish
algorithm is just one more algorithm
which uses symmetric encryption to
encrypt and decrypt data algorithms that
we have seen RSA and the others that we
have discussed as far as the interview
questions are concerned what we need to
remember is uh which algorithms are
symmetric which algorithms are
asymmetric what do symmetric algorithms
do and what do un symmetric a symmetric
algorithms do and we also look at block
ciphers and stream ciphers block ciphers
are utilized to encrypt data that is
stored stationary data data at rest and
stream ciphers are utilized for data in
motion while they're being streamed so
SSL and TLS is another algorithm that
comes into the picture when we looking
at streaming data so that wraps up our
full course on cyber security for 20123
we hope you had a lot to learn and will
be on the lookout for any suggestions or
doubts in the comments section below so
if you have any queries you know what to
do thank you so much for tuning in today
and happy
learning hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here